tell accommodation as a temporary
solution until settled accommodation
could be found
disinsured that all Afghans have been
housed in safe and secure accommodation
from the moment they arrived it gave our
Afghan friends peace of mind and allowed
us to move quickly during an emergency
however bridging hotels are not and were
never designed to be a permanent
solution
while dedicated teams across Central and
local government as well as partners in
the voluntary and Community sector have
ensured that over 9 000 Afghans have
been supported into settled homes around
8 000 remain in hotel accommodation
around half of this cohorted children
and around half have been living in a
hotel for more than a year
my colleagues have indicated that this
is an unacceptable and unsustainable
situation the government shares that
view I personally share that view and it
needs to change
long-term residency in hotels has
present prevented some Afghans from
properly putting down routes committing
to employment integrating into
communities and creating uncertainty as
they look to rebuild their lives in the
United Kingdom long term
beyond the human cost the financial
costs to the UK taxpayer of Hotel
accommodation for the Afghan cohort is
also now standing at a million pounds a
day
like I've said this needs to change
to help people rebuild their lives here
we have a duty to end this practice of
Afghan families living in hotels in the
UK this is in the best interest of
families and individuals and will enable
them to benefit from the security of
Housing and long-term consistency of
Public Services this includes schooling
and the freedoms of independent living
that only suitable non-hotel
accommodation can provide
that is why with the support of my right
honorable friends the member for Newark
and sorry Heath I'm today announcing the
government's intention to step up our
support to help resettled and relocated
Afghans access independent settled
accommodation and end the use of Hotel
bridging accommodation for this cohort
we will begin writing to individuals and
families accommodated in Afghan bridging
hotels at the end of April and they will
be provided with at least three months
notice about when their access to
bridging accommodation will end this
will crystallize a reasonable time frame
in the minds of our Afghan friends with
significant support from Central and
local government at every step as
required together with their existing
access to welfare and the right to work
to find good settled places to live in
the longer term
we remain unbowed in our commitment to
those who supported us at Great personal
risk in Afghanistan and the debt we owe
them is one born by our nation as a
whole
we also need to support those people who
are brought to the UK as genuine
refugees fleeing persecution
the UK has and always will provide safe
Refuge to those who arrive through safe
and legal routes there are veterans
across this country enjoying normal
lives today because of the service and
sacrifice of this cohort in keeping them
safe in Afghanistan it is a national
Duty that we have in communities up and
down this country that is why the
government is taking significant steps
to honor and protect this group by
providing increased support and funding
to facilitate the transition into
long-term settled accommodation
trained staff including home office
liaison officers DWP work coaches
Council staff and Charities will be
based in hotels regularly to provide
advice to Afghans including information
on how to rent in the private sector
help to find jobs and English language
training in addition we will publish
guidance for families on what support is
available and how to access it
we are announcing 35 million pounds of
new funding to enable local authorities
to provide increased support for Afghan
households to move from hotels into
settled accommodation across England the
local Authority housing fund will also
be expanded by 250 million pounds with a
majority of the additional funding being
used to house Afghans currently in
bridging accommodation and the rest used
to ease existing homelessness pressures
these measures represent a generous
offer and in return for this we do
expect families to help themselves
whilst this government realizes our
significant responsibilities to this
cohort there is a responsibility upon
this group to take the opportunities
that are offered under these schemes and
integrate into UK Society
wear an offer of accommodation can be
made and is turned down another will now
not be forthcoming
at a time when there are many pressures
on the taxpayer and the housing market
it is not right that people can choose
to stay in hotels when are the perfectly
suitable accommodation is available
we are balancing difficult competing
responsibilities including to the UK
taxpayer
as well as ensuring that Afghans already
in the UK can move into long-term
accommodation we will also continue to
honor the commitments we have made to
bring people into the UK into
sustainable non-hotel accommodation that
includes British Council and guard well
contractors and achievement alumni offer
places under the pathway 3 of the acrs
scheme and refugees who are referred to
us by unhcr through pathway 2.
well forgiving welcoming people who come
to the UK who safe and legal Roots has
always been and will always be a vital
way in which the UK helps those in need
we are legislating to enshrine our
commitment to safe and legal routes in
the illegal migration bill but the use
of hotels to accommodate families for
lengthy period of time in the UK is not
sustainable or indeed appropriate for
anybody
have a responsibility is not working as
we would like at the moment
we will continue we will honor our
commitment to those who remain in
Afghanistan
our priority is to ensure they can enter
suitable accommodation which is the
right thing for these families future UK
arrivals will go directly into
appropriate accommodation rather than
costly temporary hotel accommodation
this is the right thing to do to ensure
that those to whom we have made
commitments are supported and that they
are able to successfully reintegrate
into life in the UK
we will provide more detail in due
course on plans for supporting people
yet to arrive into suitable and
appropriate accommodation
but what we are setting out today is the
fair and right thing to do for both
Afghan communities to rebuild their
lives here and for the British public
who continues to show enormous
generosity towards those who come here
safely and legally this government will
realize our commitments to the people of
Afghanistan and I commend the statement
to the house Channel Secretary of State
John Healy
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank the
minister for the advanced copy of his
statement
he himself means well but this speak
this statement should be the defense
secretary explaining why 18 months after
Afghan families were airlifted to the UK
8 000 are still in temporary hotels and
the backlog in processing cases has
risen to 66
000. this should be the Home Secretary
explaining why it took nine months to
open the alternative acrs scheme and why
by the end of last year just four people
had been brought to Safety in the UK
since the fall of Kabul
this should have been the housing and
local government secretary explaining
why he's not required all Council areas
to play a part in discharging the
national obligation we owe to these
Afghans and their families we could have
built the homes they need since we
airlifted in that amazing operation
pitting our our Armed Forces airlifted
them from Kabul to Safety in the UK in
August 2021.
this nation as the minister said
promise those who put their lives at
risk to serve alongside our armed forces
in Afghanistan that we would relocate
them we would settle them we would give
their families safety we would help them
rebuild their lives
and this obligation is felt most
fiercely by those who served in our
forces in Afghanistan whose operations
depended on the courageous Afghan
interpreters and guides
never mind operation warm welcome never
mind the warm words from the minister
today he's confirmed the government has
given them the cold shoulder
he's serving eviction notices
on 8 000 Afghans half of whom are
children
with no guarantee they'll be offered a
suitable settled place to live
and that's Mr Speaker nail a myth at the
heart of this statement he said that the
house today it's not right that people
can choose to stay in hotels with other
perfectly suitable accommodation is
available
well the government's website
confirms at the end of last month the
number of Afghan households who had
refused accommodation offers was just
258.
they want homes not hotels they want to
rebuild their lives they want to
contribute to this country the new
country that has offered them this
Refuge
Mr Speaker the government failed to plan
for an orderly withdrawal from
Afghanistan in the 18 months following
the Doha agreement in February 2020.
ministers only set up the Arab scheme in
April 2021 they only relocated 200
afghans
before the fall of Kabul in August 2021.
the government has failed the brave
Afghans who supported our troops before
the fall of Afghanistan and it has
failed them since so can we now fill in
the many gaps in the minister statement
to date
how many Arab applicants and how many
acrs applicants have been re-housed into
permanent homes
what is the current backlog in
processing Arab cases and acrs cases
how many Arab eligible applicants remain
in Afghanistan
why have there been no flights
carrying Arab eligible Afghans and their
families from Pakistan since November
have there been any more Arab data
breaches since the one in February 2022
many hotels are still in use as
temporary bridging accommodation for
these Afghan families
what consultation has there been with
local authorities to identify the
thousands of permanent homes still
needed
still in hotels
be given notice to quit only when a
permanent home has been identified for
them
how will decisions on eviction deadlines
for individual hotels be determined who
will make these decisions
and will the minister guarantee today
that none of these Afghans will be made
homeless as a result of being moved on
from the hotels in which they currently
live
Mr Speaker Arab and acrs have been beset
by failures
those inferior their lives left in
Afghanistan housing promises broken
processing staff cut
ballooning backlogs
breaches of personal data and even the
mod even the mod
saying to saying to applicants they get
should get the Taliban to verify their
Arab application documents far from
being as the minister has said Fair
and right this record
and this statement shame us all
right thank you Mr Speaker and I'll
address uh some of those points uh in
turn and look I'm not going to stand
here and uh defend the system uh as it
currently is I've said what I've said
previously about it that's not what I've
sought to do today I've been very clear
today in what I'm trying to do is
identify a path forward in what is an
unprecedented and a very difficult
situation and that's what I'll focus on
uh in my remarks when it comes to giving
Afghans in this country a Cold Shot I'd
say it was a pretty expensive cold
shoulder if you're looking at 285
million pounds worth of new funding
that's been announced uh today uh in
terms of the number of people who've
turned down homes there is a significant
proportion and he mentions 258 homes uh
it's higher than that now there is a
significant proportion of Afghans who
have turned down homes and uh it would
not be right to ignore that problem and
to allow Afghans to remain in hotels
paid for food and accommodation uh
families and uh and so on um add
infinitum for the next 20 years that
would not be right and I won't I'm
afraid be cowed into accepting that it
is when it comes to numbers
um all these uh numbers are publicly
available
um look we reckon there's about 4 300
entitled Personnel uh who remain in
Afghanistan who want to get over here
we've had 12 100 uh who've arrived to
date uh on the arap scheme on the acrs
scheme we've promised twenty thousand
okay we've had
7637 uh who've arrived through that at
the moment and look past three different
Pathways for that and I'm happy to speak
to colleagues in here or elsewhere about
what they are and clearly I I accept
that some of those Pathways have not
been running as we would like but that
is precisely why I'm here because if we
cannot uh move these people out of
hotels which is unsuitable for them and
unsuitable for the UK communities and
unsuitable for the UK taxpayers we
cannot extract people who are entitled
to be in this country issue because of
the sacrifices they made during
operation Afghanistan as I'm afraid
whilst this is a very difficult policy
area we are not going to yield in doing
the right thing and trying to tackle
very difficult problems and balances
between making sure that we make it as
easy and as seamless as possible for
Afghans to get out of hotels and into
integrate into the United Kingdom Hotel
whilst at the same time making sure that
the Afghan cohort understand the offer
never was to remain in hotels uh add
infinitum and all the problems that
brings with it so look I accept this as
a different difficult policy area I
accept that there's uh the track record
on this policy area
um you know has has been difficult and
to be fair to everybody who has done
this before this is an incredibly
difficult unprecedented Dynamic
situation that we are facing with the
collapse of international will to remain
in Afghanistan we are now doing our best
to see through our strategic Promises to
the people of Afghanistan we are
absolutely going to do that and we will
strain every sinew to get these people
out of hotels get them into the UK
community and the wealth of Veteran and
volunteer support who I know want to
welcome these people with open arms uh
is is Unleashed to make these people
feel part of the UK and I look forward
to that challenge
John Barron thank you Mr Speaker I again
commend the Prime Minister for his
recent direct intervention to break the
acrs Log Jam by allowing British Council
contractors and others to continue their
applications of the safety of a third
country thereby allowing them to leave
Afghanistan where they were in fear of
their lives
however
there are remain a significant number of
approved contractors in Afghanistan
unable to obtain and or afford the
necessary visa and paperwork to exit
Afghanistan and enter the safety of a
third country
can the minister therefore tell the
house how he is working with colleagues
across government to help remove these
obstacles
many contributions on or on this piece
of work
the ACs ACR scheme uh pathway that he
refers to you can now apply to that from
a third country uh and uh like I said at
the beginning we have made commitments
to this cohort of people we need to make
sure you know one of the one of the
driving
motivations behind this difficult piece
of work is that we have people stuck in
Afghanistan who we have a duty to get
over here and we simply cannot do that
if we're just going to continue to load
these hotels continue to build pressure
in our local communities uh at a huge
cost for the taxpayer that is one of the
primary motivations in the moral case
for what we're doing today because we
still have a duty to people who serve
we've made these commitments and I'm
absolutely determined and this prime
minister is absolutely determined that
we will fulfill those commitments to
people of Afghanistan and this is the
start of that process today
we come to our 70s spokesperson Alison
thulis thank you very much Mr Speaker
and I think the minister for coming with
this statement uh today on these benches
we are absolutely clear that hotel
accommodation is not appropriate
particularly for families but also
because of the tragic Park and incident
that happened in Glasgow we know the
consequences of people being kept in
situations where they were under severe
stress so can I ask the minister a
number of questions on the back of his
statement it's not clear in here if
there is any specific funding coming to
Scotland as part of what was mentioned
here England is specified Scotland is
not what communication has he had with
the Scottish government and with kosler
on the issue in Scotland because it
would also be useful to know exactly the
numbers in Scotland at the moment STV um
did an FY request last year and said
there was 300 people in bridging hotels
across Scotland I'm not clear from what
he said today what the current numbers
are where and where those people are
actually living this present time
and who will be picking up those those
pieces uh what he said about offers
being made and turned down and another
office not offer not being forthcoming
concerns me because under Scottish
housing legislation uh a reasonable
offer of accommodation is referred to
and that reasonable offer is quite
important because the accommodation
being offered might not be appropriate
for a family it might be overcrowding a
family because we know that there's a
shortage of larger family homes the
accommodation may be far away from
schools where the children are currently
being educated and might be away from
the community support that Afghan groups
value so much it might be far away from
mosques and access to shops that have
that sell halal meat for example so a
reasonable offer rather than just an
offer being rejected and that's all
you're getting it seems to me a quite a
worry if that's the road that the
government are going to go down
um because it will also if these people
are made homeless it will be local
authorities and it will be Charities who
pick up the pieces if people are put out
on the streets particularly as I say
families who will be at risk but other
people will also be put at risk if they
are made homeless
to turn into the reference me to um
unhcdr pathway two this pathway and to
describe it as being deficient would be
the understatement of the year only 22
people brought on brought in under uh
the uh unhcr Pathway to so far I have
many cases that I've dealt with as a
result of this uh this deficiency of the
government I think people at my surgery
who have made expressions of interest
and they have heard nothing back they
cannot be waiting indefinitely in a
situation in Afghanistan where they are
unsafe people are moving about to avoid
persecution to avoid the Taliban finding
them and is incredibly dangerous for
those people that are left there when
Afghanistan felt I had around 80 cases
of families who talk in Afghanistan I
only know of two who managed to get um
to Scotland to safety people cannot wait
in danger indefinitely so can you tell
me when the cases have currently made up
expressions of Interest under this
pathway when they will be processed and
when they will arrive at home in
Scotland
thank you very much Mr Speaker and if I
can take those in in two broad handfuls
if I can talk about funding first
funding for round two of the local
Authority housing fund is coming from
existing d-lock housing under spends and
that funding is devolved which has
already gone through the barn at formula
when it comes to the 35 million pounds
putting into casework teams across the
country uh that is UK wide and we will
be deploying casework teams into hotels
and Scotland to work with local
authorities to make sure that we uh uh
we we support Afghans out of hotels in
Scotland into the community but what I
would just say on this issue around
balance and a fair and reasonable offer
uh nobody there's nobody in this
government wants to make any of these
individuals uh homeless not to have a
home right the truth is we are going to
have to balance very difficult competing
priorities where individuals have been
in hotels for a long period of time
maybe in school uh maybe have specific
Health needs and a suitable offer will
be made elsewhere in the country but
they don't want to leave that location
education we will do everything we can
to make sure that they can stay where
they have these local routes and so on
but that has to be balanced off about if
there is a choice between them staying
in a hotel in that area and going to
suitable accommodation I'm afraid the
priorities to get them into suitable
accommodation so the idea that this you
know I I recognize how this is going to
be slated and tailored and all the rest
of it the truth is we you know we are
going to do everything we possibly can
to take into account all those specific
circumstances the ambition is that
nobody is homeless uh throughout this
process but we are going to implement
our commitments to people of Afghanistan
and I don't make any bones about it
that's an easy thing to do uh but we we
are gonna uh through everything we've
got at it uh integrate these people into
UK Society turn back on the flights and
make sure we see through our duties to
the people of Afghanistan
who are you standing
my questions already been answered
around administrations thank you thank
you very much James sanderlin Mr Speaker
I thank the minister for his statement
does he agree with me that is entirely
right that we do all we can to support
those who serve alongside British forces
in Afghanistan and that it is right in
law to distinguish between those you
come here illegally and those who come
here by invitation legally so that we
can then do more for those on the Arab
scheme
look my old friend's absolutely right
and there is a fundamental difference
between those who we have a duty because
as I said to him and he will know there
are veterans and service personnel and
people working in the Civil Service who
have sat around lunchtime tables this
afternoon who would not be here were not
for the actions of this cohort and we
have a very specific duty to them uh we
have to balance that against competing
demands but we have made our commitments
to this cohort of people
um and like I've said what I've outlined
today uh our lines are very clear and
significant commitment uh to make sure
that we see through our duty to them get
them out of hotels uh and make sure that
we honor our commitments
eagle
Mr Speaker the bridging hotel in my
constituency is still full
um about half of the 375 or so people
there have been there since the
evacuation one of the reasons why they
haven't been able to find alternative
accommodation or it hasn't been found
for them it's because they're they have
big there are some big families there
and there isn't suitable accommodation
what particular provision is he going to
make for those families and I've heard a
rumor that that particular hotel is to
close to the Afghans in August but I've
had no letter no communication from the
government or from any department so can
he confirm perhaps outside the chamber
when the hotel in my constituency is due
to to be closed
okay I'm more than happy to meet my
humble friend and go over the situation
in her hotel no hotel has been given uh
has been given its sort of closing
orders so you know uh these these rumors
I'm more than happy to uh challenge them
but uh um that's certainly the case uh
in that uh in that area uh in terms of
getting people out of hotels and the
flexibility of what we're doing is
increasing flexibility in how that money
can be used so uh with the new 250
million pounds coming into the local
Authority housing fund that can be used
to do things for example I was talking
to the leader of London uh this morning
uh to knock through accommodations
create bigger uh accommodation because
we have this specific challenge of
massive families in this cohort and
finding a family for uh you know a house
for a family of tent is extremely
difficult in the UK so yes we have
introduced flexibility in that space to
make sure that it can be used for
improvements for example to knock
through into the house next door
whatever it may be so that we can see
through our commitments to these people
Mr Deputy speaker I have been very proud
of the welcome that the cities of London
and Westminster have provided Afghan
refugees as they have two refugees
um across the world for many many
centuries
um when I visited two of the hotels in
the city of London that were I'm home to
uh Refugee afghanisters last year I was
taken aback by the warmth that the hotel
staff provided and the corporation of
London working with Charities providing
English lessons in the Guild Hall
that's why I write Uncle friend agree
with me that actually having seen what
how people were living in these hotel
rooms often five six seven members of
family in one room it is important that
they are helped to move on to permanent
accommodation Nick I I think my own
boyfriend for a question she's
absolutely right the easiest thing uh
the easiest thing in the world is sort
of her
um accusations of this policy the
reality is if you go and look at it you
will see that you will see lots of
people living in the same rooms
um and uh children and families in
accommodation that is unsuitable for a
prolonged period of time uh and so I I
make no apology at all for the moral
case of uh of helping these people move
into permanent accommodation
um when it comes to what people have
done look I pay a huge tribute to all
those in local authorities up and down
this country not only in local
authorities but in voluntary groups as
well and in the veteran sector as well
who have bent over backwards to try and
welcome these people into their
communities and all I'm seeking to do
with this piece of work the prime
ministers asked me to pull together is
harness all that energy right and make
it work for the Afghan people so that
all this good offer all these offers
whether it's around employment whether
it's around Community groups a harnessed
and we can actually take take the action
to move these people out of hotels it is
the right thing to do for the Afghan
people it's the right thing to do for
the British people uh and I'm determined
that we'll see it through Jessica Morden
thank you Mr Deputy speaker on Friday I
met with an Afghan interpreter who'd
collected a list of 45 colleagues who
put their lives on the line for our
forces who are still waiting for the
government schemes to deliver many in UK
stores to accommodation in Pakistan
waiting for entry clearance visas for
the home office for 18 months he also
told of those who found it quicker to
resort to the treacherous and dangerous
small boats Journeys rather than waiting
for this government to deliver how can
ministers stand here and defend This
Record
Minister look I just say it's my old
friend this has been incredibly Dynamic
and uh difficult situation over 18
months we now have this plan to go
forward
um you know anybody can apply to acrs or
to the Arab program from third countries
and that's what I expect people to do
thank you Paul thank you Mr Speaker our
hotel is not a home and it is important
to find permanent accommodation for
these families so can I thank my right
honorable thankful his statement today
we also mustn't get a terrible plight of
the people in Afghanistan especially
women and girls 553 days now since women
were gut banned for since girls were
banned from going to school women are
banned from leaving their homes in the
meantime senior Taliban members are
sending their own daughters to school in
other countries so will my right
honorable friend work with ministers in
the fcdo to tighten the knot of
international sanctions and travel bans
on the taliba
look uh I've got a very clear remit in
this space and that that is to deal with
Afghans who are in hotels and get this
pathway opened up clearly we want to see
through our responsibilities uh no you
know whatever's happened in Afghanistan
is for the fcdo to comment I mean uh
Everybody Knows My Views uh which remain
unchanged we now need to deal the
challenges we find it now which is far
too many people in hotels and the
blocking up of that pathway that we are
determined to make sure is a
professional clear pipeline that people
can get out of Afghanistan into the UK
where we owe them a duty
Dan Jarvis thank you Mr Deputy speaker
the minister well understands the deep
bond of friendship that exists between
those who served and the Afghans we
fought alongside but I know that you'll
also recognize that there have been very
long-standing concerns from members on
both sides of the house about the
processes that underpin both Arab and
acrs now Mr Deputy speaker I've recently
received reports of families who are
approved under arap who are stuck in
Islamabad and are now being told that
they're going to have to Source their
own accommodation in order to be able to
get here now the focus of the statement
from the minister so far has been around
Afghans who are already here in the
country so can I ask him to say a bit
more around the process for future
arrivals and in particular can he give
an assurance that no one who's currently
in Afghanistan or Pakistan who's either
accepted or eligible for Arab won't be
disadvantaged as a consequence of the
policy announcement being made today so
nobody who is in Afghanistan who's
accepted or eligible for our operation
RSP disadvantages as a result of what
we're doing today
um in terms of what's going on in
Pakistan clearly the the situation in
Afghanistan I saw in Pakistan where we
have over a thousand people uh in hotels
waiting to get to the UK is clearly and
demonstrably unacceptable the challenge
is we cannot do anything about that if
we have people in hotels in in this
country uh who are um who have been
offered accommodation who
um you know who should have taken that
accommodation and are still residing in
hotels
um allow not allowing us to unblock that
uh that that pipeline what I'd say to
one of a friend is he knows my
commitment on this issue I want to work
with everybody on all sides of the house
this is not I know this government's
made commitments to this but this is not
a sort of uh inter-party political issue
okay this is the nation's duty to this
cohort of Afghans who kept a lot of our
constituents alive during the fight in
Afghanistan
um and I'd urge all colleagues to work
together to make sure that we can build
that Pipeline and honor our commitments
to the people of that country well it
might be Croft thank you Mr Deputy
speaker we certainly do a huge debt of
gratitude to those Brave Afghans who
helped our armed forces and stood up for
the values that we believe in and I
won't be alone in the house and
remembering cases and individuals and
families that my office helped
um my honorable friend is passionate
about this and he's an expert and
frankly his word is good enough for me
on this is he absolutely reassured that
this is the right one to do
I have I have no doubts writing to you
otherwise wouldn't be studied today I
think that uh it's an incredibly
difficult policy area Okay so nothing is
black and white there is no zero-sum
calculation here where everything we do
is going to sort this out and and there
is no zero risk option here right but
that that is not good enough to to not
try and see through our commitments to a
very difficult population I keep hearing
you know 18 months throwing at me from
the other side of the room this this has
been an unprecedented situation and
nobody wanted these people to stay in
hotels for over a year uh we uh clearly
have opened up these Pathways uh we want
to make sure that these people integrate
into uh UK Society properly and I'm
absolutely convinced it's the right
thing to do
16 people standing all thereabouts if we
can have shorter questions and shorter
answers if we may Minister minira Wilson
thank you Mr Speaker the minister said
at least three times in a statement that
we will honor our commitment to those
who remain in danger in Afghanistan well
whilst that may be true for him
personally I'm afraid as far as this
government goes that promise is utterly
Hollow and I challenge him to come to my
surgery and look the Afghan families
whose families have been left behind in
the eye and say that and in particular
three weeks in a row in this chamber I
have now raised the case of five British
children under the age of 18 who have
been abandoned in hiding in Kabul their
mother is an Afghan National there is no
safe and legal route for her to apply
for the British father was blown up with
by the Taliban when will the next around
of the atrs open up or will he admit
they've just given up on them
okay so I thought I think uh my presence
is there indicates that we clearly have
not given up on these people it's
incredibly difficult to get people out
of Afghanistan nobody uh nobody is happy
with what's happened uh in that country
uh we have opened up acrs and our app
applications to third sector uh sorry to
uh third countries uh and I would
encourage people uh to apply to that uh
to get themselves on the scheme and
we'll do everything we can to see
through our duty to them blunt thank you
Mr letting you've given your uh
recommendations short questions I've got
a number of questions which I will uh
table by a way of written parliamentary
question uh can I just say how much I
welcome my right honorable friend
statement and the Candor with which he
has approached it and he has asking
questions
um could I ask about one uh Amazon I
have been involved in supporting uh
someone who's trained with me uh at
Santa's very long a very long time ago
and assisting that family
um and there'll be no doubt endless
examples of other things in this same in
the same place uh I was slightly
concerned when I offered a scheme to the
Minister of Defense
um due to his successor as veterans
Minister
um about mobilizing wider support for
this particular community and uh not
least about engaged in creating creating
the social housing are referred to by
the uh uh by spokes from opposite
um and I wonder why it was then directed
during that question why it was then
directed uh that uh people who could
support this scheme were told they
couldn't do it in in uh in army time
wants to write to me I'm more than happy
to to address what has happened there
but look I've got to be honest with him
I'm not overly interested in how we got
to where we are because uh you know
there are a number of reasons it's been
an incredibly difficult situation uh the
collapse of Afghanistan has been
unprecedented in our generation uh and
seeing through our duties to these
people has been incredibly difficult I'm
not going to go over and consistently
kind of uh re-heat that argument what I
want to do now we have a clear set of
commitments we have a a significant
financial commitment to these people we
have a duty to get them out of hotels
and open up that pipeline to allow
people to come into this country and
that's what we're going to do
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and I pay
tribute the minister for his service in
Afghanistan along other members of this
house but I really really wish he had
come with me a few weeks ago to meet
Afghans living in a hotel in my
constituency because I genuinely feel he
would have felt a deep sense of Shame
and embarrassment about how this country
has not done our duty to those people
who served alongside us it's quite
frankly shocking and disgusting and I
just want to leave him with two thoughts
one many of those people in that hotel
had not had offers of accommodation at
all they told me how the officer dried
up and many of them had been languishing
there for 18 months secondly many of
them had qualifications and skills that
were not being recognized in this
country so they couldn't get work that
DWP program is clearly not working
despite the intentions behind it and I
hope you can clarify just how much
additional support Wales will get to
support those people into long-term
accommodation
so respectfully stay to my honorable
friend he has no idea
as the depth of the feeling that people
like me feel for what has happened in
Afghanistan uh what I would say is that
uh some people have turned down office
of accommodation that is a fact it's not
the majority no but it is a fact that
some have
um and I spent a lot of my time with the
Afghan Community now and I recognize
entirely their feelings I have one of
them who I got out of Kabul and now
works for me in Plymouth and lives in
Plymouth so I fully recognize that we
have to deal with the situation as we
now find it this prime minister has come
into office he very clearly recognizes
the duty we have to these people so
whatever has happened before we're going
to create these Pathways we're going to
give them every opportunity to relocate
and reintegrate into UK society and I
look forward to the whole house helping
us as we complete that endeavor
Foster thank you uh Mr Deputy speaker I
do actually welcome that my writable
friend is now doing this from the cabin
office as having seen quite close at
hand the coordinated cross-govern effort
that delivered op pity is now necessary
sort of exactly the same to resolve the
issue of bridging hotels now he'll know
from mine conversations with him that I
do think there was a chunk of naivety
about how much housing would come
forward in the latter part of September
2021 and it's clearly now necessary to
bring to an end the use of hotels no
family should have a hotel as their home
for the long term but can you be sure
about what plans he has got with local
governments some communities including
his own in Plymouth can communities like
Glasgow an extremely welcoming stepping
forward others haven't what challenge
he's putting to those who have not how
he sees this work as part of a
coordinated program and also how he will
ensure that this was the result of this
isn't people turning up at the local
housing office to try and get
accommodation and to the public funds
they have access to
yeah absolutely you know our first set
of questions my friend and I pay tribute
to him for his work uh in this area uh
previously
um when it comes to uh making sure that
uh local authorities come forward look
this is all part of this is a uh is
trying to create the environment where
local authorities want to do that right
so there will be a part of it that talks
about increased funding uh you know 21
000 pounds uh per family settled over
three years prior to today that
increases by seven thousand pounds today
we are going to do everything we can to
incentivize uh families to do this um we
recognize that this is a national
commitment but look in London we can
only do so much we need to really tap
into the national feelings about how we
felt about Afghanistan when the collapse
happened welcome these people into our
communities and make them a strong part
of the United Kingdom
several robbers
the minister mentioned that half his
cohort is children now members of the
appg for women and girls heard this
morning from their head teacher of year
11 schoolgirls being moved six weeks
before their gcses tomorrow and they
won't be found meaningful educational
arrangements for another 20 weeks he
must surely agree that integration must
offer meaningful opportunities for
Afghan women and girls and particularly
in relation to education and this may be
one of the reasons that families turn
down accommodation but when he also
agreed that the support provided by
wales's Youth Organization arirth was
pioneering in integrating Afghan
families into Wales and will he agree to
work with the
appgir and Afghan women's
representatives in Wales in developing a
toolkit for use to empower Afghan women
and girls as they integrate here
so so Mr speaker clearly I'll work with
any groups as we try and recognize these
responsibilities and a big part of it
um you know we'll be setting up casework
teams in every Hotel I'll be visiting
all these hotels and I invite honorable
members to come with me as we try and uh
meet this challenge when it comes to
moving on Afghan families who are at a
particular time of school that is one of
the reasons why we're looking at the end
of the summer to have this completed
because we know that people are starting
a new Academic Year there are plenty of
um of competition of priorities if you
like as to when we should or shouldn't
do this and there's lots of issues
around Ramadan around Eid around medical
treatment around schools what we have to
do is try and plow Authority down that
balancing up all those competing
priorities but realizing the Strategic
aim of getting these people out of
hotels and into communities across the
country I've ever
representatively speaking my
constituent's wife is tracked in
Afghanistan she applied for a visa to
come as a spouse it took eight months to
get a decision and it was turned down
because there was a discrepancy of 33
Pence per month in his salary that he
put in the original application the way
we are treating people from Afghanistan
the way the government is treating them
is a disgrace and we need to ensure that
people are treated fairly and that their
applications are looked at and and and
when there is a genuine application is
there is in this case make the right
decision yeah
so if my humble friend writes me with
that specific case I'm more than happy
to get back to him and help him and
Laura
perfectly
Foundation not easily available in
Newcastle I know that from the thousands
of constituents who write to me
Desperately Seeking it it is the number
one issue I also know it from talking to
Afghan refugees and Ukrainian refugees
for that matter so what is the minister
going to do after 18 months to Magic up
this perfectly suitable accommodation or
is he seriously going to be making
homeless those who risk their lives at
our sides
yeah I mean Mr Speaker I've covered I've
covered these points before I've said
that I I don't want to make anybody
homeless clearly the local Authority
housing fund which comes into play is
going to help that process am I saying
to the house we're going to build six
thousand homes by the end of the summer
no uh but we have to be you know
unable to you know if we just look at
this as like we're never going to get
there then we're never going to change
anything at all we're never going to
meet this challenge she will know that
there is an acute demand for housing
across Society in places like Newcastle
uh and Plymouth and we're going to do
everything we can including increasing
things like the private rented offer to
make sure that we get these people out
of hotels and into communities like hers
just remind you we have six hours of
protected time after this plus several
votes just to remind you to focus your
questions Joanna Cherry thank you Mr
Deputy speaker I've got a particular
case that I know the minister will want
to help me with and I know he's genuine
in his concerns here it relates to a
gentleman who worked for the British
geographical survey part of which is
based at Harriet watt University in my
constituency he spent a lot of time at
working to keep British people safe and
help them navigate around Afghanistan
while the British government were
helping Afghanistan to explore mining
opportunities to bring income to the
country despite all his hard work his uh
arap application has been turned around
turned down and he's having to appeal it
and I wonder if this is a case that the
minister would speak to me about to see
if we can get it speeded up
writes me about that case I'm more than
happy to come see it
Wendy Chamberlain
speaker as The Honorable member for
deferment said the appg for Afghan women
and girls met this morning to
specifically discuss UK resettlement and
I have to tell the minister the feedback
was was not great nobody wants to be
staying in hotel accommodation but I'd
reiterate her offer please and engage
with the appg and please provide
reassurance that in terms of that
appropriate accommodation situation such
as schooling job opportunities those
things that help integration are being
considered so let me speak I'm all happy
to come and address the appg on
addressing the appg for Afghanistan
later on and as I've said of course
those things will be taken into
consideration you know we have to press
in perspective there are people who've
come to this country who have resettled
into all communities who you know 9 000
of them who are happy who are getting on
with with their life in UK but broadly
speaking we need to see through our
responsibilities that's precisely why
I'm stood here today it's precisely why
this government's determined to realize
its commitments and we will see it
through Andy Slaughter I think security
speaker on the 20th of February after 18
months in a bridging hotel in West
London the nadiri family and many other
Afghan refugees were relocated to Leeds
and housed in another bridging Hotel
yelda nadiri was about to take her GCSE
at William Moore's six former
microstituency five weeks on she still
has no school Place well the minutes to
see that yelder can return to her school
and take her exams if you can't do that
well that's what he can do
sure I'm all happy from honorable friend
to write to me about that case we don't
want to be moving people from bridging
accommodations bridging accommodation if
you've asked me about that case I'm more
than happy to help him out it'll be
Abrahams I'm absolutely convinced that
the minister is is committed in this in
this regard
um
you know his track record has shown that
but would he put some pressure on the
Home Secretary and also on
disappointingly the International
Development secretary who who wrote to
me after Westminster Hall debate on this
very issue and said that he wouldn't be
able to help Afghan women judges under
threat of their life by the Taliban when
they are clearly eligible for phase
three or of the acrs
look I I mean nobody's better the acrs
uh pathway 3 has been very difficult to
open up it's quite a it's quite a
technical path where we have had our
first person through on that uh we have
made commitments to uh over uh I think
it's over a thousand through that
pathway
um pathway three yeah a thousand places
offered and we have 351 in uh in third
countries at the moment uh I'm look uh
we have made commitments in the space
we're going to see them too and if she
feels that's not the case she's more
than welcome to come and see me
speaker I'm very thankful to the to the
government department for their work to
resell those of our allies who are in
danger and I know that the minister and
nobody doubts that the minister will
accept that there are still those who
need to be processed is there any way
minister of enlarging the team to be
able to deal with these cases more
efficiently as there are families living
in fear of their lives every second of
every day and I believe more needs to be
done originally to give those whose
lives are on the line due to their
loyalty to democracy and individually to
those that they work with thank you yeah
because I've said a number of times my
uncle friend will know that one of the
primary moral cases for this is the fact
that we have not been able to continue
that pipeline out of Afghanistan we have
there were operators who sat there in
Afghanistan today who are entitled to be
in the UK they are not here because that
pipeline is not working we have too many
people in hotels and we want to
reintegrate them into UK societies it's
as simple as that so you know we clearly
have a moral case all of us have a
responsibility to try and see through is
our commitments to these people and get
these Pathways open I want to see a good
professional seamless pathway out of
Afghanistan on those three pathways
through acrs and our app as much as he
does and I hope we can work together in
the months ahead you've got speaker in
the 18 months since the UK government
capitulated to the Taliban my
constituent Hadi sharifu has been
helping Afghans who work for or with us
to escape one is the former commander of
Kabul whose injuries at the time
prevented him from leading with UK
forces he's now across the border but
Minister why does he still have no legal
means to enter the UK and why is this
government's reward for his service to
our forces to throw him to people's
Smugglers criminalize his entry to this
country and then threaten to ship him to
Rwanda
the the
conditions of Arab or acrs compatibility
are very clear and if he if he has
served in those roles and he's entitled
to the Arab program or acrs then he can
apply to those from third countries now
uh and if he if he does so if there are
individual cases where that's not
working then let me know but those you
know the criteria for acrs and fire up
are very clear if he meets that criteria
then he's entitled to come in John
McDonnell Secretary of the national
Union of journalist parliamentary group
we're aware by working with
International bodies about these 200
Afghan journalists who fled into Africa
into Pakistan and Iran their visas are
expiring some of them have been harassed
by Taliban supporters as well the Nega
is written through Home Secretary
earlier this month we'd welcome a
meeting with the minister to try and
ensure that his scheme now has adapted
more effectively to cover those who are
vulnerable journalists so that would be
pathway through the acrs that's
precisely what it's designed to do and
that is exactly why we're taking this
course of action because there are
people that we want to get through these
Pathways who are not now coming through
these Pathways because of the we've
gummed up the system in the UK with too
many people in hotels so I hope with all
colleagues we can make a real effort to
get these people out of hotels into
communities where they deserve to be for
supporting Western values and UK forces
in Afghanistan and I look forward to
working with my honorable friend to get
that done
thank you there were several thousand
Afghans in the Asylum system even before
operation petting and indeed many of
those are still awaiting decisions
including a young Hazara mother my
office is working with alongside her two
daughters
since then there's been many Afghans
have come to the UK buy small boats due
to the feelings of the acrs given the
situation of Afghanistan surely the
minister would agree that it's
inconceivable that the UK would Deport
anyone back to Afghanistan
yeah so we're currently not returning
anybody to Afghanistan so uh if these
people are eligible for the criteria on
the acrs or the program I encourage them
to apply for that they can now do that
through a third country we're determined
to get these individuals in the UK out
of hotels so that we can make that
pipeline work and then it works for
people like The Honorable friend
mentions
I'd like to thank the minister for his
statement today and responding to
questions for eight minutes short of an
hour
presentation of Bill Emma Hardy
Humber 2100 plus project Bill second
reading what day
24th of November
thank you
we're now moving on to the 10-minute
rule motion on bus services consultation
Mr Dean Russell thank you Mr Deputy
speaker
um Mr Deputy speaker I beg to move that
leave be given to bring in a bill to
require consultation of bus users before
changes are made to bus services and for
connected purposes now Mr Deputy speaker
Imagine This
a hard-working member of the public
perhaps working night shifts where their
only means of getting to work is by bus
night after night waiting in the dark
perhaps sometimes in the cold and the
way rain and cold weather
simply wanting to get to work and
through no fault of their own find out
the bus needed to get to work on time
has been changed giving them an
impossible choice of being late to work
arriving impossibly early or even worse
making it near impossible to get to work
at all or perhaps a pensioner living
alone at home where the bus is a
Lifeline to visit friends and family for
them to attend doctors and Hospital
appointments and where the bus is their
transport to living a full life not just
for traveling for when their local bus
timetable changes skipping the nearby
bus stops meaning they can no longer
access them suddenly through no fault of
their own they find themselves cut off
from The Real World and their support
network
now Mr Deputy speaker behind every bus
timetable change there will often be
passengers who just want to live their
lives individuals who find themselves a
reliant on a service they have little or
no say in and I'm sure we would all
agree buses are an important part of all
of our communities in fact buses are
used for twice as many Journeys as
trains and from thousands more stopping
places across the country and according
to the National annual bus stats 2022
the number of local bus passenger
Journeys in England alone was 2.8
billion in 2021 and 2022
taking the bus instead of a car twice
each month would reduce emissions by
15.8 million tons of CO2 by 2050
according to the better transport
campaign so it's good for the
environment too
and also read a statistic recently I
think it was on the NHS England website
that a survey of NHS trusts indicated
that around 7.8 million appointments a
year and around 650 000 a month were
missed citing transport issues which I'm
sure some of those uh would be related
to buses now buses are without a doubt
the most used form of public transport
they carry millions of people each year
and are a vital public transport link
for individuals for the economy and for
People's Health and for the environment
yet despite their importance it is hard
to believe that when timetables are
changed there's no official requirement
to directly engage or consult with
passengers of a bus when its timetables
are being considered for Change and by
bus passengers I mean the people who use
the actual bus those who get on it every
day to get to work to get to their
appointments to see their friends to see
their family people are more than just
numbers they have Hospital appointments
they have jobs to go to they have lives
to live yet they do not currently need
to be asked about the services that they
use now there's art there are legal
requirements for official organizations
to be asked for example in England bus
operators are required to give a
statutory notice period of 70 days for
registrations variations and
cancellations in relation to Community
Bus Services made up of 28 days notice
the local Authority and 42 days notice
to the traffic commissioner and many do
consult and reach out to passengers but
they don't have to and there's no legal
requirement for bus operators to inform
passengers of the changes until the
canceled the council registration has
been processed this bill seeks to
address this giant pothole of an
oversight and give bus passengers a
voice in the process now before I go
into the proposal of this bill I should
clarify that I really welcome the work
of government to support buses and I see
the uh the minister for buses on front
bench and I appreciate the time he is
spent to meet with me to discuss this
the national bus better strategy 2021
has aimed to address long-term decline
in bus services and to create a bus
Network fit for the future and as I
understand it the strategy has been
backed by three billion pounds with 1.4
billion being or allocated already and
within my own County of Hertfordshire we
have received 29.7 million pounds for
the bus service improvement plan there
is much more I could say about this
fantastic work that government is doing
to invest in buses and make sure that
the the network is is fit for the future
but it is clear that investment and the
national stress was there the national
strategy is there my proposal today is
simply to ensure that the users of those
buses who rely on these vital services
that will be supported by this fantastic
government spend
um of our part of the journey to make
decisions now my proposal is a very
simple one to implement a legal
requirement or guidance for all
companies commercial or public who
provide a public bus service to ensure
users of the service are given an
opportunity to feed into a consultation
before services are changed changed or
canceled so if a service is due to be
changed or canceled canceled that they
ensure every effort is made to inform
the impacted bus users through signage
ideally on the bus itself and at bus
stops and shelters and of course through
the usual online channels and Community
engagement now I do want to counter some
criticism I've had of The Proposal due
to a lack of understanding of my request
what I am not proposing is that if a bus
service has a handful of passengers and
is simply not viable at all even with
financial support that the bus
passengers should somehow be able to
stop uh the timetable from changing if
that were the proposal I think it'd be a
fair criticism but I'm not saying this
I'm simply asking that the voices of
passengers are heard in the process and
are properly considered as part of the
decision-making process my experience at
bus passengers many of which I have met
in my own constituency of Watford as
part of Outreach and bus Community
engagement is that they are pragmatic
and realistic about the challenges they
also often have very smart and practical
ideas and solutions to solving issues
with timetables but they often feel like
they are just numbers on a spreadsheet
in an office and they're never asked
until it's too late
and those paying customers and they are
paying customers are using a service
that they rely upon I just want to
Simply give them a voice in that process
and not to have decisions imposed upon
them uh without a being aware that
they're coming B being able to have a
say in it and C making sure that they're
not just simply told after the fact and
as we all know as much as we'd like to
believe that when timetables are changed
that everyone knows instantly often that
isn't the case and so often people will
be turning up hoping their bus is going
to come and it may not arrive because a
timetable has changed this would help
address that now I Mr Speaker Deputy
speaker I should say this bill feels
quite personal to me I confess I didn't
properly learn to drive until my late
20s although I'm proud to live in my
constituency of Watford and have lived
there since I was elected I've been a
resident at Hertfordshire for over 20
years and I originally grew up in the
West Midlands for many years I worked at
Birmingham airport and was reliant on
buses to get to work sometimes 6 a.m
shifts to go and be a clean cleaner
sometimes 10 pm shifts to do night
shifts patrolling car Parks I wasn't
that threatening I should I should say
um an often 12-hour shift outside of the
usual nine to five so I've been the
person waiting at a bus stop in the dark
I've been the person praying that the
bus is going to arrive soon so I'm not
late and get into trouble I've been the
person hoping the timetable doesn't
change to make it impossible for me to
earn some money I know what it's like to
be reliant on public transport and I
also know how wonderful it can be I know
that it can transform lives buses can
transport us to live our lives but also
it can be a Lifeline for hard-working
people to to go out meet friends and
family but also to get to their jobs so
buses really are something special and I
know that the government is doing all it
can to protect them to protect them as
part of our communities to help protect
our environment and ensure patients get
to their appointments on time
and they are also needed to ensure
hard-working British people can get to
work which they do on a daily basis so
in conclusion Mr Deputy speaker with
this bill I'm asking colleagues across
the house to support this I'm asking
them not to Ring The Division Bell today
and for the government to get on board
with this bus Bill and issue clearer
guidance so bus passengers across the
country are part of the journey when
timetable changes are being decided
thank you very much this would normally
be the opportunity for somebody to
oppose the 10-minute rule motion but
I've been no given no notification that
anybody wishes to do so and I see nobody
wishing to do so so I'll pose the
question and the question is that the
honorable member have leave to bring in
the bill as many of that up and say aye
country now I think the eyes have it the
eyes have it
who will prepare and bring in the bill
Mr Speaker it's ABC speaker at Jack
bryton Marco longy Jason McCartney
Elliot Colburn Andy Carter Andrew Jones
Dr Lisa Cameron Anthony Higginbotham Jim
Shannon Joe Gideon John kigullis and
myself Mr Speaker Mr Dean Russell
Aviation
thank you bus services consultation Bill
second reading what day November 24th
November the 24th thank you very much
the clerk will now proceed to read the
orders of the day
illegal migration Bill committee day two
now we now move to Committee of the
whole house
order
illegal migration bill
my members that in committee members
should not address the chair as Deputy
speaker please use our names when
addressing the chair today either Dean
Rosie Mr Evans or sir Roger Madam chair
chair Madam chairman or Mr chairman are
also acceptable we will now begin with
the amendment 186 to Clause 2 with which
it will be convenient to consider the
other amendments Clauses the schedule
and new Clauses as listed on the
selection paper and as ever like
yesterday I just advise people that
there are a lot of people who wish to
speak today and if they could focus on
shorter contributions it means that
everybody will get an equal shout and I
call Alison thielitz to move Amendment
186. thank you very much Mr chair and I
moved the amendments in my name and
those of my honorable colleagues and as
as of yesterday there are many
amendments we are making to this bill
and a very vain attempt to try and make
it more palatable but this bill really
is so religious us to be unamendable and
unsupportable
the aim of this bill as I say out I is
reflected by the statement by the UN
High Commissioner for refugees who has
said that the legislation would amount
to an asylum ban extinguishing the right
to Refugee protection in the United
Kingdom for those who arrive irregularly
no matter how genuine and compelling
their claim may be and with no
consideration of their individual
circumstances
this is an extraordinary and extreme
piece of legislation if passed nearly
nobody would be able to claim asylum in
the UK not children not traffic people
not people at risk of persecution not
survivors of torture
the refugee Council has estimated that
the bill will result in as many as 250
000 people including four forty five
thousand children being detained or left
destitute in States provided
accommodation
Mr chair in this section my colleagues
and I have set a range of exceptions to
removal and we've done this for a very
clear reason to humanize this brutal
Bill and talk a bit about some of the
specific impacts it will have
the Tories like to speak as if the
people affected by this bill or some
kind of amorphous blob they are not
each and every one of them is a real
human being people who are wept at my
surgeries is Despicable this government
cares so little for their welfare as
well as our International obligations
names have been changed in the number of
the examples and the case studies I'm
going to use here but they are real
people
Amendment 188 is haseen's amendment and
we ask in this amendment that the duty
of removal does not apply to people who
are under the age of 18 when they
arrived in the UK
Hussein was flown over from Djibouti age
nine by a woman he'd never met his
travel documents were faked his identity
was changed he was made to look after
another family's children while still
only a young child himself
it took him until adulthood to speak
publicly about his case many of the well
known by the name that he's more famous
for sir mufara
under this bill children like Casino
Abdi Khan would never have been given
the opportunity to rebuild their life
they would have been denied certain
citizenship
detained and removed unaccompanied
children would not be supported as they
are through the excellent Scottish
guardianship service run by aberlauer
Scotland's children young people's
commissioner Bruce Adamson has said the
UK is required to ensure that children
seeking Refugee status receive
appropriate protection and Humanity lean
assistance under article 22 of the UN
convention and the rights of the child
the ncrc also requires the UK ensures
that children are protected from
exploitation and abuse and afforded
support for Recovery this bill violates
those obligations and many others its
enactment replaced the UK in clearbridge
in clear breach of its international law
obligations under a range of Human
Rights treaties I urge the government to
accept our amendments excitement
Amendment 19 exempts Afghan Nationals
and nothing that the the minister who
came to the house earlier has said has
made any difference to how I feel about
this there are still many Afghan
Nationals who do not protect and I
wonder perhaps if it might be possible
to call this tobias's amendment since
the person in the case who I'm going to
mention which is to remain anonymous the
independent has reported that the Air
Force Lieutenant who flew 30 combat
missions against the Taliban and was
praised by his Coalition forces
supervisor as a patriot to his nation
has been forced into hiding and said
that it was impossible to make his way
to Britain via a safe route this has um
sparkling Nation from The Honorable
member for Bournemouth East who would be
up here to be entirely detached from the
reality of what he has voted for in this
bill
did this is clearly not who we are as a
nation and it's not how our migration
system should operate I hope the
government will look at this case
specifically and address The Wider issue
of how an Afghan who supported UK armed
forces can safely apply for asylum in
the UK well let me explain this to this
honorable member and to all the others
if this bill passes which it no doubt
will this is exactly who this nation is
this is exactly how the UK migration
system will operate it is a exactly what
members opposite have voted for in
supporting this Wicked Bill no
exemptions no backsies no fingers
crossed behind your back people like
this Air Force Lieutenant people who
work for the British Council Afghan
interpreters Educators the widows and
Children of Men Who served with British
troops the supplied of Crockery to
British Armed Forces cannot sit and wait
for the Taliban to find them and execute
them
if they managed to get out if they cross
continents if they step in a dinghy and
get across the channel and even if they
fly here via Pakistan on a visit Visa
obtained by pretending that they would
go back the UK government will not hear
their case they will put them on a
flight to Rwanda this is what an
admissibility means in practice and the
member for Bournemouth East and all his
other colleagues should catch themselves
on
I'm in 190 exempts people who are
refugees under the refugee convention or
in need of humanitarian protection
because they're seeking Asylum is not a
crime
Amendment 191 exempts people at risk of
persecution because of their sexual
orientation and I could call this a vets
amendment I met her at the rainbow
sisters drop in last week she's from
Uganda if you're just brought in brittle
anti-lgbt laws and her statement to me
last week is why would the UK government
send her back to neighboring Rwanda she
would feel no safer there than in Uganda
under this law under the laws the
government are bringing forward she
would be offered no protection and sent
back to her certain death
Amendment 192 exempts people for whom
there are reasonable grounds to suspect
that they are victims of torture and I
could call this kalbasius amendment
kobasia Hassan MBE is a survivor of
torture and founder of survivors speak
out and he is an incredibly Brave man
he's a torture Survivor from Chad
detained on claiming Asylum who has
spoken powerfully about the impact that
that detention has had on him the
uncertainty that he faced and he has
said that he would have killed himself
rather than being returned to the hands
of his torturers this bill would allow
that to happen to kalbasia
Ukraine but wait I wasn't actually sure
Mr chair if that would be an order
because it is a safe and legal route for
people from Ukraine you won't find them
coming over in a boat in the channel
they don't need to come here because a
safe and legal route exists that should
be the option for anybody in their
circumstances
amendment 2 exempts people who uh who
have HIV AIDS because they are put by
this bill at risk of not receiving
treatments or being returned to a
country where they would face stigma and
risk and potentially death
I will
remember for giving away and making and
Powerful points today I declare an
interest as one of the co-chairs of the
all-party Parliamentary group on HIV and
AIDS and the UK along with many other
nations we are working together
to end new HIV transmissions by 2030 the
UK is also one of the co-founders of the
global Health Fund in terms of making
sure there is commitment and funding
does mindful friend agree that what we
are doing in terms of denying people who
are diagnosed with HIV and AIDS is
counteractive to all of the aims and
states of that
she's absolutely correct as a co-member
of uh not all party group to make that
point uh because we have a
responsibility here and the way in which
this bill is scheduled takes no account
of people's Health circumstances
whatsoever and it could put those people
at severe risk where they sent back
where they denied treatment and the home
office the minister she said but the
home office has formed here and denying
people who receive medication to manage
their condition the treatment that they
are entitled to in detention which is
where they wish to place people the
national leads trust have highlighted a
case to me of a person detained at
harmsworth IRC who has denied access to
the care that would meet clinical
guidelines to prevent this case you
couldn't get the medication and the
dedication was not given at the
appropriate times with food as was
prescribed because the staff there had
no experience of this and were not able
to support him adequately so if the
government is going to deny people entry
and detain people what is the guidance
for this what guarantees can the
minister give that those with HIV AIDS
will actually be able to access this the
treatment that is keeping them alive
Amendment 194 exempts people who have
family members in the United Kingdom now
there are many cases Mr Speaker that I
could the Mr chair who I could attribute
to this case in this case I'm going to
call it ibrahim's Amendment he is here
in the UK his wife his son and daughter
are in Iran they have been patiently
waiting for over six months now for a
family reunion visa to be processed but
in the meantime his family are in danger
his daughter was followed home by from
school and raped by the irgc this is why
people don't wait in country for the
government to process their visas they
don't wait because they are at risk of
persecution of rape of danger of torture
that's why people flee people come here
to join family because they're in danger
they are not prepared to wait for safe
and legal routes because in many cases
they do not exist from the reunion in
many cases that I see is just too slow
and it is not available to everybody who
needs it
I'm in online five accepts people for
whom there are reasonable grounds to
suspect that they are victims of
trafficking or slavery and this I will
call Eva's amendments
Eva as a 20 year old woman from
Southeastern Europe who was referred to
the Tara service in Glasgow by police
Scotland over the 2016 festive period
through our relationship she believed
was real she ended up being assaulted
drugged trapped in sex work and
trafficked
she was later placed in a lorry and
moved for three days eventually she came
to be in Scotland kept in a flat
isolated from the other women that were
also being held there being raped
multiple times by men every day
she was able to escape and find her way
to the police
under the legislation proposed she would
now get no support
her trafficker will threaten her now
that if she goes to the authorities they
will send her to arabanda they will keep
her under control by the measures the
government are bringing forward in this
bill
in addition she will not get the expert
support that Tara provide in Glasgow she
will be at risk of re-trafficking and
further exploitation this is the reality
of this legislation for Eva and many
like her a traffickers charter
I'm in wanting six exempts people who
met who meet the definition of an adult
at risk in paragraph seven of the home
office guidance on adults at risk in
Immigration detention 2016 including
particular people suffering from a
condition of experienced a traumatic
events such as trafficking torture or
sexual violence that would be likely to
render them vulnerable to harm so let's
call this Muhammad's Amendment after the
experience of young people described by
freedom from torture in their reports
fleeing a burning house which I
recommend to all members on the opposite
benches
Muhammad arrived in the UK via Libya
in Libya the treatment is so cruel we
have a few young people who are really
traumatized Smugglers were basically
killing people on the journeys I think
that one of the most traumatic
experiences is being raped or seeing the
brutality of people the UK government is
not in this legislation seeking to
assess the trauma that people arrive
with but to remove them without asking
any questions
putting people into immigration
detention re-traumatizes people I have
visited Napier Barracks there was no
privacy there was no dignity diseases
like covered and scabies run Rife this
model dehumanizes now I've heard some
people say if it's good enough for
troops it's good enough for refugees but
the reality is that these facilities
have been abandoned by the mod for a
good reason because they were inadequate
and for many people who are fleeing
trauma it's that militaristic experience
that they are running from it's entirely
inappropriate for vulnerable people and
we know from The Brick House inquiry the
home office is a sketchy history of
those people who meet the definition of
adults at risk they should be reducing
immigration detention not expanding it
our list of exemptions are not
exhaustive we accept labor amendment 2
which mentions gender and it's not
possible to detail every single possible
category of person who should be exempt
from the duty to remove because every
person who comes has their own story and
their own circumstances and a bill which
treats all of them as a problem to be
removed is not fit for purpose
the duty to remove is far too broad and
currently only has minimal narrow
exemptions by including people like
victims of trafficking and the duty to
remove the home office is creating
secretary is creating circumstances for
the traffickers have even more power
than the people that they are
trafficking
Amendment 197 removes the lactated
element of the legislation many people
who have already started their Journeys
would not be aware of this legislation
when they began them it will impact
people who have also already accessed
support Arrangements here in the UK and
to all our tents and purposes in the
Asylum system they could not have known
the detail of this legislation uh when
which had not been published when they
made their journey and it's particularly
egregious that they are being punished
for this
moving to close three unaccompanied
children regulations giving the power
the power for the Home Secretary to
remove unaccompanied children there is
no duty to do so but it remains at her
discretion the Home Secretary said in
the second reading debate that the
duties to remove would not apply to
unaccompanied Asylum seekling children
and the only in limited circumstances
with the power to remove unaccompanied
children be used such as refund the
union however there is no detail in the
bill itself of when such a power would
be used and given all that I know about
the home office I certainly wouldn't
trust them as far as going through them
from the children's Commissioner of
England the children's Commissioners
team tell me that they recently met a
boy who believes his family that who
believes his family were killed in Iran
and was brought to the UK by people
Smugglers he had no idea which country
he was coming to and no choice in the
matter the bill sets out the children
like this boy who arrive in the country
are regularly up whether alone or with
their families will essentially be
denied the right to claim asylum in the
UK these are children who are fleeing
persecution and then further exploited
and abused by people Smugglers any child
arriving in the UK after these
experiences must be first and force most
viewed as vulnerable and in need of love
and care many of these children will be
trafficked here against their will and
must not be held accountable for the
crimes of their adult exploiters
plus one makes applications under close
to an admissible so the government
wouldn't consider the application at all
no matter how strong an application may
be and separated children will also have
any claims deemed and admissible
plus five details agility and the Home
Secretary to remove people which we've
amended by placing some safeguarding
Clauses in here so that people can't be
removed to dangerous countries
research from the refugee Council has
shown that around half of the people who
made the journey last year came from
just five countries with highest Island
Grant rates these people cannot be sent
back home it's just not possible to send
an Afghan back to Afghanistan or
Australian back to Syria they are not
included on the safe countries list
there are no alternative Arrangements in
place to remove people either there's no
agreement with the French government in
the EU and the Rwanda scheme is beset by
legal challenges and even if it was
working as the government imagined it
would only a few hundred people per year
would be expected to be removed so that
leaves a situation for thousands of
people some are very compelling and
legitimate cases who would currently be
allowed to remain will be left in limbo
indefinitely forever any application
they make will be in admissible they
can't go home and they can't go anywhere
else the Home Secretary is creating a
situation where thousands of people will
be eligible to be detained and I
wondered slightly if ministers perhaps
had the hope that those people Smugglers
across the channel would set up in Dover
and take people back and because it
doesn't seem that they have any other
plan we're how to deal with this
situation
plus six gives the Home Secretary Paris
to amend the schedule list of the
schedule which is a list of safe
countries and these two countries I
would say are not safe
for everybody
Albania has often talked about but many
of the people that are being trafficked
here particularly for sexual
exploitation are being trafficked from
Albania if the return as I mentioned
earlier they may be at risk of re
trafficking
women for Refugee women and rainbow
sisters set out as well the very clear
risks for lesbians within this
legislation as well because Gambia Ghana
Kenya Libya Malawi Nigeria and Sierra
Leone are listed here within brackets in
respect of men but a number of these
countries Gambia
um I also includes women Nigeria says
that it talk to the lgbtq danger index
but somehow is listed in here as a
country where people could be removed
men face the death penalty by stoning in
Nigeria women face whipping an
imprisonment for being LGBT is the
government really telling me that an
LGBT person whose case we're not going
to assess because we're not going to
talk to them we're not going to find out
why they're going to be at risk will be
returned to Nigeria to be whipped or
stoned to death because that is what
this bill sets out
they are not considering the risks to
individuals in here at all they've made
this list of safe countries which is
clearly not safe for everybody and no
understanding of what that is actually
going to mean
in practice for the people that they are
seeking to move
I will thank you
a powerful case against this frankly
rotten and disgusting bill I wanted to
just mention her Amendment 186 does she
agree with me that without that
Amendment Clause 2 effectively shuts
down
pretty much the whole of the UK Asylum
system because it captures nearly all
Asylum applicants not just those who
come by boat but the nearly half of the
people who don't arrive that way so
without her Amendment 186 essentially
the Asylum system in this country will
no longer work in any shape or form
I absolutely agree and thank her for the
point that she is making there we all we
accept that the government has made an
absolute hash of the Asylum system that
the Asylum backlog is enormous and that
they should be putting attention in it
but tackling the problem by denying
anybody else Asylum ever doesn't really
seem to be the legitimate way to about
dealing with this problem
I
closes at 11 to 12 expands the power of
detention as the chair of the appg on
immigration detention this is an
incredibly worrying development and this
includes people who cannot be moved to
the country of origin UK government says
that their policies to decrease they
previously said that their policy was to
decrease the immigration attention in
the state but there's now going to be
expanded and expanded dramatically the
harm done to people in detention
facilities is immeasurable it
exacerbates and existing trauma it tears
families apart and it has crushing
impacts on mental and physical health
after the Home Secretary is removed the
right for people to apply for bail
thousands more will be trapped in this
system indefinitely the UK's detention
system is already an international
outlier with people being held
indefinitely out of line with Provisions
in the criminal law system and I
received an email earlier on uh from uh
from L Smith McDonald's who works for
medical Justice uh on reports very
worrying and serious reports uh of a
Death at a Detention Center Colin Brook
IRC and I would be grateful if the
minister would stop playing with his
phone and confirm of whether or not the
reports of a deaf at this Immigration
Center has actually happened because
it's incredibly worrying uh and what's I
would I would like to know what steps
the government are taking to ensure that
there will be investigation if indeed
this death is true because there have
been deaths and other immigration
detention centers before and we don't
want to see the minister the government
repeating those dangerous errors I would
like to know what the appropriate
counseling and bereavement support has
been made to other people in the same
Detention Center because this isn't a
frightening experience for them and it
would be useful to know why whether the
home office has stopped including the
number of deaths in Immigration
detention for the official immigration
statistics because they were published
every year from 2017 to 21 but the
latest stats for 2022 deaths were not
included
immigration detention is bad for people
it's bad for their mental health and if
there's going to be further immigration
detention the the minister shakes his
head the evidence around this is
incredibly clear the immigration
detention is bad for people
the bill also expands detention criteria
to include children it was a hard-fought
fight to remove children and pregnant
women from detention estate before and
this rolls back on those hard-worn
rights by the Glasgow girls and others
which stopped children being held
immigration detention is no place for
anybody it is certainly no place for
children
some of the detainees that the minister
wishes to hold will be pregnant
the BME have said under the illegal
migration Bill the protection of the
72-hour time limit and the Detention of
pregnant women introduced by the
government in 2016 will be denied so
women arriving by a regular means
instead pregnant women will be locked up
indefinitely while the government
attempts to remove them from the UK they
will not be allowed to apply for
immigration bail for the first 28 days
they're detained nor to judicially
review the lawfulness of their detention
and indeed many pregnant women are
likely to language send attention for
some time since there are a few returns
agreements in place by which they could
be could be removed from the UK
and to highlight a particular case study
from women for Refugee women uh
regarding a woman called Priya Priya was
a trafficking Survivor he was detained
in yarlsworth when she was 20 weeks
pregnant and held there for almost two
months before being the least
Prius says I only had one Hospital
appointment when I was there for my
20-week scan and even then I was
escorted by officers it took me 40
minutes late for my appointment
I felt frustrated that I wasn't able to
speak to my Midwife after my scan
because there was no time
the officers took me straight back to
the yards wood instead it was not easy I
often felt weak and in pain I'm anemic
and my blood pressure is very low on one
occasion I passed out in your house with
but they just took me back to my room
and left pregnant women being locked up
in detention centers what kind of
message does this send out to the rest
of the world it is in human
close to opens the Immigration Act 1971
and specifies that determining what is a
reasonable period to detain people is a
matter for the Secretary of State rather
than for the courts these changes would
apply to existing detention Powers as
well as the new powers provided for and
Clause 11. our Amendment removes the
considerable latitudes given to the Home
Secretary to decide what's reasonably
necessary to enable examination or
removal Clause 13 amends immigrant
immigration Bill Provisions in schedule
10 to the Immigration Act and it would
just the jurisdiction of the courts to
review the lawfulness of a decision or
to detain or to refuse bail closes 15 to
20 deal with the provision of Asylum
accommodation for children provided by
the home office rather than local
authorities which is entirely
unacceptable the children's commissioner
for Scotland has condemned this move in
the strongest terms saying that the home
office has history of neglect renders an
unfit parent for vulnerable children
the children's commissioner for England
says the bills it stands the profounder
years of uncertainty for example what
formal accommodation provided two
children by the home office will take
making proper scrutiny uh deeply
challenging and we know that the home
office has already lost children from
the accommodation it has used so we
can't really trust them to look after
things at present why would you give
them more powers in this area I spoke in
the previous uh the second reading
debate about treating people as we'd
like to be treated
we wouldn't treat our own children in
this way why does the Home Secretary why
does the minister why does this
government think we should treat
children this week
I know she's given incredibly powerful
testimony will she therefore consider
supporting new Clause 18 which requires
that we treat every child on UK soil
with the same care that we would any
child and we Safeguard every child
equally whether they are refugees or not
absolutely supports her amendments and
the work that she's done in this area
but
forgets and they're talking about people
as if there are more first blob that
these are children they have rights
under the uncrc in Scotland uh children
who are looked after I have we've done a
lot of work in that in Scotland with the
promise we should not be treating these
children as any less than we would treat
our own
it was a 23 section names says this
section shall not come into effect
without the Scott the consent of the
Scottish Parliament well Parliament
evenings in both Scotland and the UK our
human rights guarantors and its
important part of our role to ensure
that legislation is compliant with
International obligations on human
rights incompatibility of this bill the
European convention and human rights the
refugee convention the conventions of
action against trafficking and the
conventions and the rights of the child
I mean that we as lawmakers are obliged
obliged to vote against it undermining
the rights can read upon individuals by
these new agreements must be resisted by
all spheres of government because if
they're coming after this group now
there'll be another group soon enough
afterwards this bill will negatively
impact directly on those seeking
International protection in Scotland as
well as in the powers and the duties of
the Scottish government local
authorities and other public bodies
under the Devolution settlement and I
strongly urge and I strongly expect to
be honest the Scottish Parliament will
withhold legislative consent for this
bill I expect the UK government will
override that consent
the SMP Amendment removes Provisions
along the Secretary of State and
regulations to make certain Provisions
which would alter the operation of the
two-year Sunset clause in relation to
Clauses 21 to 24.
Provisions for Leafs to remain for
victims of slavery or human trafficking
she will no longer be in place it will
be very difficult for third-party
agencies to encourage victims of
trafficking to come forward or to work
with them should they do so Tara and
Glasgow have told me that it's
increasingly difficult for them to
reassure the service users that they are
currently seeing who are victims of sex
trafficking that they will not be
returned or sent to Rwanda for speaking
up and this bill will mean that they
can't reassure them at all
people who are trafficked are often in
very vulnerable situations in their own
countries which have been exploited by
traffickers that is why they are here
the risk of being returned to those
situations mean that those people will
either stay in a dangerous situation or
escape and go underground to other even
more dangerous situations if they are
apprehended and return the risk of
retargeting is high because if the
reasons for their vulnerability is not
addressed
and third-party agencies have been clear
that this bill will filter their ability
to reach out to vulnerable groups to
support people women children victims of
torture and trafficking and all kinds of
Human Rights abuses and that there will
be a sharp drop off and the number of
people seeking help because they will
fear to do so
Mr chair this bill will not stop the
boats it will not fix the Asylum backlog
it will not do anything other than put
lives at risk it is an anti-refugee bill
it is a traffickers charter it is
ripping up human rights Scotland wants
no part of this bill we want an
independent country where we can stand
up for human rights not diminish them as
the sugar government seeks to do
the question is that Amendment one eight
six be made Theresa May
who were Mr Evans and in following on
from The Honorable members of Glasgow
Central I want to focus on an aspect of
this bill which she has touched on in
her references to trafficking and modern
slavery covered of course in the
building clauses 21-28
the modern slavery Act was World leading
in many ways it is still World leading
it ensures that people who are in
slavery in the UK be they British
citizens or not are supported when they
escape their slavery but crucially that
there's an emphasis on identifying
catching and Prosecuting the slave
drivers the traffickers the perpetrators
my fear with this illegal migration bill
is that it will drive a coach and horses
through the modern slavery act denying
support to those who've been exploited
and enslaved and in doing so making it
much harder to catch and stop the
traffickers and slave drivers
now it's been said a number of times by
ministers and indeed by others in this
chamber that the modern slavery Act is
being imbu abused and it is at least
implied that there is a link between the
number of people coming on small boats
and the modern slavery act I have not
seen evidence to support that play
indeed as my right honorable friend the
member for chingford and wood green set
out in the second reading of this bill
in 2022 only six percent of people
arriving on small boats made a modern
slavery claim
and I would remind everybody across this
house that you don't just rock up and
claim modern slavery and refer yourself
to the National referral mechanism it
has to be done by a first responder and
the majority of First Responders are
officials employed by the home office
so from the figures I've seen so far an
attack on the use of the modern slavery
Act is not justified
now I haven't laid any amendments to
this bill because I I hope it will be
possible to work with the government to
find Solutions
what I would like to do today is to set
out the problem and suggest some
possible solutions
I'm not going to dwell on legality or
issues of legality in relation to to
international law or other but there is
no doubt that serious concerns have been
raised on this not least in relation to
incompatibility yes so I I'm grateful to
my old friend and uh where she's going
is very much the the journey that I
think we need to go on could you also
understand that explain to the
government that the the whole issue
about modern slavery is that they give
when they feel secure they give evidence
to the police the police don't get after
the traffickers one of the problems
might be here that as 60 of the cases
are within the UK they may suddenly feel
that they're about to get kicked out and
then they will stop giving evidence and
that's one of the big problems that we
have to face here well
absolutely right on that point I'm going
to make a reference to that issue myself
later on because I think the government
hasn't thought through the implications
and I think they should be assessing the
implications in terms of how many
traffickers and perpetrators can be
caught as a result of this bill I said I
wasn't going to dwell on the legal
issues but there are genuine questions
of incompatibility with Article 4 of the
European convention on human rights
um of course part of UK law through the
Human Rights Act and incompatibility
with aspects of ecat the Council of
Europe conventional action against
trafficking in human beings such as
articles 13 and 10.
but the problem at the heart of the
problem is I believe very simple if
someone is trafficked here into the UK
by illegal means coming from a country
where their life and Liberty was not
threatened and is taken into slavery
here in the UK
they will not be able to claim modern
slavery or have the protection of the
modern slavery Act
that would cover most of the men women
and children who are trafficked into
slavery in the United Kingdom
so let me let me give an example a woman
say from Romania who's persuaded does a
great job here for her in the UK is
brought here on false papers but to work
as a prostitute in a brothel she's come
here illegally from a safe country but
she is in sexual exploitation in slavery
here in the UK
just the sort of case in addition to
British Nationals who've been enslaved
here that the modern slavery Act was
intended to cover
let's say she manages to escape and meet
some people willing to help she's taken
to the police but the government says
you came here illegally we're deporting
you to Rwanda
all the traffickers fear she's looking
to escape
take her to one side and explain it's no
good doing that because all they'll do
is send you to Rwanda
we would have handed the traffickers a
gift another tool in their Armory of
exploitation and slavery
now the government might say that it'll
be okay if the woman actually helps with
an investigation
because there is that caveat in the
building but that seriously
um misunderstands slavery and the impact
of the trauma of slavery on the victims
it can take
some considerable time weeks and weeks
for somebody to be in a position where
they feel confident enough to give
evidence against their slave drivers and
this bill by that time by the time that
they might have actually been able to
get that confidence they will have been
removed from this country so as my right
honorable friend has said it will become
harder to catch the traffickers and
slave drivers
um I could give another example perhaps
someone who came here illegally then
gets in and works through in the economy
sadly
um you know people are able to come here
illegally and work in our economy but
then for various reasons find themselves
vulnerable on the streets picked up by
slave drivers are taken into slavery
again even if they escaped slavery
perhaps after years of exploitation the
government under this bill will shut the
door on them and send them away
I could give other examples but examples
have already been given by The Honorable
member for Glasgow Central and I will
think the point is made
now there are a number of solutions yes
at the weaker end of answers the
government could delay the commencement
of modern slavery section of the bill I
know the official opposition have
suggested doing that until there is a
new independent anti-slavery
commissioner in place and they have
assessed the impact of the bill it would
be good to have an independent
anti-slavery commissioner in place and
to hear their views of this bill but I
think there is more to be considered
first the government should not be
introducing the modern slavery parts of
this bill until they have assessed the
impact of the changes they made in the
nationality and orders act which came
into place at the end of January they
are piling legislation on legislation
they've already passed and which they
have no idea whether that is going to
work and therefore this is not necessary
secondly the government needs to assess
the impact of the deal with Albania
given that in recent times a significant
number of people coming on the small
boats have come from Albania and then it
does need to assess and this is the
point that I've made my right humble
friend has made the impact of this bill
on the ability uh and willingness of
people to come forward to identify to be
identified as slaves and to give
evidence against the traffickers and the
slave drivers I would give away to The
Honorable lady thank you I wonder if the
honorable lady has seen the letter from
all of the home office funded providers
of modern slavery Support Services which
arrived yesterday from
um that their overarching body of the
Salvation Army where literally every
single one of the specialist support
providers doing this exact work that you
have uh you have identified have clearly
stated to the government that it will
absolutely make it impossible for them
to provide support and help catch
traffickers well I'm grateful to The
Honorable lady for pointing that out
because I haven't seen that letter as it
happens and but I'm not surprised that
those working directly in this field are
making those points to the government
and I I say to my right honorable friend
uh the minister that I feel sadly
throughout the modern slavery aspects of
this bill it reveals I fear a lack of
proper consideration of slavery and what
it means and the Imp and the experience
of the victims and survivors and the
need for us if we're going to stop it to
be catching the perpetrators and the
difficulty that this will break so I do
think the government should be assessing
the impact on the willingness of people
to give evidence and on the ability
therefore for us to actually catch the
traffickers and slave drivers but of
course there is a move that will be of
more benefit in enabling us to catch the
slave drivers and support victims and
survivors which would be to ensure that
those in slavery here in the UK were
excluded from this bill now that would
mean recognizing the intention of the
modern slavery act that those who've
been here in slavery in the UK should be
protected by the ACT regardless of their
immigration status now there may be some
of my colleagues who might say oh well
doesn't that mean an awful lot of people
are going to to want to stay here and
worry about the numbers but many people
brought here into slavery actually want
to go home they don't want just to stay
here
um under this bill I fear it is more
likely that they will stay here in the
UK and be staying here in slavery now I
could say much more about the business
implications but in the interest of time
I won't I and I realize I've already
spoken for longer than I told the whip I
might be speaking for but it is in the
interests of uh black mark in the book
but it is in the interest
I do want to sit down with the
government to find a way through that
does not deeply damage the modern
slavery act abandon victims and make it
harder to catch traffickers and slave
drivers I fear that this bill is going
to do all of those things that's why
find a way to ensure that it is not
let's find a way to maintain our
world-leading reputation for support for
those who are the victims of slavery and
for the work that we do to catch the
traffickers and perpetrators and the
minister has indicated he wishes to come
in early so Stephen Clinic
well thank you very much indeed Mr Evans
and can I just say it's a great pleasure
to follow the rightful normal lady the
member for maidenhead who spoke so
powerfully on uh the issues that are
right at the heart of this bill and I
think uh I pay tribute to the uh
outstanding work that she does in this
area around modern slavery and
trafficking
so here we are again uh Mr Evans back
for a second day of debate with all
across this house agreed I think that we
need to stop the dangerous Small Boat
Crossings and to destroy the criminal
industry at the heart of of them
and yet each of us knowing if perhaps
not all of us admitting that this bill
is a con and a sham that will only make
a bad situation worse this is because
the government does not have any returns
agreements with the EU to replace the
one we were part of before brexit nor a
working deal with Rwanda with the Home
Secretary failing in her Mission last
weekend to persuade Rwandan officials to
specifically state that that country can
take thousands rather than hundreds of
Asylum Seekers sent from the UK every
year although at least the Home
Secretary did get to have a photo op out
some outside some houses that are being
built for Rwandan citizens
in order for a deterrent to be effective
it has to be credible Mr Evans and there
is next to nothing in this bill that is
remotely credible because it's about
chasing headlines and government by
gimmick when what we need is common
sense hard graft and quiet diplomacy so
that we can really go after the people
Smugglers upstream and do a deal on
returns and on family reunion
what we need Mr Evans is Labor's
five-point plan which will stop the
small boats Crossings clear the Tory
Asylum backlog and re-establish a firm
fair and well-managed Asylum system
Mr Evans I said yesterday that this bill
was being rushed through this house at
such a speed as to make detailed
consideration and debate almost
impossible that applies perhaps even
more to today's session than yesterday's
way I know um what the shadow minister
is saying about quiet diplomacy it seems
to me actually the Prime Minister has a
very good cordial relationship with
President of France but it's quite clear
that back alone won't be enough to sort
this problem out
well the the party opposite has spent
the last five or six years completely
destroying our relationships with our
European neighbors and partners so any
Improvement on that is of course very
welcome but um I feel that the Prime
Minister has a an uphill struggle on his
hands given the very low base from which
he is starting
I will do for you I just say to The
Honorable gentleman he said we'd spent
the last five or six years destroying
our relationship with France uh perhaps
you might like to reduce that by I think
two
can I say for you I don't believe you
that's one of the best uh intervention
that I've ever received and I am more
than happy to stand corrected and hereby
I hope the that Hansard will correct the
record accordingly
um that's completely knocked me off my
stride now
as a result I will uh again have to uh
limit my remarks to the Amendments and
new Clauses tabled on behalf of the
opposition Clauses two to five of this
bill establish legal duties which are
sure to be unworkable for the Secretary
of State to ensure that every single
person who arrives in the UK without
prior authorization is held in detention
and then removed from the UK now I use
the word unworkable advisedly since the
questions I put to the minister have
second reading about where these people
will be detained and where they will be
removed to are still unanswered likewise
we have no idea how much these proposals
if implemented would be likely to cost
we assume that impact assessments
modeling the potential costs have been
carried out but since the government has
failed to publish these assessments thus
denying The house's Democratic right to
hold a fully informed debate on these
matters then we have only various leaks
and briefings to the pro-tory media to
go on we know from these briefings along
with independent third-party analysis
that the Bill's price tag is likely to
be at least three billion pounds a year
and possibly more but the fact that
those impact assessments have not been
made public suggests a deliberate
attempt on the government's part to
limit the scope for parliamentary
scrutiny and to obfuscate its own
calculations of the amount that will
have to be paid by the British taxpayer
so I asked the minister what is he
afraid of why will he not publish this
Vital Information
it's simply not good enough both for
members of this house and for the
constituents that we represent as a
result we've had to table new Clauses
which would force the government to
publish within tight time scales the
impact assessments which are clearly
being Sat On by ministers
all we're asking for in Amendment 286
and 287 and new Clause 28 is for
ministers to publish detailed
assessments on the likely implications
of this bill in terms of cost to the
public purse and availability of
adequate accommodation and detention
capacity so that we can have a fully
informed debate
looking beyond the tension capacity we
know that the Asylum backlog alone means
there will continue to be a need for
some time for accommodation to be
provided to families who would otherwise
face destitution in recognition of that
new Clause 27 would make it a legal
requirement that local authorities be
consulted as part of the process of
accommodation being provided in their
areas now I know that there are strong
feelings about this issue on both sides
of the house and on that basis I do look
forward to cross-party support for new
Clause 27 as we go through the division
lobbies this evening
on the basis that sunlight is the best
disinfectant we're also calling in
Amendment 284 and nucleus 22 to oblige
the Secretary of State to report
regularly to Parliament on the
government's progress towards clearing
the ballooning black backlog of Asylum
cases an issue that's not even mentioned
in this bill and on the number of people
removed from the UK under its provisions
now the backlog as we all know is eight
times as high now as it was when when it
was handed over to the conservatives by
the labor government in 2010 as
confirmed by the UK statistics Authority
and contrary to what uh ministers have
been claiming from that dispatch box 166
000 cases unresolved as of today only
half of which relate to small boats it
must be said it's an astonishing
abdication of Duty so if the government
truly believes that clearing the backlog
is a priority then I can think of no
good reason for them not to accept the
reporting requirements that we have laid
out in our amendments the scope of some
of the Bill's key Provisions
particularly those that relate to
detention and removal is exceptionally
broad what the government is proposing
is to do away with virtually all
existing safeguards many of which they
themselves established in law within
just the last few years and which many
of our amendments are designed to
protect Amendment 148 would remove from
the bill the Secretary of State's powers
to remove unaccompanied children from
the UK now the government says it does
not currently plan to use these Powers
but if that's the case then what are the
powers doing in the bill in the first
place
Amendment 21 would retain the current
time limit for the Detention of pregnant
women established by the party opposite
in the its own Immigration Act of 2016.
ministers have not made any case let
alone a convincing one for scrapping
these limits and thus allowing pregnant
women to be detained indefinitely
additional safeguards we're calling for
in our Amendment include exemptions from
the duty to remove in cases where in
Amendment 285 there is no realistic
Prospect of a person's removal due to
the absence of the necessary returns
agreements in Amendment 6 where the
person's cooperation with law
enforcement could help with efforts to
tackle crimes such as people smuggling
and in Amendment 13 where the person's
removal is not possible without
violating the refugees convention
prohibition of reformal
removal to third countries designated as
safe is obviously a central part of the
government's plans even though no
country other other than Rwanda has so
far expressed any interest whatsoever in
being part of a similar deal with the UK
but in the event that there are similar
deals we believe there should be certain
rules in place to prevent the Secretary
of State ignoring evidence of the
dangers some migrants may face if
removed to the country in question as
has clearly been the case with Rwanda
for instance Amendment 17 would add to
the bill a requirement that the
secretary of state must consult with the
unhcr and other relevant experts when
designating safe countries rather than
cherry-picking evidence that supports
decisions that she has already made
Amendment Six together with new Clause
21 form part of a package of new
approaches intended to strengthen the
government's hand in ensuring the
detection prosecution and conviction of
those guilty of people smuggling
taking ministers at their word that they
are serious about dealing with these
issues I look forward to the
government's support for these
amendments
Mr Evans as I have said the intention of
most of our amendments and new Clauses
is to ensure that robust safeguards are
in place to prevent the broad Powers
being given to the Home Secretary on not
being exercised completely arbitrarily
in addition to those I've mentioned
already amendment 18 would ensure that
notices of removal should be provided to
people in a language they can understand
and with information about their rights
and where they can access advice
turning now to the modern slavery
sections of this bill I would start by
reminding the government of the words of
the right honorable member for
maidenhead not just in the powerful
speech that she just made in this
committee stage but also at second
reading when she said nobody wants to
see our world-leading legislation being
abused but the government has to set out
the clear evidence if they're saying
that there is a link between that act
and the small boats and so far I have
not seen that evidence and I would say
that she is not the only one Mr Evans as
we on these benches have also yet to see
any evidence to that effect
the right honorable member for
maidenhead also correctly pointed out
that significant changes were made to
Modern slavery legislation by the
nationality and borders Act the relevant
sections of which have only come into
Force within the last few weeks and that
further changes at this point are
clearly unnecessary that is the point we
are making with a number of opposition
amendments to these sections of the bill
for instance Amendment 24 would keep in
place the definition of public order
provided by the nationality and borders
act which states that modern slavery
protections do not apply to people who
pose threats to public order such as
violent criminals or terrorists the bill
seeks to extend the definition of such
threats to literally anybody who arrives
on a small boat it is far from clear
that this is what the trafficking
convention had in mind when it provided
for exemptions to the general
requirement to make protections
available to victims for that same
reason we do not believe that support
for victims should be withheld from
people who would otherwise be subject to
the duty to remove that the bill
establishes those provisions of the bill
would be removed by our amendments
288-289 and 290. amendments 291 and 292
are more targeted and would provide
specific exemptions for victims of
sexual exploitation and prevent the
removal of victims who are not parties
to the echr and the convention against
trafficking
nucleus 30 recognizes the potential
victims of trafficking may be
particularly vulnerable on to Serious
harm if held in detention for indefinite
periods on that basis nucleus 30 calls
for the Ed government to implement
special procedures to Fast Track any
cases of potential victims whose modern
slavery referral first arises when the
while the person is held in detention
the government has sprung these changes
on us without any meaningful attempt at
consultation Amendment 50 serves as a
reminder to the government that last
year ministers made very specific
promises not to try to make any changes
to Modern slavery laws without first
appointing a new independent
anti-slavery commissioner and Consulting
with him or her on the potential
implications of any proposals that
commitment has not been honored and
Amendment 50 goes no further than asking
ministers to keep to their own promises
it would simply delay the entry into
force of the relevant sections of this
bill until after a new commissioner has
been appointed and consulted and their
news taken into account and whilst we're
on the topic of the modern slavery
commissioner it is of course worth
noting that the former modern slavery
commissioner Sarah Thornton has stated
that if you remove support for modern
slavery victims coming forward you make
it harder to prosecute criminals
I spoke earlier about attempting to
amend the bill to provide certain
safeguards ultimately all the safeguards
in the world are unlikely to substitute
for the requirement that measures should
comply with basic human rights as
enshrined in the Human Rights Act of
1998. the secretary of state has been
all over the place in various
announcements in which she seems to
contradict herself on the question of
whether this bill if enacted would be
compliant with human rights law
Amendment one simply says that that that
requirement which applies to all other
legislation should apply to this bill
too
ministers should have nothing to fear
from this amendment unless of course
they doubt their own statements to the
effect that they are confident in the
Bill's compliance with human rights law
Mr Evans as it stands this bill is a
traffickers charter we therefore urge
the government to support our amendments
and new Clauses so that we can remain
true to the values and principles that
underpin the modern slavery Act
Mr Evans I'll just end with a few
Reflections on yesterday's debate
because I do have to say that I found
some of the comments made by the benches
opposite deeply troubling
many talk a good game on defending
Ukraine and Hong Kong and other
democracies around the world from
authoritarian threats but they're
sometimes not as good at defending their
own democracy it's seen indeed they seem
to be focused on undermining it I'm yet
to hear a definitive definition of an
activist judge from what I can work out
this is simply a judge who makes a
ruling that the government disagrees
with
I'm yet to hear any definition of a
lefty lawyer I think it's someone who
has picked apart and defeated the weak
case that the home office may have put
together despite the thousands of
experts that it has as its disposal and
I'm yet to understand how we Define the
home secretary's Civil Service blob are
these the people that work for her day
in and day out a number of whom are in
junior low paid roles being asked by
senior ministers to make complex Asylum
decisions because of cuts made by the
conservatives 10 years ago I asked these
questions Mr Evans because the
separation of powers and the functioning
of these Powers is absolutely critical
to our Constitution and to our democracy
yet many members on the benches opposite
are increasingly sounding like their
right-wing counterparts in America
blaming every Institution for their own
failures terrified of scrutiny from the
media unable to do their jobs within the
law because they either don't understand
the law or because they've been over
promoted
Mr Evans I'm not a lawyer and I'm not
making these points from a legislative
legalistic perspective
but I am a Democrat
and when I hear the tirade of abuse that
the benches opposite hurl at our
Judiciary during debates such as the one
that took place yesterday I have to say
that it leaves me fearing for the future
of our democracy because the separation
of powers between the executive and the
Judiciary is absolutely fundamental and
these powers and these checks and
balances are axiomatic to our Democratic
Values so I would urge members opposite
to think long and hard before they
launch any further assaults on our
Judiciary because we don't want to live
in a trumpian version of Britain Mr
Evans we want to live in a vibrant
democracy that is based on upholding the
independence of the Judiciary
defending the separation of powers and
respecting the Integrity of our
institutions thank you
Smith
channel uh thank you very much indeed
for being called as early as this and
I'll try and be brief as per uh the
reaper I want to focus if I could
specifically on what my right normal
friend has talked about which is the
modern slavery elements of this bill and
keep it to a reasonable amount of time I
just want to draw the uh reality of what
we seem to sometimes get mixed up there
is a fundamental difference between
people who are trafficked and people who
pay traffickers to come here for reasons
that are economic or whatever and I
don't want to dwell on that but the
important thing is we've mixed these two
terms up there is a very clear
definition of being traffic it's people
who don't want to be here and were
brought here against their will and only
used for various Services which they
shouldn't be and they are slaves so on
that basis I also say because Central
Justice came forward with a important
paper on that and my writable friend
when she was Home Secretary picked that
up turned it into legislation and we
were the first country in the world to
bring this legislation through and I'll
be honest with you it may be a little
unfashionable now to say but
I'm I'm very proud of that I think what
we did was worth celebrating and worth
protecting and if there are faults in it
then we need to correct those but the
problem I find in the bill and I know my
writable Friend by the way on the front
bench has been uh very accommodating and
has talked at length and I I thank him
for that and I will make a few comments
now if I could on way it's there's a
problem and where we could possibly help
because we want to help Rectify this I
understand what they're trying to do but
I want to protect some of the modern
slavery bits so first of all it's
important to note that some of which my
right and friends said
commencing the modern slavery Clauses
only after publishing an assessment of
the problems and impact I understand
that the opposition to put down uh
various tools to do this in the new
clauses I just want to make the point
that the government has argued that the
bill is needed to address illegal
migration at the Modern slavery Clause
that needed to address and prevent abuse
of the modern slavery support system by
false claims from people seeking to
bypass removal so the model slavery
Clauses in the bill should be targeted
at the problem of false claims with
clear assessment made to the level of
false claims and impact on a widened
widening modern slavery policy the
government should specify therefore in
the bill that the modern slavery Clauses
21-28 would only be commenced therefore
as a specific threshold perhaps of the
modern slavery claims as an increase in
those claims is reached demonstrable by
evidence of that I think is fair uh that
would mean that alongside the false
claims it would trigger modern slavery
Clauses the government could commit to
publishing evidence on the current level
of false modern slavery claims and any
increased decrease and of course section
63 of the only recently passed National
nationality and borders act would enable
the collection of that data quite
quickly on bad faith claims since the
30th of January 23. also uh not to
commence against an assessment has been
published of the impact of the modern
slavery Clauses disapplying modern
slavery protections on identification of
victims including the willingness to
come forward and the prevention
detection investigation and prosecution
of slavery and human trafficking
offenses these are important because at
the end of it all what we need to know
is is there evidence now I understand
the government's fear that somehow this
will be used therefore as an alternative
vehicle to escape the claim of being
sent back but um we don't see any charge
of that six percent of all those who
have come over on the boats only six
percent overall have actually claimed
modern day slavery to seven percent
that's a tiny number and they they would
know by now that they could do that and
the reality is that that hasn't happened
so I bring back the attention that it's
there's no real evidence at the moment
now I understand the government May well
think we need to protect ourselves
against that potential but we need to
see the evidence that that is actually
breaking that trend I give away
I absolutely agree with everything that
he's saying and look forward to working
with him uh going forward uh to get some
of the things that we all want to see
um would he agree with me though that
there would be no risk of modern slavery
victims
um being held up in the system that
maybe allows them to stay here or or
fake modern slavery claims as the
government seems convinced exist if it
didn't take on average 553 days for them
to be assessed if it went back to the
45-day system that used to exist uh
perhaps if more had been put into it
over the years there would be no risk
that people might use it to stay in the
country longer yeah well clearly
obviously the faster that these claims
can be assessed uh the better for
everybody they can either be discovered
as illegal or they can be discovered as
genuine victims and that's the key thing
and I think the point that I made about
the clear evidence of such abuse in the
system uh needs to be published because
it's quite important that the figures
are there to be understood that there's
a very small number that are actually
claiming it although that the the 71 73
that they we were told during the course
of the second reading in fact refers to
those who at this stage are detained for
removal after arrival and that amounted
to 294 people so we just need to get the
figures in context and then we can
understand what the problem is and how
we deal with it and if there is an
increase then the evidence shows then we
will be able to use perhaps parts of the
bill the main giveaway
forgiving wean he and I have discussed
this issue and the lack of an Evidence
base for this aspect of the bill and
when the former and modern slavery
commissioner Professor James Sarah
Thornton gave evidence to the Joint
Committee on human rights recently about
this issue she suggested that because no
replacement for her has been appointed
for over a year there's a lack of a
proper evidence basis for these
children's Liberty aspects of the bill
does he agree with me that she's right
about that and will he use his good
offices with the government to try and
ensure that uh modern slavery and
anti-slavery commissioner is appointed
flattered by the idea of my good offices
with the government and I will take that
at face value thank you very much indeed
but I will speak to the government about
that and I do accept that we do need to
get this replacement made very quickly
but the one point I really want to make
here which is very very powerful the
most important point is that we need
really to think about exempting the
victims exploited in the UK as my
honorable friend from the disapplication
of modern slavery protection there is a
very good reason why that is the case
because otherwise as my right hand laid
out very clearly they will then see that
any idea of coming forward to break with
that and give evidence will be simply
dismissed I suspect because very simply
that they will fear that they will not
be allowed and not be accepted and
therefore they will have to go and many
of them won't have given evidence yet to
the police so the bid in the bill that
suggests that the secretary state will
be able to assess whether they've given
evidence at least this is a longish
process and therefore protecting them is
after rule over 60 percent of the cases
I really do wish the government would
think carefully about that because that
and I think the police will back us on
this because they want them to give
evidence and the I the irony here is the
more we help them the more they give
evidence the more of the traffickers we
catch the more get closed down and
probably fewer people then come across
on the other end of it which is on the
boats coming across the channel this is
all part of a circle of trust and
identification and final prosecution I
think this is really really important so
amending Clause 21 to exempt victims
exploited in the UK at the new
thresholds for positive reasonable
grounds decision requiring objective
evidence would therefore no longer
prevent spurious crimes the whole point
about this is It's finding a way and and
I think the main point to make about all
of this is I think we can agree about
this you know modern slavery in the UK
the work that we've done the evidence
all the rest of it is now helping
prosecute those traffickers if we lose
that delicate flower as it were of
success from the modern slavery then we
will find ourselves in a worse position
and we will find many more people
trafficked deliberately because we
become a soft touch on trafficking so I
urge my writable friend I understand
fully by the way I must say to him of
his his the government's problem of
trying to deter the whole nature of the
illegal use of those boats coming across
China A for their own safety and B
because it puts huge pressure
unnecessarily on the services here but
when it comes to modern day slavery I
beg of him please accommodate these
concerns and make sure that we do
something in the bill to protect them in
the long run
thank you so much Mr Evans I will first
like to address my comments in support
of a range of amendments regarding the
rights of children because this bill
punishes children just for being
refugees and puts unaccompanied Children
at Risk there isn't enough time to go
through every Clause but I would like to
highlight some of the many crouties
indeed the measures before the house
today not only abolish protections
afforded to children but instead allow
for the routine Detention of
unaccompanied children beyond the 24
hour time limit and detention anywhere
the Secretary of State considers
appropriate
children being detained for prolonged
periods of times is UN utterly
unacceptable and poses serious risks to
their health safety and protection
Clauses two to ten will create a large
and permanent population of people
including children and families and
unaccompanied children living in limbo
for the rest of their lives
close three could see a child arriving
alone in the UK fleeing war and
persecution being allowed to integrate
into the UK Society only to then be
forcibly removed from the UK as soon as
they turn 18.
Clause is 15 to 20 give the Secretary of
State a range of astonishingly
far-reaching Powers including the power
to terminate a child's looked after Care
status and the key legal protections
provided by local authorities
this is despite
I'm very grateful The Honorable lady
giving away I'm pleased that she's
raised these particular Clauses within
the bill do you think it would be
helpful for for the minister I know
having spoken to him is is Keen to
ensure that we get clarity on this issue
that we understand when the home office
is providing appropriate accommodation
for children what that actually means in
practice as well as the other care and
support that's required as well as the
justification reasons for enabling the
Home Secretary to remove a child from
the care of the local Authority Under
the vice versa Clause Clause 16 because
at the moment an explanatory note there
doesn't seem to be any reason given for
that power being needed
but for his intervention and I hope that
the minister will be able to address uh
his points in his reply this is despite
the array of evidence an array of
evidence on the significant harm facing
unaccompanied children currently
accommodated by the home office in
hotels for vulnerable children this bill
denies Refugee and human rights
protection and recovery from trafficking
and prolongs their fears and insecurity
by denying them the reassurance that
they have found safety and it's not just
children that are being targeted by this
government they are removing almost all
protections for victims of modern
slavery and trafficking who are targeted
for removal as such I'm also supporting
amendments regarding equalities and
human rights including my new clause 20.
this bill will be disastrous for
disabled and lgbtq plus children and
adults
women fleeing persecution will be
prevented from claiming Asylum Asylum
and detained indefinitely with no
exemption for those who are pregnant
indeed Clause 11 will enable the Home
Secretary to enforce the indefinite
Detention of children and pregnant women
in camps such as manston on a statutory
basis going back to what was happening
even before 2016 when pregnant women
were being detained for weeks in some in
some cases for months on end with no
idea of when they would be released
that's this is utterly disgraceful
how can it be right that people are to
have their human rights ripped away from
them because they are from a different
place and surely human rights are
inalienable and Universal persecuting
some of the most vulnerable people
fleeing torture war or oppression during
a climate of increasing anti-migrant
hostility with attacks on Hotel hotels
housing Asylum Seekers and a growth in
far-right activity is cowardly and
dangerous
the illegal migration bill will be
mocked in history as an extraordinary
and chilling attack on our values and
our way of life for years to come and so
I will conclude my remarks by saying not
in my name I oppose the government's
Clauses before the house today I reject
their purpose and principle in their
entirety because all human beings are
born free and equal in dignity and with
rights and in the words of Article 2 of
The Universal Declaration of Human
Rights everyone everyone is entitled to
all the rights and freedoms steps set
forth in this decoration without
distinction of any kind such as race
color sex language religion political or
other opinion National or social origin
Property birth or other status
furthermore no distinction shall be made
on the basis of the political
jurisdictional or International status
of the country or territory to which a
person belongs thank you Sean Howe
to talk to my amendment that is listed
on the amendment paper
my purpose is to ask the minister to
think about what I am requesting over
the coming days
I'm not asking for a commitment now and
it's important for me to State this and
that I am not seeking to divide the
house on this question
of my amendment is to get an opinion
from the commission for democracy
through law otherwise known as the
Venice Commission
the Venice commission is part of the
Council of Europe
it consists of lawyers from across the
wider Europe including the UK
its individual members include
professors of public and international
law
Supreme and constitutional Court judges
the UK members are Mr Timothy ottey and
Mr Murray hunt
they are competent lawyers
it exists in part to comment on
legislation whether in draft or final
form as to whether and how that
legislation is compliant with the UK's
obligations as a party to the European
convention on human rights
I have used their offices before to
comment on draft legislation that is
currently before the Turkish Parliament
it can be quick
I believe the Turkish legislation took
about a month to examine
but France and Germany have also used
the Venice commission and they have used
it in reference to uh to to opinions
about constitutional law
incidentally I am already negotiating
hard with German socialists to stop a
hostile notion sorry a hostile motion uh
being laid against the UK
how much better to go to this to this
organization as part of an international
and multilateral Community rather than
simply being dragged there
in the wording to my amendment I have
ensured that any referral to the
commission does not hold up the passing
of this legislation
it comes into Force only one month from
the passing of this bill into an act
I understand from the minister that he
has consulted other countries on this
legislation
how much Fuller and more expensive would
it be to use this vehicle with its Rider
wider remit to get an opinion not a
guarantee but an opinion that meant that
no one had to guess anymore what the
chances were of the legislation meeting
the requirements of the convention
I cannot see the harm in using this
vehicle to do this and I am very happy
to be involved in helping to facilitate
a reference to the conclusion
so in my conclusion I asked the minister
to consider this proposal further in the
days ahead and I am fully available to
discuss it with him
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Evans and I Rise
to speak
to support the group of amendments in
the name of mine would find the member
for everyone
and I am proud to stand here and speak
on behalf of my Vauxhall constituents
many of whom have contacted me about
this really important issue and my my
constituency
in my constituency like many other
constituencies to be fair we celebrate
diversity and we welcome people
from all over the world who are fleeing
war and persecution and we stand in
solidarity with them and I'm sure that's
the same across the UK and nobody in my
constituency wants to see the
continuation of the horrific scenes
we're seeing across the channel
if we look at this some of the
statistics 2022 saw an average of over
100 people a day take the perilous
journey across the channel five times
higher than the figure in 2020 and more
than 40 of these people attempted to
cross the channel on a single day just
before Christmas
the dinga that they were on contained
Afghan Nationals fleeing the Taliban and
a dozen accompany children
and Miss Evans we know that tragically
that dinghy capsized
resulting in the death of four people
and the sad reality is that these people
will ruthlessly exploited by people
traffickers at their most vulnerable
moments
so it is right that we in this house
come together and do everything within
our power to stop the horrific loss of
life
and on this side of the house we do
believe that we must crack down on the
criminal gangs that have made nearly 180
million pounds in the last 12 months via
the exploitation of vulnerable people
but Mr Evans we have to be clear this
bill before us is not the solution
it does more to criminalize runnable
victims than it does to punish those
responsible
and in fact this bill in its current
form and this legislation does not solve
any single problem driving this
humanitarian emergency
it lacks any effective measures to
tackle the criminal activity of people
smuggling gowns and it fails to
eliminate the backlog about standing at
silent cases which myself and many other
NPC in our caseload on a weekly
sometimes daily basis and this will
increase the number of people in
temporary accommodation including some
of the people in in one of the hotels in
my constituency I heard how that was
initially designed just to house single
men but a situation where we are seeing
families and young children housed in
those hotels yeah but most shamefully
this bill leaves the victims of modern
slavery without any protection
and never in my right experience did I
think that I'd you know haven't been
elected here that we would see a
situations where we were having to
debate that
that really does sadden me
and I think instead of cheap headlines
it would be so great to see the Home
Secretary concentrating on looking at
reform and resettlement schemes to
present to prevent the dangerous
Journeys
and how we can engage on the hard work
of diplomacy to get our International
Partners to provide support in working
on this together Britain cannot solve
this alone we have to work with the
International Community and there is a
clear pathway in doing this
as outlined in some of the Amendments
that many honorable right under the
members are spoken and about today
and Mr Evans the sharp Spike we are
seeing in Channel Crossings doesn't come
in the vacuum
instead it is exacerbated by the void
safe and legal routes into this country
available to those facing violence and
persecution in their own countries
and of all the Amendments outlined to
their new clauses I just want to focus
on Amendment 4148 which is really
important and has been touched on
already
it cannot be right that unaccompanied
children are risking their lives without
any protection
and by removing unaccompanied children
as this bill proposes will not stop that
Danger
instead it will stop unaccompanied
children getting the support they need
and I'd ask the minister
um
how can he think about the scenes that I
described earlier where we saw a dozen
children capsize on a boat in the
channel desperately in the cold December
Winters are not recognized that we must
do everything we can within our power
to open up safe routes to those children
it is unacceptable and it is inhumane
and I'd urge everyone to really look at
and support those Clauses today
alongside this is the crucial work we
must do with our International neighbors
to establish safe routes for Asylum
Seekers and to really crack down the
people smuggling
but sadly what do we get with the
current government we've got measures
that would prevent Sudanese and Afghan
women subject to sex trafficking in the
UK from access and support
and this bill as many honorable and
right North members have highlighted on
won't clamp down on abuse of modern
slavery it says traffickers Charter and
that's why we should also support
Amendment 288 which would remove the
provision to restrict modern slavery
support
and I think about the many organizations
and who have already highlighted that
there are yet to see any evidence
showing that modern slavery system is
being exploited including anti-slavery
International which is one of the oldest
human rights organizations based in my
consistency working really hard to end
and eliminate all forms of slavery
and the provisions not only help the
victims of the most horrific crimes they
also help us in Catching and identifying
the Gans
and we know that modern slavery victims
are subject to coercive control by their
traffickers and coming forward to report
their experience takes amounts of
considerable courage and again I I
reference the meeting last week from
Women to Women refuge and rainbow
systems hearing powerful testimonies
from a number of women who shared their
experience and the fear of being sent
back into the hands of people who abuse
them a blanket ban on blocking anyone
arriving to access their support through
the early statutory system to help
identify and support systems is wrong
this bill seeks to deny them basic
support and it's shameful
no sensible migration policy should
actively make it easier for criminals to
avoid accountability and that's what we
would have that's what's in front of us
now
and Grant and home office powers to
detain women children who are pregnant
or disabled people in prison-like
settings just for seeking Asylum is
wrong
I hope that the ministers will listen
and I hope that they will have some
compassion some empathy in people who
are reaching out to all of us as
constituency MPS with their cases people
who are speaking out on behalf of people
who don't have a voice
another government to change tack on
this bill
to abandon this grandstanding and
support tangible solutions to look at
how we solve this desperately sad
situation before it's too late and
before we see more lives lost
Jeremy Wright thank you very much Mr
Evans I Rise to speak to Amendment 182
in my name and in the name of other
honorable and right honorable members
and it makes a simple point which I hope
the minister can accept this bill of
course focuses on those who arrive in
the United Kingdom in the circumstances
described in Clause 2 of the bill
essentially those who arrive in the UK
after the 7th of May this year without
leave to do so and who've passed through
safe countries on the way and in
relation to those people the bill does
not only provide for their removal and
detention it also imposes lifelong
consequences on those who enter in this
way including permanent exclusion from
the Grant in future of various types of
short-term entry into the UK If
indefinitely to remain and of
citizenship all set out in Clauses 29 to
34. but of course despite the Bill's
clear and important deterrence objective
its effect is not as simple as break the
rules and you're banned for life
it recognizes rightly in my view that
exceptions have to be made for
exceptional cases
and in relation to all the future
applications I've mentioned the bill
provides for the Secretary of State to
be able to Grant the application if it's
necessary to do so to comply with the
UK's obligations under the European
convention on human rights or under
other International agreements to which
the UK is a party
now given the focus of yesterday's
discussions on removing the echr from
decision making in other parts of the
bill I won't dwell on the significance
of the eechr in this part of it but I
will perhaps just say in passing that
the government may want to reflect on
how attitudes to echr obligations in
different parts of this bill now fit
together
my focus though is on the other ground
for allowing in exceptional cases the
grant of a shorter term entry clearance
to those otherwise excluded from that
Grant because they had previously
entered the UK under the terms of this
bill
and that is when the Secretary of State
considers and I quote that there are
compelling circumstances which apply in
relation to the person which mean that
it is appropriate to do so that's in
cause
2933b so in relation to circumstances
and applications for some entry
clearances the government thinks it's
reasonable beyond what is necessary to
meet its International legal obligations
to allow some applications in compelling
circumstances from those who would
otherwise be refused and I think Mr
Evans of that is very sensible
but such provision for granting
applications in compelling circumstances
does not exist in relation to
applications for citizenship and it
seems to me that that is not sensible
incidentally Mr Evans I must confess
I've noticed too late that the
compelling circumstances exception is
also not in the bill in relation to
applications for indefinite leave to
remain and I should really have
submitted an amendment to the same
effect regarding them at Clause 2935 but
I hope the minister will indulge me and
consider that point too but my Amendment
182 would add the ability for the
Secretary of State to Grant
exceptionally an application for
citizenship where there are compelling
circumstances so what might such
compelling circumstances be well as I
say there's consequences of an entry
into the UK under the terms of the bill
are lifelong and the entry in question
may take place at any age
what that means is that someone brought
into the UK on a small boat within the
terms of the bill as a baby on which of
course they would have had no say would
be excluded from entering and remaining
in the UK including as a citizen at any
age thereafter except in the exceptional
circumstances as defined in the bill so
for example that person who arrived
first as a baby could not 20 or 30 years
later become a naturalized UK citizen as
a result of marriage to a UK National
now such a scenario would I think likely
constitute compelling circumstances and
the Secretary of State should have the
power to Grant citizenship in such cases
I'm happy to give away I'm grateful to
the restaurant for for giving away
because it's making an interesting and
very worthwhile Point here but in
Practical terms knowing as we know the
ruthless efficiency of the home office
in Practical terms How likely does he
think it is that they would ever marry
that baby coming to this country without
papers to the person seeking to come 20
years later
well he makes a reasonable point but I
think we have to pass legislation in
this place that assumes a degree of
competence on the part of all government
departments and uh and and we would do
that I think
um with straight faces throughout but in
any event it is important that
secretaries of State as I know he would
recognize have the powers they need to
do the right thing in the right
circumstances and that's what I'm
seeking to provide a secretary of state
with here and of course it's right to
say that these cases would be rare but I
believe the discretion should exist to
deal with them when citizenship is
applied for or indeed when indefinitely
to remain is applied for as it is when
shorter term leave to enter is sought
and that is what my Amendment will
achieve and I hope the government will
be able to accept the force of it but Mr
Evans finally let me say this if this
bill is to succeed in its objectives it
must have both political and legal
credibility and I agree with those who
said yesterday that such credibility
depends on clearly available safe and
legal routes for entry to the UK in
parallel with the sanctions this bill
imposes on those who do not use them and
I look forward to what the government
will bring back on that point at report
stage but I also think that the Bill's
sanctions will only have credibility if
they allow for the fair treatment of
exceptional cases and I hope Mr Evans
that my Amendment will improve the bill
in that regard
Alyssa Carmichael thank you very much Mr
Evans it's a pleasure to follow the
honorable gentleman in particular just
to pick up in his last point about safe
and legal Roots uh the truth of the
matter is of course we don't need
legislation for safe and legal roots and
if I think if I thought for the
government for one second that the
government was acting in good faith when
they make references to save legal
reasons then I I would have a lot more
time for the contents of this bill but I
see no evidence of that good faith and I
think that he and his honorable and
right honorable friends may have to
reflect on that when it comes to how
they consider their position at later
stages in the bill because everything in
this bill is all about electioneering
and politics it's nothing to do with the
occasion of a of a safer legal root or a
workable a system of migration or indeed
stopping the small boats which we all
want to do from coming across the
channel
I particularly enjoined the
contributions from the right honorable
member from Whitford green and indeed
the right honorable lady the member for
maidenhead
um I served in government with very
honorable lady for five years
I don't think we need to wait for the
30-year release of papers to say or to
learn that relations between hot and
some and my party were not always easy
in that time
having said that I equally don't think
we need to wait for the release of 30
years papers to know that relations
between herself and some in her own
party
possibly in the treasury in number 10 in
these years were always easy because of
course relationships in government are
not always easy
but you know I listen to Her speech
today and I listened to the forensic
dissection of those parts of this bill
that impact on the bill the act that she
brought through in relation to Modern
slavery and I found myself almost
weeping with Nostalgia for her time in
the home office the the intellectual
rigor
and the political substance and the
determination to do what was ranked by
some of the most vulnerable people
living amongst us because I remember
when the right honorable lady thought
that build as it then was to Parliament
hey it's funny to cabinet and and I
remember thinking at the time that what
she was talking about was people who
were for all intents and purposes
invisible amongst her community there
were people who were living amongst us
about whom we knew nothing
and he heard it it would have been the
easiest thing in the world
for her and others to ignore them in
simply to pass on but she didn't it was
enormously to her to clean it and I
think she is absolutely right
when she explains his concern that the
provisions in this bill seek to drive
coach and horses through the legislation
that she brought through she's also
absolutely right that we should have had
appointed by now an independent
anti-slavery commissioner uh the right
honorable gentleman is right when he
sees that a the effect of this
legislation if it is ever to be
implemented and given that we've only
just completed the implementation of the
national team borders bill it needs to
be seen uh act rather it remains to be
seen whether it will ever actually be
implemented will be to push these people
these vulnerable victims of slavery back
down into the shadows and away from
public View and away from the protection
that the most undoubtedly need and
deserve
and the evidence you know again and the
lack of evidence runs like a Silver
Thread through this bill there lack of
of the impact assessments you know have
these impact assessments been done are
they ever going to be done if they have
been done are they've been published you
know the honorable gentleman from the
opposition front bench made much of this
in his speech and he was absolutely
right to I was tempted to intervene in
them to say hold on a second here man
you shouldn't be going so fast you be
allowing the minister to come to his
feet and to to tell us the position
but he didn't
I suspect he's not going to do so again
now
I have to say there have been times when
I have seen ministers in the treasury
bench look more uncomfortable than the
the right honorable Richmond does today
and did from during the speeches of his
right honorable friends but I struggle
right at the moment to think when that
might have been
the particular points that I wish to
focus on today however relate to the
question of detention and in particular
the Detention of children
the Detention of children is something
that I thought we had seen the back of
and again I'd pay tribute to the right
honorable lady because although it was
an initiative that was driven by my
former colleague Sarah Taylor when she
was the minister for young persons
um she in the home office did a lot to
support this it was an absolute Steam on
our country that we kept children locked
up in Immigration removal centers like
done Gable in Scotland I remember
visiting done Gable it must have been
about 2007-2008
an event but also I have to see success
of home office ministers and immigration
ministers then in the labor government
standing up at the dispatch box and
seeing that I was a bleeding heart
liberal and this was just something that
we had to live with and there was
nothing that could be done when of
course as we know because we did it five
years later there were things that could
be done and ultimately well done but I
think it tells you quite a lot yes just
in a second I think it tells you quite a
lot about the journey that the
conservative party has been on from
those years in 2011 2012 to today that
they feel that they feel it necessary to
reintroduce detention for children you
know we've had 10 years without it now
and what have been the bad consequences
I don't see anybody nobody's saying that
it has brought a massive increase for a
spike or caused any particular problems
but now for the sake of sheer political
positioning we are going to return to
our situation where again children will
be placed behind razor Wild on places
like dungeable the minister sitting
there shaking his head if he wants to
intervene and tell me that I'm wrong
about this I'm more than happy to take
his intervention
to you and or answer it more fully later
when I make my remarks but it is
undoubtedly true that we Face a serious
situation today where the number of
unaccompanied minors coming into the
country over the channel has increased
fourfold since 2019 and that place is a
great strain on our system and we need
ways to ensure that where those people
are being age assessed and may
ultimately be decided not to be miners
that they are held inappropriate
detained accommodation and that is one
of the issues that we're seeking to
tackle with this part of the bill
well I mean can I just see to the
minister I hope that tomorrow he gets a
hold of hand sound uh reads what he has
just said and as my mother used to say
to me takes a long hard look at himself
because it doesn't say
um the idea that that is a justification
for locking up children is absolutely
disgraceful and you know for him to try
to draw and to invent a causal link
where none exists again is a consistent
line of the way this government acts it
is the same way that they tried to draw
the causal link between the modern
slavery act and those coming in in small
boots it just does not exist I will take
them
with what he's saying on the treatment
of children the current proposal in the
bill is that unaccompanied minors coming
here claiming Asylum will spend the
balance of their childhood here knowing
that the day they become 18 the Home
Secretary will have an obligation to
remove them from the country isn't that
an unconscionable way for any government
to treat children
unconscionable is one of the more polite
and major terms that we could use about
it but you know aim I reflect on the
fact that when I was visiting dung evil
whenever it was
2007-2008 my own children were about six
and ten years old and they thought that
kept coming back to me when I saw that
facility and let me see parenthetically
the staff in dungeable did an absolutely
phenomenal job to mitigate the horrors
of what they were dealing with but at
the end of the day we were keeping
children behind eraser wire lockdown
institution and that was downright
inappropriate and unacceptable and you
know nobody will ever persuade me that
we should treat any child differently
from the way in which we would want to
treat our own does the honorability come
I mean the fact that the minister
on the record said that it is okay to
incarcerate miners another word being a
child because you think some children
may not be children reflects why we need
to clarify as a safeguarding and Welfare
responsibilities of all public agencies
who deal with these children and
everybody is a child until the age of 18
in international law so we'll the member
confirm that he also supports new Clause
18 to give parity of those
responsibilities and put Beyond doubt
the direct responsibility of the
Secretary of State and the ministers to
look after every child equally well in
this country
it'll come as norger it's a place to The
Honorable lady that I do and you know
this it brings me now really to thinking
about what we do here because there is a
danger those of us who follow the
evidence who actually care about what's
going to happen if this Dreadful
of legislation ever where actually to be
implemented disappeared down the rabbit
hole of trying to improve it and amend
it and mitigate it and you know we've
all feebled dozens some of us hundreds
of amendments
um but a this I think is a piece of the
bill that has simply to be excised so
yes
um when it comes to divisions I would be
seeking to divide the house in relation
to Clause 11 Stan park because I think
frankly this is a piece where that uh
you know
there's no mitigation there's no
polishing of that I avoid the vulgarity
but you all know what I'm talking about
there's no way that you can polish and
and improve on something that is so
fundamentally removed from the way we
would tolerate the treatment of our own
children you know I was struck earlier
than we were talking about returning
people yesterday I was privileged to
meet a group of Hong kongers who are
amongst that privileged group of people
who came here by a safe and legal route
they still have the problems of course
their Journey didn't end when they
arrived at Heathrow they still have to
deal with the trauma of leaving friends
and family and others behind in
circumstances where they would
importantly ordinarily have chosen not
to do so
but I heard a quite remarkable story
there from one person who didn't come
a through the safe and legal route
because her arrival predated that Visa
scheme being opened up and she told me
in fact that her twin sister had been
here but had left the country and now
she was being told that in fact she
would need to leave because they had
confused her Biometrics with those of
her twin sister my God
um that's the sort of Ruthless
efficiency of which the home office is
keepable
but you know is that are we seriously
hearing now that we are going to start
sending people back to Hong Kong
because they happen to have come here
before the start of the bno Visa session
um demon Rosie I I feel I've detained
the house for long enough I I feel this
is probably a matter of consensus
amongst members
um but when it comes to divisions we and
these benches will do everything that we
can to improve the spill But ultimately
there are pieces of it that simply
cannot be left to stand
uh well I Thank The Honorable
gentleman to for coming to a right on
other gentleman for coming to a
conclusion what I I am going to try to
call people who didn't get called
yesterday as well as those who have
amendments but
um that will require a certain amount of
uh brevity David Simmons
well thank you very much indeed Dame
Rosie it seems a long-standing conundrum
of the immigration debate that most of
our constituents do Express concern
about the issue of immigration its
impact on our country but at the same
time tend to be very positive about
their own personal experiences of people
who've come to this country as migrants
I know representing a very diverse
constituency in Northwest London that is
the case but in other parts of the
country as well where the experienced
people have is that people who come as
immigrants are those who drive the bus
they're the people who work in the local
shops they're the people who work in
their children's schools and maintain
the NHS and we're having this debate at
a time when we must acknowledge that one
of our biggest
demographic challenges Remains the fact
that we have a declining working age
population and the ons data very clearly
shows that we have a significant
challenge alongside much of the rest of
the developed World in maintaining a
Workforce sufficient to support our
population
it's been a very constructive debate so
far and I think in particular I'd
highlight the comments of the member for
Bravo in respect of the need for a
returns agreement Professor Tom Brooks
of Durham University recently did a very
detailed study and highlighted one of
the biggest pull factors for those
waiting to cross to the United Kingdom
was the absence of a returns agreement
with France or with the European Union
and I'd particularly pay tribute to the
member for East Worthing and Shoreham
for the work that he's already done with
government in respect of safe and legal
routes as we heard during the evidence
we took at the Joint Committee on human
rights in the passage of the nationality
and borders act the existence of a safe
and legal alternative for those who wish
to claim asylum in the UK
is one of the defenses open to the
government and seeking to treat those
who arrive here for example in a small
boat with a less advantageous process
but Demers I'd like to focus my
contribution in particular
around what I fear are some of the
unintended consequences of a piece of
legislation which we all support the
objective of of making sure that we end
the situation where people are putting
their lives at risk who are facing death
or serious harm in the English Channel
as a consequence of seeking to come to
the United Kingdom that being the only
place in which they can Lodge an asylum
claim in our country and in particular
I'd like to focus on the way in which
this bill interacts with some of the
positive obligations on our public
authorities that are created in other
legislation for example the children act
and all of the Allied legislations such
as the leaving Care Act and as the right
honorable member for maidenhead has
outlined the provisions contained in the
modern slavery Act
my experience of this in local
government in particular is highlighted
by the Hillingdon Judgment of 2003 which
concerned the children act
responsibilities of local authorities in
respect of unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children and what that judgment
clarified
was that the immigration status of a
child is irrelevant to the local
Authority's obligations to provide
support to that children that child both
under the children act when they're
under 18 and as they enter adulthood
through the leaving Care Act another
legislation which we have passed in this
house so we know when we considered the
status of children in care we were very
clear that we wanted them to enjoy
support until they were at least 25 to
make sure that they started out their
lives in the most positive way having
spent some time during my days with the
local government Association in a room
with officials from the home office and
the department for education
became very clear that the home office
was aware and has always been aware
that the challenge that this legislation
sets up is that when a direction is
issued to a local authority to say this
child is subject to immigration control
and therefore they need to go through
this different process the next step
that is likely to follow is that that
child's lawyers will take the local
authority to a judicial review and the
local Authority will be found as they
have been umpteen times over the years
to be in breach of their children act
obligations if they fail to pursue the
best interests of the child and if they
fail to provide the services which they
are obliged to under that legislation
and by the same token I have a concern
partly stemming from the evidence we
took recently The Joint Committee on
human rights from the Salvation Army and
others about modern slavery
that those organizations that have first
responder duties who come across someone
in the course of policing or local
Authority housing or whatever it may be
who is possibly a victim of modern
slavery they have a duty they have an
obligation
to make a referral to the National
referral mechanism so that that person's
needs and circumstances can be
considered and nothing in this bill as
it currently stands removes that
obligation so similarly we would expect
to find potentially compensation having
to be paid because those public
authorities have failed in those duties
despite the fact that they were doing so
at the direction of the home office in
compliance with a piece of immigration
legislation and I strongly urge the
government that we need to resolve this
and ensure that we don't have a
situation where the objective of the
legislation which most of us share of
bringing about an end of those small
Boat Crossings and a more efficient
system for supporting people who come to
the UK to seek Asylum and to remove
those who have no right to be here is
not brought into distribute by the fact
that some of these Provisions inevitably
lead to an enormous tangle of judicial
reviews where public bodies may be
required to pay compensation for failing
duties where those Duties are in
conflict with other legislation passed
by this house and in particular in
respect of unaccompanied children
and we need to recall that the children
act says that a local Authority takes on
responsibility of caring for an
unaccompanied minor not as would be the
case if that child arose through uh
being born in the UK and the subject of
a care order but they do so by operation
of law so that local Authority does not
have the discretion to decide whether it
wishes to take that child into its care
or Not by dint of the fact that that
child is in that local Authority's area
and is not accompanied by an adult with
legal responsibility parental
responsibility for them they are in the
care of that local Authority and even if
that comes to light subsequently when
that child is an adult and a care lever
they are still subject to that
legislation and that is a matter which
has been established a number of times
through judicial review now the home
office has no legal capacity to care for
a child so even a child who is in
Immigration detention pending removal by
the home office will still be in the
care of the local Authority Under the
terms of the 1989 children act so once
again I think we need to make sure we
have absolutely Clear Sight of how those
duties and responsibilities will be
charge for example will detention
centers for children be regulated
inspected by offset I give way I thank
the young James for giving way and I
recognize his
so the challenge of what we've seen over
the last year in the treatment of both
unaccompanied and accompanied children
is that it is impossible for local
authorities to undertake that
safeguarding roll the duties in the
children's Act without the direct
involvement of the home office which is
discharging its duties in terms of
commissioning providers for example who
do not then have clear safeguarding
responsibilities the decision to do that
lies with the home office the home
office wrote contracts that did not
include safeguarding provision for these
children and so unless we are clear that
everybody involved in the care for these
children from start to finish has a
responsibility for their welfare
including the Secretary of State as new
Clause 18 does that Gap will remain and
in that Gap we have seen some horrific
examples of what happens to children not
just in terms of their access to
education but sexual assault and also
other serious offenses
I think very clearly highlights the fact
that there is a degree sometimes of gray
area on this point and I can completely
understand the position of the home
office and that in those early days
where there is literally nowhere else
for that child to go to have a roof over
their head sometimes in that emergency
situation the accommodation and support
that's provided does not meet the
standards that apply but ensuring as our
laws require that we very swiftly move
to a situation where it does seems to be
a reasonable expectation and certainly
one which will be upheld by the courts
and I think the point also draws
attention to the situation of children
who are in transit through the United
Kingdom who come to be unaccompanied
children because the adults with whom
they are traveling are themselves
arrested or found to have no direct
responsibility for the child through
which they're traveling and as I know
remember Hazen Hollington will be aware
over the years at Heathrow Airport
significant numbers of children who are
unaccompanied who come into the care of
a local Authority not because they
seeking Asylum but because for example
they're being trafficked into the sex
trade in the continent from another
country by way of the United Kingdom and
again we need to ensure that appropriate
care and support is provided for those
children and young people and they are
not simply placed into a process which
is focused on immigration control when
the circumstances by which they come
into the United Kingdom are where they
are being trafficked for other nefarious
purposes now all of these issues are
clearly fixable and I'm confident that
the government once cited on them will
be able to bring about their resolution
yep take me so I just like to finish but
with a note in respect of the issue of
notwithstanding Clauses which I know is
much debated yesterday and one of the
challenges that I find in respect of
that element of this debate is of course
there are a number of elements of this
legislation like the children act like
the modern slavery act where it would be
possible for the government to say that
notwithstanding those Provisions they
expect this home office process to be
followed and clearly those are all
matters that are within the legislation
of the United Kingdom that is passed by
this Sovereign Parliament but it seems
to me there is a risk if we seek to
introduce notwithstanding Clauses to
matters which are the subject of
international law and of course any of
us who've been the subject of the
recipient of legal advice at any time in
our working lives will be aware if we
were to be offered a contract that said
the other party has decided that
notwithstanding what it says in the
contract they don't have to follow it if
they choose not to after the event that
we would not regard that is in any way
sound and therefore it seems to me there
is a significant risk that if we seek to
apply notwithstanding Clauses that we
get ourselves once again into a legal
and reputational Tangle that would be
more broadly addressed by looking at
whether those International conventions
are still fit for purpose today I'll
give way I'm very grateful dead
yes right he'll understand that I have
raised I've been a signatory to one of
these uh amendments and obviously it's
to make it very clear that our concern
is around these rule 39 interim measure
orders which yes are not legally binding
were also not part of any convention
signed back in the 1950s but of course
are far too often taken into account by
UK domestic courts when it comes to the
deportation or removal of individuals so
you can understand therefore why even
members like myself will have signed
such an amendment in order to make it
very clear to UK courts that these
non-legally binding into a measures
should not be taken into account
I entirely understand I think what the
member for Stoke-on-Trent North
kidsgroven talk uh was seeking to
achieve through the introduction of
those notwithstanding Clauses we know
and we heard a great deal about this and
the evidence The Joint Committee on
human rights without shouting borders
act on the issue of the margin of
appreciation the idea that perhaps the
courts have gone further and interpreted
the meaning of some of those conventions
than was the case originally and often
that is under pressure from
parliamentarians including British
parliamentarians who have argued at the
Parliamentary assembly of the cancer of
Europe that supervises its operations
that some of these laws needed to go
further to take account of modern
circumstances so the way in which to
address those is not to say that we
somehow seek to set aside the
obligations which we freely signed up to
but rather to go and have that wider
debate with our International partners
and if necessary to say we wish to see
an end to this process in order to make
sure that what we feel we originally
intended to achieve is what is achieved
by The Village
just to clarify the purpose of the
notwithstanding Amendment it's not to
say that we are not going to not going
to comply with International obligations
it's to say that while these
negotiations are going on as he says
that's what happens when a a judgment is
made by the court against the government
while that negotiation is going on the
policy shall proceed it's to stop the
idea that the adjustment of the Court
would have direct effect and effectively
stop the flock ground the flights which
is what we're talking about which is
what happened off that entry order so
whether it's an interim order or
substantive judgment the point is that
that order should not immediately have
direct effect to stop the policy does he
accept that that's an appropriate way to
pursue
again I think that's an extremely good
point I think it's one of the
frustrations many of us who had some
involvement with in particular the echr
in the past will have felt at that point
because we recognized that interim
orders are not legally binding when they
are issued however the basis as I
understand it of that interim order was
that our own UK courts had not completed
their consideration of whether the
policy was lawful or not and therefore
the European Court of Human Rights was
saying whilst you have still not
yourselves decided whether this is
lawful it is not appropriate to proceed
against somebody in a way that would
leave them without a remedy so it seems
to me there is a way of resolving this
but the means the route to resolve it is
through colleagues in particular at the
Parliamentary assembly who have the
ability to bring about a significant
change in that so let me just finish
Dame Rosie um with a point which I've
called for the product which I'm going
to suggest again that the government
looks at and that is that we extend the
process which we currently use in
respect of our resettlement schemes
where we have United Nations High
Commissioner for refugees administering
a process where we tell them how many
people we think as a country we can
accommodate and who it is that we feel
best able to support in consultation
with local authorities and those people
then travel to the UK knowing full well
from the point they leave to the point
they arrive how they're going to be
accommodated and support it a number of
people determined by this Parliament
their circumstances vetted in advance
before they arrive permission issued by
the government of the United Kingdom in
control of our borders and it is my
argument Dan Murphy that if we want to
stop the boats we want to have a new
Asylum system that really gives us
control of our borders then we need an
asylum Visa system that operates in this
way that is robust effective and ensures
that this Parliament our government is
genuinely in control of our borders
once again I would urge a certain amount
of brevity as we're not doing
brilliantly at the minute on being able
to get everybody John McDonald
as brief as I can as much that I
absolutely loathe in this bill but I
want to concentrate on children's
attention as well I support amendments
in my own name 71
143145-144220
as well
the reason I want to speak on this is
because
I'm not sure how many members have
actually had experience of having
children locked up in their constituency
in the way that the member for roughly
in Chapman's house and the same with my
uncle stitches here and I also I was a
house part of a small unit children's
home for a period of years near Heathrow
as well and I think it's important that
members fully understand and appreciate
the consequences of their actions in
supporting this legislation in my
constituency I've got two detention
centers farmersworth and conbrook prior
to 2012 children and their families were
detained In Harm's worth in particular
they were they were locked in they were
imprisoned the last report in the Her
Majesty's inspector of Prisons described
the setting in Palmers with as Bleak and
prison-like than it is
the expense of the regime is Harsh we've
had suicide and we had another death in
comb Brook last Sunday
it's been referred to in Harmons worth
with riots the place has been burnt down
twice
when the children were there like the
member of opening Chapman I visited
and I'll tell you the story of one of my
visits at Harmons with when the children
were detained in in Harmons with we had
a small classroom to deal with children
and they were primary and secondary age
and it was heartbreaking now on one
occasion I visited they'd had a poetry
lesson and they chose to write a poem on
subjects of their choice
one of the young girls wrote us on the
subject of freedom she wrote freedom is
the Sound Outside the gate
broke my heart seeing these children
locked up in that way
all the experts I've spoken to
the teachers the child psychologists the
doctors they all reported the impact I
was having in traumatizing these
children often scarring them for life
we've also demonstrated time and time
again from the various research reports
of the children's experiences that they
actually suffer from post-traumatic
stress disorder
their experiences in detention were
exacerbated obviously and piled on top
of what many had already experienced in
their country of origin which forced
them and their families to flee and also
their experiences on the journey here
and what they've gone through in one
children's Society report at the time
the expression was used
state-sponsored cruelty
so I'm grateful to forgiving me because
this is so important you know it's there
are so few of us now you remember what
it was actually like when children are
coming here they are thrown into
association with some of the worst
people imaginable
for night the people that I saw in the
evil some of them absolutely needed to
be in detention but the idea of holding
them in the same facility as children
just took that in humanity to another
level
exactly in the children's home as a
house father of we dealt with some of
the children that had been coming from
detention and we understood the traumas
that they've gone through
before 2010 just to remind the house
many of us on a cross-party basis
conservative labor liberals and and
others campaigned to end child attention
because the numbers were increasing year
on year once you establish the principle
it's interesting how the numbers
increased at one point there was an
estimate in the Isles worth of a
thousand Children and Families
the campaigns made this an issue in the
run-up to the general election of 2010
and some of us many of us signed a
commitment as a commitment to make this
country a place of sanctuary and thank
god what happened was people of this
country woke up to what we were doing to
children and the way children were being
treated children societies reports
evidence the individual experiences of
the children as well as the research we
made that Sanctuary pledge citizens UK
some people remember and other religious
bodies and Community groups and trade
unions all came together in one Mass
campaign and we had a huge breakthrough
after the election David Cameron was
convinced and supported by yes Nick
Clegg and yes she's not in a place at
the right honorable member maidenhead
and after over a decade ago we ended we
ended with unanimity in this house the
detention the routine Detention of
children
no more children were imprisoned in
harms within my constituency or any
other Detention Center or prison-like
facilities and then we took that pledge
and we enacted it in legislation
cross-party support in 2014.
there were some exceptions obviously and
I regretted some of those but I can
understand some reasons why there were
small number of
pre-departure accommodations provided
but no one was no child was left in a
Detention Center
this bill I'm afraid whatever the
minister has said it removes those
protections it removes those protections
we arrived at cross-party unanimously
over a decade ago
so my plea to this house is just please
do not take us back to those barbaric
days the lives of children are
devastated and the estimate is eight
thousand children faced attention as a
result of this legislation under the
proposals in this bill
it will create lasting almost
irrecoverable damage to those children
and I just appeal in all Humanity for
the house to reject these proposals
Jonathan gullis thank you very much Dane
Rosie and I Rise to speak in for the
amendments in my name amendments one
three five which intends to block courts
from ordering individuals to be returned
to the UK once removed and Amendment 136
was intended to restrict the use of
hotels and of course had my name to
other amendments which were debated
yesterday that I'm proud to support and
I want to first of all Dame Rosie uh
thank the minister the right time for
Newark for his insurances he gave
yesterday evening at the dispatch box
through meaningful engagement over the
Easter recess to find a way forward on
the Amendments that I have signed or in
my name and I look forward to working
with him and the colleagues like my
honorable friend uh the member for
devises for Middlesbrough and Southeast
Cleveland uh Stone and South Holland and
the deepings and I will therefore not be
pushing any of my amendments to a vote
this evening it is absolutely critical
that this policy is delivered that's
because in Stoke on Trend we know better
than anyone when it comes to generosity
having now 1279
and Seekers or illegal economic migrants
within our great City having long term
been a member of the voluntary Asylum
dispersal scheme and having now 30 of
that population purely in hotels in
inappropriate places directly opposite
our railway station right by leveling up
projects undermining the work to
regenerate and level up the great city
of Stoke-on-Trent it is a bond that this
has been going on and for far too long
Stoke on Trent has been at the Forefront
when it comes to stepping up and
delivering in fact was the fifth largest
contributor to the Asylum dispersal
scheme and was voted the kindest city in
the United Kingdom only last year so we
as a city will do our fair share but it
is inappropriate that we continue to see
over 40 000 people illegally choose
through smuggling guns bring thousands
of pounds in those Smuggler's hands
already when they're in safe Mainland
France to come across on small boats and
needlessly risking their own lives and
making sure that obviously they
undermine our UK Visa system them
undermining the rights of our borders
undermining therefore the democracy and
sovereignty of this house and is
absolutely essential that we do
everything we can because when people
voted 73 to leave the European Union
they want to take back control of their
laws and their borders and they will be
out people and Stoke on Trent North kids
we're going to talk about outraged when
they see only yesterday that the Council
of Europe's Commission of your human
rights interfering in this place giving
their opinion from Strasbourg and
Brussels demanding that we vote this
legislation down is yet again foreign
dignitaries and foreign judges trying to
interfere with the Democratic rights and
processes of our great country and it is
simply not acceptable to see that happen
and is on why it is so important that
the member for devises amendment is
taken as seriously and I would like to
see it fully supported because
ultimately we must make sure that we
deliver on this important legislation
but I will of course then Rosie get to
the purpose of my amendments and our
happily take an intervention right to
the end-day museum I promise to keep
within the 10 minute limit that you
asked for me
Amendment 135 is about the block of
returns and if we're going to make sure
that we have offshoring of illegal
migrants to take place we cannot see
people returned to our United Kingdom
because it will simply undermine the
Rwanda policy and other I hope World
leading schemes that we will agree with
uh are the third safer countries as well
as and I support the opposition in
wanting to see safe uh in wanting to see
safely routes and see returns agreements
and like many people I was outraged that
we gave 500 million pounds of UK
taxpayers money without getting a
returns agreement with France directly
so I fully endorse what I want uh what
we want to see there but it is
absolutely essential that we therefore
make sure that in law it is made clear
that if someone does try to make a
last-minute claim to an upper tribunal
that they went even if they are removed
they have no right to return they may
indeed win damages in court but that
right to return is not granted because
if it is granted it will simply
undermine the imagery will be shocking
it will be used by Smugglers across
Mainland Europe as an advert for what
could happen if people were lucky and of
course with hotels it is very essential
as well that we deliver in this
important policy space because rightly
the British public are livid to see six
million pounds a day of their
hard-earned British taxpayers money
going to House people in hotels tofionic
suit unacceptable in places like I say
so content where we have a thriving
hospitality and tourism sector
undermines therefore by the use of these
hotels people losing their jobs people
losing at certain hotels the ability to
go to the swimming baths where they took
their children to learn how to swim
beginning to be unable to go to the gym
for the access for the facilities that
was there because sadly this a boring
trade has carried on in Staffordshire as
a whole it's now uh nine hotels that
have been taken up and it's not
something that any of us in this house
want to see and I hope therefore this
will get widespread support and I know
the minister and I thank him for his
engagement and the fact that there will
be plans coming forward soon to announce
alternative bases or places that can be
used to move people out of hotels and I
was delighted that when I had my
petition presented to the floor of this
house and gathered over 2 000 signatures
to end circo's abuse of Stoke-on-Trent
that we saw therefore that continued
movement from the minister and the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary to find
suitable accommodation for the short
term whilst we are implementing I hope
very soon the policy to get people
deported and removed to safer countries
such as Rwanda I did random deck so you
could promise The Honorable lady
intervention I will give away
I thank you in general for giving away
and as he gathers his breath he made a
very strong case there that he was
concerned about the work of the European
Court of Human Rights making judgments
about overbearing governments and trying
to stand up for Citizens I wonder
therefore does he also deplore the
recent judgment made by the European
Court of Human Rights another rule 39
interim measure in the case of Pinner
versus Russia and Aslan versus Russia
and Ukraine which was concerning British
Nationals who were members of the Armed
Forces in Ukraine who'd surrendered to
Russian forces and been sentenced to
death so the European Court of Human
Rights got stuck in to stand up for
British citizens but I presume on his
logic there he would oppose them doing
that because he doesn't like the role of
these bodies standing up for Citizens
being oppressed by governments the
European course of human rights man no
speaker when we signed the Convention as
we did back in 1950 these were all 39
injury measures were not something that
were part of the the treaty that we
signed and it's important to remember
this is a treaty and whilst we signed up
and have treaty obligations to oblige to
that should not ever Trump the
sovereignty of this Parliament and not
Trump the sovereignty of what happens in
this place because we are democratically
elected parliamentarians who speak on
behalf of our constituents well on this
side of the house we do anyway and it's
so important to understand why therefore
we deliver the policy and when the
honorable lady talks about the European
Court of Human Rights let's not forget
then last 10 years 47 of echr judgments
haven't been complying with in Spain
it's at 61 and in Germany it's a 37 the
UK I believe was at 18 so we're actually
better upholding our echr obligations
than most of our main and European
countries which I know the honorable
lady is a huge fan of and would love to
see us return to the European Union as
she so avidly campaign form continues to
privately I'm sure make the case for
with internal parliamentary labor party
and I commend her for that bravery to
take that brave star but of course the
people of so content North kids scream
and talk simply said no go away bye-bye
labor for hopefully decades to come
after 70 years of failure neglect and
under investment in our great area but
Madam speaker back sorry not mad Dame
Rosie back to the uh discussion here
today it's important to understand that
when we are talking about these blocks
and I want to thank Professor Richard
eakins of Oxford University and uh sir
and uh for his work with answer Stephen
laws Casey in helping myself and other
colleagues with the policy exchange to
be able to put forward the work that we
have done today because that's not to
forget that when we talk about these
hotels it is simply not appropriate as I
say when people are losing their jobs
it's damaging the hospitality sector
it's damaging the tourism sector of our
towns of our cities undermining
confidence in the public of our ability
to deliver on this policy and there are
disused army bases that could be used I
personally haven't no issue with Porter
cabins or tents being used at all this
is still perfectly acceptable
accommodation that can be used in a
short-term entry measure as long as we
deliver on the policy that we have said
to do which is to make sure after 28
days people are to be removed to a safe
Third Country such as Rwanda a country
that is perfectly safe and so far
welcome the fact that the UK government
has been so successful in UK domestic
courts to explain our well-being policy
is something that we should be
celebrating because ultimately this
shows that this government does
understand and despite the uh the
shutter Minister implementing the fact
that this government is worried about
whether or not it's compliant while the
fact that it's winning Court battles on
other legislation that was deemed to be
on the line I would suggest shows that
this government has confidence that it
will be on that side again and
ultimately The Honorable gentleman talks
about a labor plan one that I'm still
searching for other than processing
people more quickly which means we still
continue to accept seven out of 10 70 of
40 25000 would be completely
unacceptable to people about United
Kingdom would absolutely drive more
people into making sure that they are
able to uh The Smuggler is able to
advertise the opportunity the 70 success
rates of coming over here and that's why
many amendments laid before uh the delay
party today I'm unable to support
because obviously with the only
exception being that treat me Madam
speaker was uh new Clause I've got a
number of it but the new Causeway it
talks about engagement local authorities
but the assurances that the minister
gave the dispatch book yesterday to one
of my honorable friends who laid a
similar Amendment uh gave me the
confidence to believe that I won't be
able to join them in the lobby today but
I'm delighted that we had someone like
Carl Slappy Brown who was brave enough
to force this government to make sure
that all local authorities will be part
of the assigned dispersal scheme no
longer voluntarily opting in having
threatened to obviously legally withdraw
uh from that uh earlier so Damien thank
you for your time sorry for the one
minute it's over
Hal Williams
thank you uh
I would have liked to say it's a
pleasure to follow the honorable
judgment but supposedly I can't
um I Rise to speak to myself because
29 standing my name and the name of uh
by formal honorable friends and kind of
say firstly that I share the wish of
people across the house let's just see
the end of uh small boats crossing the
channel but this particular Bill
actually is an affront to the values of
my own party and so many people in Wales
and across the UK it sat holds with the
objectives and the spirits of
international human rights cities I wish
the UK is a secondary and it's also
Consolidated to the wishes of the Welsh
government for Wales to be a nation of
sanctuary this bill is contrary to the
democratically expressed will of the
people of Wales and had we our own way
is not not supply in my country that is
why my party is stable new Clause 29
which would require firstly that's the
weekend Welsh governments to jointly
produce guidance setting out how these
measures under this act would be
exercised in a way which is consistent
with the Welsh government's commitments
uh to Wales being initiative sanctuary
and secondly that those such guidance
could be published unless it had been
approved by seneth
indeed the Welsh government has already
listened to the UK government to say
that they believe legislative consents
will most likely be needed for the spill
as it will encroach a Welsh developed
law this is just one example there are
Provisions to allow for the transfer of
children from local authority
responsibility so that's of the home
office this may well lead to children
being cared for in Wales on turning 18
being similarly deported
this would undermine the aims of Welsh
legislation such as the social services
and well-being act Wales Act of 2014
which sets out the responsibilities of
local authorities
towards and a complete Asylum seeking
children in Wales
we also have a particular concern about
Clause 12 which allows the Secretary of
State to detain their Fugees and Asylum
Seekers essentially indefinitely the
government has made it clear that they
will be looking to use military camps as
one source of accommodation now there is
real evidence as to the danger of
detaining refugees on mass in this way
we saw that with the use of the penalty
camp in Pembroke show where a
substandard and run down sites was used
to house hundreds of Asylum speakers
over the winter of 2020
they were appalling conditions for them
huge concern locally and it was a
lightning rod for the very worst of the
extreme rights traveling to finale from
afar it demonstrates and causing huge
disruption is the government's really
heedless of this danger as he just as
the Ministers of my speech apparently
um at this point I just make
one small point I'll pay tribute to the
people of Venice devour also known as
Stanford's major who last weekend turned
out in the hundreds to assert our
welcome for refugees in Wales and our
bonds at the Hard rights last weekend
the people of
peacefully saw off the pathetic Rubble
of about 20 right-wing strangers burst
in ostensibly to protest against housing
Ukrainian refugees locally and share the
people of Saint Bauer and the people of
Wales account to live in the cloud of
because the country of refuge and I
poured their peaceful demonstration uh
to the Jack The Vicious and
unrepresentative few who seek to hijack
the issue for their own supposedly
political ends
chair constantly to the title of the
spill nobody is illegal claiming Asylum
is an international human rights
desperate people arriving in the UK by
whatever means they can because there
are no safe routes should not be
criminalized there is much more I could
say but for now I assure the house and
people listening at home and watching at
home that my past will be opposing this
vicious unfair and damaging bill again
in the division lobbies tonight
John Hayes thank you
yeah which you've found their form in
contributions from the ventures opposite
during the course of our consideration
of this bill so far and perhaps
principle amongst them is that there is
no factual basis which has provoked this
legislation that is simply not so
since 2018 from 85 000 people have been
to Britain illegally 45
000 of them in 2022 alone suddenly five
percent roughly I think it's actually
just under 74 are men under 40 nearly
nine out of 10 of those are rising a
male 18 are Albanian and armadians make
up 10 by the way of the foreign prisoner
population that's 2 000 of them
and 100
have traveled through safe countries in
which they could have claimed asylum in
order to get here accommodating these
people is costing the British taxpayer
three billion pounds per year
and that is why we urge an action to
deal with the crossing of the channel
but more fundamentally still to reform
our Asylum system to make it fit for
purpose and to cut immigration not just
illegal immigration by the way I say to
the uh Minister on the front bench
because we will need to turn to Legal
immigration to during the course of this
Parliament
as uh well I'm not I I've forgiven you
and I I've got a great respect for The
Honorable gentleman but I promised Dane
Rosie that I will be brief and if I take
interventions I know that won't be true
and I will break my promise and she'll
never forgive me I'm worse still she
won't call me again
um so um I I won't so I forgive me
so I would have tweaked the amendments
in my name which I hope will help the
government in that endeavor the
Amendments tabled by uh in my name and
in the name of the only one of the Trent
North and uh Stone and uh uh other
constituencies too are designed to
improve the bill they're not designed to
frustrate the government's efforts
indeed they are are framed in order to
make the bill work for the bill must
work
the British people are at the end of
their tether tired of a liberal
establishment which is blinded by its
own prejudices well which seems
oblivious of the needs of working class
britons but ever more indulgent
towards economic migrants or anyone else
that comes from abroad for that matter
and and the British people you demand
and deserve something better than that
they deserve a government that takes
their concerns seriously and just in
case there's any doubts about those
concerns
um I refer members of the house to the
work of professor Matthew Goodwin who
has studied these matters the uh
professor of Politics the University of
Kent who revealed that uh an immense
number of Voters in so-called red wall
constituations you remember uh those are
the seats that labor hopes to win back
by the way but they won't because
they're in the hands of very able
conservative members of parliament uh
many of whom uh take the similar view to
me about this feeling including my
honorable friend who spoke a few moments
ago from strogan friend North
interestingly in those constituencies 59
of people think that we should withdraw
the right of Asylum Seekers and illegal
migrants across the channel illegal in
small boats to appeal against their
deportation that number jumps to three
quarters of uh 2019 conservative voters
and 39 of Labor voters in those
constituencies a large majority 1610
support quote stopping migrants in small
birds from illegally crossing the
channel using any means necessary
Benjamin Israeli said Justice is truth
in action and what my Amendment 283 is
designed to do is to restore Justice to
our Asylum system by affirming the truth
this epitomizes the anger felt by my
constitutions and many others
about the unfairness
of the system than those economic
migrants with no right to be here
legally who arrived in Dover claiming to
be younger there are in order to gain
our Asylum rules as the right honorable
member for Whitton pointed out when she
was Home Secretary
two-thirds of age dispute cases have
found the individual claim to be a child
is actually over the age of 18. and
sometimes considerably over this is a
widespread problem
Amendment 2000 at sorry 283 which is a
scientific age assessment which ensure
those under 18 who need to seek shelter
here can do so as well as finding out
those over 80 who lie to cheat our rules
Mr Speaker this amendment is in keeping
with practices used in Europe by
countries which verify ages of those
crossing their borders the scientific
age assessment used in many European
countries these purposes include dental
and risk x-rays in France than the
Norway CT scans or MRI imaging used in
Sweden Denmark and elsewhere
I I'd be amazed uh to be frank if anyone
who believes in the Integrity of our
solar system would it pose such an
amendment and I hope that the minister
when he sums up will confirm that the
government intend indeed to adopt it
without such a change we cannot properly
break the business model of people's
lovers these vowel travels will simply
tell people whose lives they are risking
to lie about their age in order to
prevent them being removed turning to
amendments one two nine and 130 my name
both strength the bill by ensuring that
those who have no right to be here or
swiftly removed are present the language
of the bill promises to deport however
in law deportation is a distinct legal
process from removal deportation is
reserved for those who quote are a risk
to the public good typically foreign
National offenders by contrast removal
is the legal term for a process by which
certain people may be removed from the
UK usually because they breach
engravement Rules by remaining here
illegally but they don't necessarily
pose a public risk or danger by so doing
I hope the again the minister will enter
into discussion with me about how we can
improve the bill in that way by making
it more effective I know too that the
minister will look at those amendments
which are a which aim to toughen the
bill further in terms of language the
amendment one through five live in the
name of the member of socon Trent is
vital as it will block courts rewarding
individuals moved are removed to return
to the UK so if those removed to Rwanda
are allowed to return following legal
challenges the deterring gain from
successfully sending them there will be
diluted or lost altogether it's
essential that those who want to train
the small boats and the Smugglers
organize their dangerous Journeys know
that the deterrent is credible
Amendment 132 would uh sure that other
Provisions human rights are disapplied
and and honorable members and right
along with us will know my view on the
Human Rights Act I would repeal it they
will know my view on the convention I
would leave it but that is not what
we're saying today not what we're
debating and not what these amendments
seek to do
they simply aim to ensure the
government's policy
found form in this bill and I hope uh
soon to be an act is not once again
mired by appeals to foreign potentates
who will
foreigntates and Powers who will
frustrate the will of the government
this house and more fundamentally the
British people I won't come on and
Amendment 139 or 140 in the name of the
only one Worthing of forum except to say
that they are arguably well intentioned
uh uh
but not necessarily so
a report last year as the honor woman
for Worthington must know showed that
nearly two-thirds of some suspected of
lying when they were when they were
unaccompanied children were found over
18. of course care matters sentiment
matters we must exercise sense to avoid
being naive about this subject uh I went
for the sake of brevity uh day Rosie say
much more except to conclude in this way
the British people want to deal with the
boats they want to restore order to our
borders they believe in the Integrity of
a system which determines whether
someone is a genuine seeker of asylum in
fear of persecution in profound need or
someone who is an economic migrant
gaming the system with the age and by
the way just a quick word about judicial
activism it's a well-established uh it's
a well-established concept and I advise
the I'm going to read about it in more
detail since he hasn't seemed to have
heard of it
that's what the British people want
that's what this bill will do and we
must I say to the minister avoid
listening to the bleats and cries
liberal establishment who will Who will
go out of their way
and go out of their way to stop the
government doing what is just and is
right I look forward to further
engagement with him and on that basis
assuming that he says something
sufficiently generous indeed slightly
more than that I'd like to feel
flattering I will be withdrawing your
members to stand in my name yeah
thank you madam Deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to follow a knight of the realm
lecturing all of us on being in touch
with the people and class class Warfare
what a what a lesson what a what a
dystopian Vision he paints of this
country let me confine myself to the
three amendments in my name because I
said very clearly and I'll say again he
does not speak for the majority in this
country actually in his callous
disregard of people seeking sanctuary
and in his callous disregard for the
actual evidence or facts and I want to
come on to that but let's start with
Amendment 293 which I believe reflects
the challenge that he sets and indeed
the challenge that the member from Stoke
set when he complained about
um people with visas he must be
disappointed then that a bill that's
called the illegal migration Bill does
nothing about people overstaying their
visas who are committing a clearly
illegal offense if this bill actually
were about things that were illegal in
our Asylum system it would tackle the
those Visa over stairs it says nothing
about those people who actually people
traffic there's no further sanctions no
efforts in this legislation to actually
help catch the people in those organized
crying grams indeed may I possibly
realize why there isn't given his
absolute objection to a European Court
standing up for British citizens who are
facing the death penalty couldn't even
possibly say that was a good thing to
stop people being sent to death for
standing up to Putin but this bill says
nothing about the the liaison with
Europe that we would need to be able to
catch those people so I've tabled
Amendment 293 because this house this
chamber should not be running the
government's election campaign and it
should not be passing legislation which
is not actually about anything illegal
because it is not illegal to seek Asylum
and we will keep saying that and keep
reminding the British public of that and
that therefore this legislation is just
about the the conservative party getting
its Leaf that's done on the cheap by
getting them done in this house so
Amendment 293 is to remove the word
illegal from the bill of the title
because Bill doesn't cover illegal
behavior and indeed doesn't cover the
illegal elements of our Asylum system
that we should be dealing with and I'm
sure members opposite would want to deal
with
um
secondly Amendment 138 is about safe
routes now we had the discussion about
this yesterday and the minister
challenged me was outraged that I would
suggest that they were not safe and
legal routes because after all if we're
having a bill about illegal Behavior
Quit It quotes on there needs to be a
legal system in order to un underpin
that and the minister particularly
claimed to me that the 6 000 people from
Iran who had claimed Asylum here and
that was reflecting a safe and legal it
was in direct response to my question
and that matters for Amendment 138
because Amendment 138 is about all of a
safe and legal route exists surely that
should be part of the decision-making
process as to whether we give somebody
Asylum so it very simply sets out that
when somebody seeks Asylum you can
reject their claim if you can show the
safe and legal route they should have
taken to come here and to look at the
figures but let's look at the figures
for what the minister claimed on the
record he said the UK has taken more
than six thousand Iranians directly for
Asylum purposes actually when we look at
the Home Offices figures their own home
office figures on people who have
actually been granted Asylum under a
safe illegal route from Iran since 2015
it's 59 not six thousand six thousand
refers to the number of people who've
had a family reunion family reunion is
not a safe and legal route and the fact
that the immigration Minister doesn't
understand that let's put it in layman's
terms and maybe he'll get the answer on
this a safe and legal route is for
somebody right now in Tehran standing up
to that government the people on the
benches opposite people want to stand
with being able to leave it's not for
somebody who had the wherewith or
perhaps to marry somebody and then get
that person to leave the country ahead
of being able to be a democracy
campaigner if the minister for
immigration himself doesn't understand
that family reunion visas are not the
same as a safe and legal route what hope
have we got for this legislation what
hope have we got that is being open with
Parliament about the numbers of people
this government has helped if he thinks
it's a safely legal route he doesn't
understand even what the Ukrainian
system is which he's supposed to be
overseeing it so Amendment 138 is about
trying to say if a safe and legal route
exists it should be part of the
decision-making process it seems are
relatively straightforward process but
given that the government doesn't know
what a safe and legal route is to be
able to implement one I can understand
why they might object it let me then
turn to Amendment new Clause 18 which
really ought to be a no-brainer if we
are the decent
possibly liberal but I would just say
British and patriotic society that
doesn't like to see children suffer for
the decisions that their parents make
new Clause 18 is about the duties of
safeguarding now I can see that the
minister isn't going to look me in the
eye on this because he and I have had
several meetings about his failure to
oversee the safeguarding of children and
they are indeed children in hotels
whether they are accompanied by their
parents or carers or whether they are
unaccompanied children who've
experienced sexual assault because of
failures of safeguarding in the hotels
in this country children who've not had
education places children who've not had
clothes on their back apart from those
that they fled with to cope with the
British weather children who have gone
missing hundreds of them who have not
been found
the government will point to the
children's act and say this is all about
local government the safeguarding of
these children cannot be done without
the active involvement of the home
office and what we've seen to date shows
that very clearly because those children
have gone missing because those children
have experienced sexual assault because
those children have not been in school
which I'm sure even the member from
Stoke would agree would be a good thing
for any child to be in school and
learning
new Clause 18 says that we should treat
every single child on you I I will
happily give away as long as he will
clarify on the record that his comments
about me were mistaken I'm sure he would
not wish to malign somebody's good
reputation even if he did disagree with
them
very grateful Dave Rosie I must say I
don't remember seeing the honorable lady
on the streets of the West Midlands
campaign to vote leave in the 2016
referendum so I feel confident my
comments about her being a pro-european
is perfectly acceptable in terms of the
children comments when the minister came
to the dispatch box before about the 200
missing children 95 of those were 16 to
17 years old an age in which traffickers
and Smugglers sorry Smugglers encourage
people who think they can get away with
looking at such an age are encouraged to
do 88 of those were albanians why would
any parent spend four and a half
thousand pounds to send their child
illegally on a small rubber boat when it
could go on an airplane for 30 pounds
and it's important to understand as well
that they missed to make it clear that
with those 200 there was no evidence
that anyone had been kidnapped that they
left of their own accord
uh the previous moment I'm sorry it's
not in his place who suggested that the
immigration Minister himself when he was
dismissing concerns about locking
children up because he was suggesting
that they probably weren't children
because of the the concerns about age
varication used a gentle phrase about
his mother might say have a long look in
the mirror I would suggest that the
member from Stoke gives his head a
wobble for what he has just said about
children who have gone missing 16 and 17
year olds are children 16 and 17 year
olds are children he's chuntering from a
sedentary position
if that child turns up I hope to
goodness that they all turn up safe and
well because if they don't what this
member has just said we'll come back to
haunt him now he can keep shouting all
he likes but the vast majority of the
British public are horrified by the idea
that 200 children Plus have gone missing
from hotels that the home office were
supposed to be overseeing the manston
center is due to have a public inquiry
the government has accepted that because
of article 3 breaches for concerns about
basically how we were treating pregnant
women young children coming into the
manston center but as yet that
investigation has not happened to be
able to inform this legislation Clause
11 extends detention for families and
pregnant women Clause 14 removes the
duty to consult the independent family
returns panel about the treatment of
children
children children under the age of 18.
we accept that in law and we have
Provisions in law around for example the
use of bed and breakfasts that have not
been mirrored in how we have treated
children to date who come in through
this system I can hear why from the
member from Stoke for his callous
disregard but I go back to that simple
principle whatever you think of the
parents of these children whatever you
think of the the parents of these
children punishing children by agreeing
in law
to have second-class citizenship which
is what this legislation will do to
Refugee children well The Minister's
shaking his head is a very simple answer
because all new Clause 18 does is commit
to parity it says we should treat every
single child on UK soil with the same
concerns that we could Safeguard every
single child I'll happily give Wayne and
I do want to finish up because I
promised Dame Rosie that I would be
brief but I'll happily give wave
safeguarding I I Thank The Honorable
lady for giving way and it and everyone
wants children to be safe nobody
anything wants a child in a hotel and
fundamentally nobody wants a child to
make a very dangerous Crossing in a
small boat the safest place for trials
is not to make that Crossings there are
safe and legal routes and that's what we
should try and focus on rather than
encouraging people some others to take
children on the channel that's the worst
thing for a child doesn't always agree
with that nobody is encouraging the
Smugglers and in the heat that's being
generated in this room I think it is
very important we recognize across the
house nobody supports the Smugglers
equally there aren't the safe and legal
routes and the example of Iran proves
that very clearly and the fact that the
minister doesn't seem to understand that
either is what's troubling to me so
we're left with a situation where if a
child does come here what happens to
them what new Clause 18 does is extend
the parity of how we treat other
children for example the rules around
bed and breakfast and where we would put
a child in with a a single adult for
example where we don't with a bed and
breakfast and in his constituents if he
were to find that he would probably
rightly challenge his local Authority
about it why are we saying that because
a child has refugees as parents it
doesn't matter how they are treated
which is what this legislation will do
so all new Clause 18 is looking for is
parity now the member from Stoke may
disregard those children but I waited
there are other members on the side who
do recognize that when it comes to
children we have responsibilities we
have obligations and I hope the minister
in summing up will just say on the
record yes absolutely the same standards
as safeguarding and the home office
having failed to put safeguarding in the
contracts it absolutely failed to
mention them because I had to foi the
contract from his Department to be able
to check it and I did check it because
the minister doesn't do the minister
doesn't do his own homework so somebody
else has to and it very clearly does not
mention it and I've read it's not a
fantasy what is a fantasy are the
figures that the homesick the Home
Secretary and indeed the minister just
came up with in terms of safe and legal
routes from Iran and perhaps he might
want to reflect on that and indeed what
the statistics Authority has said about
the home office's relationship with the
truth when it comes to the numbers and
Asylum I want to finish my statement
simply by urging the governments just to
say on the record if if I am wrong
correct me then say that every single
child in this country will be covered by
safeguarding and the home office itself
will take a direct safeguarding Duty for
these children it wouldn't be that
difficult I'm not going to give way he's
made his feelings clear even if he's
taken the Shelley's grandmother approach
to communicating any sense about them
what is modern matters now now is that
this government speaks up for every
single child because if we don't I
promise you there are people in this
house who will continue to do no matter
how much barracking we get because every
child matters
Ben Bradley thank you Dan Rosie uh
pledge to serve into your chairmanship
today uh to Echo all my friends from
South islands and zipping said earlier
in the statistics he provided about uh
how uh strongly people feel about this
issue 35 of all policy inquiries to my
office last week related to this issue
of illegal migration and small boats
people often ask me you're in the very
middle of the country in Mansfield why
do people care it is a simple matter of
fairness it's a massive government
commitment one of the prime minister's
key pledges to the people of this
country to tackle this issue of small
boats uh the people of Mansfield are
generous but they believe in the rules
they believe in Law and Order they're
happy to help those people who follow
the rules but when they are struggling
and they see people arriving or who are
facing genuine
um safeguarding issues genuine issues of
their personal safety and they see
others coming from a safe country of
France jumping the queue they feel the
unfairness of that when they are sat on
housing waiting lists and unable to get
a home but somebody who has no legal
right to be here is able to get
accommodation they feel that unfairness
it's very easy for us in this room uh
none of whom I would imagine rely
heavily on our public services to say
that there's no negative impact to all
of this but in reality if you are on
that housing waiting list and unable to
get a permanent home for yourself and
your family if you're struggling to
access primary care if you're told you
can't get the help you need if you're
sacked from your job at a hotel because
it's become a migrant accommodation
if you're seeing public funds intended
to support
um people in this country who are
struggling diverted to support people
who have no legal right to be in this
country then of course you feel the
unfairness and to suggest that that is
not a problem is to deny the experience
of many of my constituents and many
people around the country who feel that
very very strongly it's very grateful to
remember for giving way Dame Rosie The
Honorable a from Walton store was
talking about safeguarding as someone
who's a local Authority leader will he
agree with me that we all have reducing
yourself to safeguard the young people
of our country against people who we do
not have any documentation to prove the
age they have claimed upon arriving on
the shores of this United Kingdom
illegally and therefore until age
verification can be guaranteed we have
to make sure that those alleged children
and alleged until we can prove it are
not mixing with actually genuine uh
birth certificate holding UK residents
who we know are under the age of 18.
thank you for his interventions right I
do have that role and it does present
significant safeguarding it does present
significant resourcing challenges uh The
Honorable lady from Wilson snow said
earlier you know everyone should have a
right to education I don't know where
she thinks these School places just
emerged from because you can't plan for
hundreds of school places when people
arrive forty thousand in one year I've
got British children in my County unable
to access a school place near to their
home because of the sheer volume of
um of genuine asylumsy because we've
come from through genuine Roots who are
accessing those places instead I will
give away
the ramp project which funds A
researcher in my office has done a lot
of work on this issue I think that's my
honorable does he acknowledge that where
there is a young person who is of
statutory school age it is an absolute
legal obligation on a local authority to
ensure that they have that education and
if they fail to do so then that child is
eligible for compensation which is paid
out to the dedicated School Grant that's
affecting the budgets of all schools in
that area so does he agree with me that
it is absolutely vital that in this bill
we clarify exactly what the position is
of Channel Asylum Seekers so we know
whether they are within that children
that legislation or whether they somehow
fall outside I fully take on the
audience Point familiar thank you for
that intervention about
um who holds responsibility for applying
these duties and and how these mix
together and that's a complex issue and
one that I can't answer uh today but
he's absolutely right that we need to
make sure that we do Safeguard and
support children and that we offer them
all the sport that we can of course but
recognizing that we have a duty to as
I've said uh British citizens and
British children to supply those School
places uh and it can't be right as I've
said to the men the member opposite from
Autumn Stone to suggest that all of a
sudden these schools in these places and
these opportunities will just appear
because they don't give them away twice
already I'm really conscious of time
um One Last Time One Last Time very
briefly I'm just very valid points he's
making about the important role that
local authorities play will he therefore
be supporting our new Clause 27 when we
put it to the vote this evening that it
should be a legal requirement for the
home office to consult with local
authorities before making any
Arrangements on accommodation for Asylum
Seekers all right thank you for that
intervention and this was a challenge
that I raised in the house myself last
year I've since had many many
conversations with the department and
feel very reassured actually recently
that that communication has been far
better and I feel much more confident
now that that relationship is better but
it certainly was a challenge at the
start of this so I'm grateful for my own
friend right and friend the minister for
having dealt with that we're gonna make
some progress uh Dane Rosie because I
know you're Keen to crack on I wanted to
touch on a couple of the Amendments that
are listed today and perhaps demonstrate
some of the challenges in this system
there are a number in here that are
effectively trying to prevent
deportation or removals at all costs
um blocking the entire premise of us
being able to control our borders
um and then doing that in preventing us
from controlling our Borders or removing
people with no right to be here it
dissolves in effect our national
self-determination our national identity
it degrades our ability to decide for
ourselves and Ronald Reagan said if you
can't control your borders you're not a
nation or not a nation state 8 and it
takes away some of those significant
powers that we should absolutely have
and hold in this country use examples
such as Amendment 138 that says you
can't remove unless there was a safe and
Legal Group you mentioned that uh on
friend uh member opposite mentioned that
earlier what it seems to say to me is
that if there isn't a safe and legal
route then you have carte blanche to
arrive here through whatever means that
you uh suggest or that you would like
they can't be a safe and legal route for
everybody around the world who could or
be eligible to come here that's a
hundred million displaced people around
the world you have to somewhere draw a
line that says what is reasonable for us
as a country to actually be able to
Resource local authorities tasks we're
looking after a lot of the people who
come there is limited resource there is
limited capacity to do that in order to
be fair both to Asylum Seekers and
people in genuine need and to UK
citizens who rely on public services you
have to draw a line so it can't possibly
be right to implement a clause like that
that will prevent us from removing
basically everyone
um if you uh Clause uh Amendment one two
one you can't remove um until you've
exhausted a million appeals uh through
every court in the land forever and ever
and we'll
um actively encourage the kinds of
scenes that we've seen uh in recent
years where people are lodging late
appeals and dragging people off of
flights again that we won't be able to
do to enact any of this if you try to
implement those kinds of amendments it
defeats the entire object of the bill
and perhaps that's what members opposite
are trying to achieve in bringing them
forward it's absolutely right that we
need to prevent the exploitation of
children and I think uh The Honorable my
right of a friend from South Island's
deepings is right to say the age of
Education verification is an important
part of that important as it is to
ensure that we Implement A system that
is rightly uh tough on the rules for
adults if you want to implement A system
that also seeks to safeguard children
you have to be able to effectively
decide who children are and to show that
the system isn't being exploited in that
way if you're going to have of those
duties to safeguard young people
inevitably if you say and you put on the
face of the bill that we are going to
have a system for uh children that says
you have
um rights to all sorts of um the same as
a British child that you would and
members no longer in space but you
wouldn't remove people at 18. if you
write that on the face of the bill and
effectively say you'll be able to come
and live here as effectively a British
citizen with the right to stay forever
then more and more children will arrive
on small boats and we will be actively
encouraging children or people
traffickers to put more vulnerable
unaccompanied children on boats and push
them off into the sea and that would be
an horrendous outcome if we were to um
to make that uh clear to people in this
business sadly who are exploiting
vulnerable young people
but finally in terms of the Amendments
uh Dame Rosie my constituents voted uh
one of the highest proportions to leave
if anywhere in the country 71 uh voted
to leave the EU they be voted for
self-determination they voted to remove
uh the control and the overriding
decision-making of European institutions
I think amendments 131 132 the name
model friend from devizes my Umbra
friend from Middlesbrough South seek to
ensure that the rules around this are
decided and implemented and applied here
in the UK notwithstanding reviews of
those who are in Strasbourg on uh
removal flights or because of Provisions
in the echr that might now overreach or
might be open to exploitation whilst we
work this out and whilst we get to a
place where we have a functioning Asylum
system I think most of my constituents
would fundamentally expect at the very
least we should be able to make our own
rules and decisions here in the United
Kingdom and that we should be able to
determine the compliance with those
rules here in the United Kingdom I think
that plays a huge part a in the
um the reasons and the methods behind
people choosing to leave those European
institutions finally Dame Rosie I just
wanted to say that my constituents in
Mansfield absolutely expect to see
numbers of people crossing the channel
illegally fall dramatically they
absolutely expect to see people moved
out of hotels and into a secure
accommodation and they absolutely expect
to see uh removals flights leaving this
country and taking people with no legal
right to be here to somewhere else I
know I've said this before but I asked
the minister again to do everything in
his power and for the Home Secretary to
do everything in her power to make sure
that we can keep that promise to the
British people yeah yeah
Stephen Ferry
thank you very much Dan Rosie and in
following the honorable member for
Mansfield I think it's important uh to
point out the dangers of framing this as
them versus US competition uh for for
scarce resources and indeed this notion
that there's a hundred million people in
the world who are all wishing to come to
the UK
um the answer to the first question is
of course to invest in resources for
everyone across across the UK and also
to have some degree of perspective that
whilst there may well be 100 million
people in the world who are refugees or
internally displaced only a small
fraction of those are seeking to come to
the UK even in the context where we
expand the range of safe and legal
routes most want to stay close to the
original homes with someday the
intention of returning there
um I very much much want to focus
particularly on one issue which is um
Amendment 70 in Miami but also to offer
support to other amendments from this
side of the house but in in talking to
amendments at 70. I have to say I am
somewhat self-conscious and indeed
humbled that it is a very specific uh
nice niche issue in the context of what
is an overall bill which I feel is
lacking in compassion lacking in
humanity to people who are very fleeing
war and persecution there's a breach of
international law in terms of refugee
convention and the European convention
on human rights and is in denial of the
lack of viable safe and and legal Roots
into to the UK
nonetheless it is important to replace
these particular concerns on record and
once again we have a situation where
home office legislation failed to take
into account the realities of the common
travel area and the particular movements
on the the islands of Ireland
whilst there is a open border with no
routine immigration checks UK
immigration law nevertheless does
continue to apply and people who cross
into the UK particularly on the island
of Ireland still remain at risk of
immigration enforcement and indeed in
legal Jeopardy if they are in breach of
any particular
immigration rules
so under close to off the bill as is
presently framed someone who enters the
UK via VIA Northern Ireland now risks
potential detention deportation uh to a
a third country or their home country
and even a ban whatever returning
I do welcome the home office's recent
guidance on the electronic travel
authorization insofar as it gives an
exemption for Third Country Nationals
living in the Republic of Ireland who
don't need required visa to enter the UK
to come in to uh into the UK without the
need for the the ETA that is sensible
and pragmatic but it doesn't go far
enough and there are two colleges of
people that I wish the Highlight in
connection to this bill and the Clause
to The Spill significantly raises the
Jeopardy for people who aren't covered
by that exemption in terms of of the ETA
the first one I want to focus on is
those residents of Ireland
we currently do require a visa to enter
the UK including obviously at Northern
Ireland now the Visa itself isn't the
issue in terms of this particular debate
but the change in their legal Jeopardy
very much is
so let me give you a couple of examples
we could see a woman from Kenya who's
living legally in say for example County
Donegal and crosses the Border a simple
Bridge across the border from lifford to
strabane to do the weekly shopping on
somehow it ends up interacting with the
state authorities and it is therefore it
comes to to the light of the of the
immigration control
potentially she could end up in a
situation where she is deported not just
back to her home in Ireland but actually
deported all the way back to Kenya
or we could have a Nigerian man who's
simply traveling between two points in
the Republic of Ireland in clonus and
cavan town and the people may well know
that road famously crosses the Border in
Northern Ireland County fermata about it
six times
that that person has no intention of
doing any business in the UK but
unfortunately it has a traffic accident
and comes to the attention of the state
under this uh Clause as currently
drafted he too could be deported not
just back to his home in Ireland but all
the way back to Nigeria
secondly let's look at the issue in
terms of Tourism
at present Northern Ireland is marketed
internationally as part of a single
entry in terms of the island of Ireland
that is a networking of the The Good
Friday agreement
furthermore most International visitors
to Northern Ireland first arrive in the
Republic of Ireland primarily through
Dublin Airport and then travel
northwards it is currently intended that
those individuals would require an ETA
in order to access the United Kingdom
there is a separate discussion that I do
want to have with the home office around
that current requirement for tourism in
terms of the impact on the tourist
sector but in terms of today you want to
focus on the immigration aspects
there are of course CF guards in terms
of anyone entering the UK via a Seaport
or an airport that will essentially
capture and ensure that they do have the
requisite papers but that isn't going to
be the case in terms of what is an open
land Border in Ireland so we do have the
potential for potentially many thousands
of tourists innocently and unwittingly
coming to Northern Ireland without an
electronic travel authorization and
therefore being placed in legal Jeopardy
even if they have at the the the
intention not to stay in in the UK
because they're simply tourists but
under this bill as it's currently
drafted they too are at risk of
detention deportation
and also about never coming back to the
UK again is that seriously the message
that we want to send to the rest of the
world in terms of UK tourism yes
grateful to The Honorable gentleman for
giving way would he not also uh I mean I
agree with fundamentally that the point
that he is making and the government
should note that this is an argument
which finds unanimity
across the political parties of Northern
Ireland and that of itself should speak
volumes to the government yeah
yes I'm very grateful
um for the sheriff's North Affairs
committee for that interventionally is
quite right
um this is something that across the
political Spectrum in Northern Ireland
we are taking a pragmatic approach to
because we are very sensitive to the
importance of of Tourism uh to to our
economy uh there are very particular
concerns about the need for an ETA in
terms of tourist movements and beyond
that today we're just highlighting that
there is also the issue of enhanced
legal Jeopardy for someone who travels
without that documentation and that
their potential potential risks also uh
Jim Rosey I just want to briefly uh make
a few other points in relation to the
implications for for Northern Ireland uh
just also to say that um there is the
potential for this bill to run country
to the requirements of Article 2 of the
Northern Ireland protocol and I renamed
the Windsor framework alongside the
wider issue in terms of adherence to the
European convention on human rights I'm
not sure that the government has done
property diligence in that particular
regard this relates to the
non-demination of Rights and of course
Asylum Seekers are as much part of the
community in Northern Ireland as as
anyone else and finally also want to
place on record my concerns that the
bill potentializes actually a state to
be a modern slavery regulations which
apply to devolved invasions and Nations
and they encroach upon the Vault matters
and those Powers will be struck without
the consent of those that have devolved
authorities including including Northern
Ireland where we don't currently have a
functioning executive Anna Sandy thank
you very much
Janet Davey oh thank you
um uh Madam chair I Rise to speak in
favor of amendments
148-285-288 and 292 and the new calls 18
21 22 27 28 and 13. and this is because
my constituents and I are deeply
concerned about so many aspects of this
bill specifically on Clues to Clause two
and four the unhcr has stated the bill
would deny protection to many Asylum
seekers in need of safety and protection
and even deny them the opportunity to
put forward their case
now over the years I've worked with
refugees and Asylum Seekers
unaccompanied minors children and
families and the stories I've heard
about them traveling to the UK are
brutal and gruesome at the hands of
people Smugglers
they're always left deeply traumatized
I've heard of stories of male children
being raped I've heard stories of a
young person traveling with his brother
and being separated along the journey
and then never seen him again and being
worried and concerned that actually
maybe you never even survived the
journey
I've heard stories of a husband who has
handed his child and saw his wife being
repeatedly gang raped
these are terrifying incidents I've
heard of stories where guns have been
placed to children and adults heads
these people are terrified and they have
endured unimaginable conditions on their
Journey to the UK
yeah when we hear about refugees and
Asylum Seekers from the government and
the opposite side of the bench their
experiences of crossing the channel to
free persecution is never mentioned or
even rarely ever mentioned and I find
that utterly shameful
this government has demonized these
people and children and they're
forgetting they're human just like all
of us across this chamber refugees that
come by boat or in lorries do so because
of the lack of safe routes to the UK and
they're completely vulnerable and that
the mercy of the people's Smugglers
it is the people Smugglers and criminal
gangs that the government should be
focusing all their efforts on to stop
this illegal and criminal act and that
is why I'm back in New Clothes 22 to
enshrine in law a new National Crime
agency unit to crack down on people's
Smugglers and gangs as the MP for Lucia
means I've talked a lot in this chamber
about my pride and joy that Lucian
Council was the first in the country to
become a borough of sanctuary local
authorities are heavily involved in the
housing of Asylum Seekers and that is
why I urge colleagues to vote for new
Clause 27. this will force the Home
Secretary to consult with local
authorities when opening up Asylum
accommodation and hotels in their area
we have a hostile and Asylum
accommodation in my constituency and I
am appalled when I have been there to
speak to some of my constituents about
the conditions that they are having to
live in they're not able to cook for
their families not able to cook for
themselves not able to choose make
choices that families would want to and
what they do want to do is to provide
for their families to have their visas
to be able to work and to have a home
and to to care but what I am finding is
that so many people that are in this
country they're Asylum Seekers or
refugees are beginning to suffer from
mental health problems because of the
endured process of how long this has
taken and the government is allowing
them to remain in these unsatisfactory
conditions but at the national level the
small boat failure exists due to the
Tory government's incompetence because
it was this government still to leave
European Union without a returns
agreement in place which has led to a
huge increase in the number of dangerous
Crossings and a backlog in the silent
cases I'm not sure why the backlog
hasn't been resolved obviously the
government does not have the appetite to
really push forward to make this happen
and I'm further outraged this bill
breaches Refugee convention and gives
the Home Secretary power to remove
unaccompanied children
uh my honorable friend from Wolfenstein
has spoken about new Clause 18
eloquently and I absolutely support the
reasons why she has mentioned that and
her persistence in making sure that
children are treated equally and fairly
and continue to ensure that children are
of the government's Paramount concern
the government is risking the welfare
and safeguarding of vulnerable children
that is absolutely clear and therefore I
back Amendment 148 which removes the
home secretary's power to remove
unaccompanied children and I trust many
honorable members from across the house
will do so as well most people want
strong border security and a caring and
effective Asylum system but at the
moment we have Neva and this build is
little to achieve this labor has a plan
to prevent dangerous Channel Crossings
and to reduce the Asylum and Refugee
backlog in order to improve this
shameful piece of legislation we must
pass all the Amendments I've raised in
my speech and lastly I want to mention
the work of together with refugees they
are a coalition of over 550 national and
local organizations calling for an
effective fairer and Humane approach to
supporting refugees I urge the
government to listen to them
Joanna Cherry you Dean Rossi I Rise to
speak to amendments 121 and 123 to 127
which are tabled in my name and also in
support of amendment one tabled in the
name of the right honorable member for
aberraville who speaks for the official
opposition to which I've added my name
and I've tabled these amendments as
chair of the joint committee on human
rights I'm not going to push them to a
vote because the committee has only just
commenced our legal scrutiny of this
bill that's not because we're dilatory
in any way but because it's been bounced
on us at shot such short notice we've
got very little time to undertake that
scrutiny but we hope to report Before
the bill has finished its Passage
through the House of Lords and at that
point I hope we'll be able to recommend
some detailed amendments with the
backing of the whole committee
team Rosie I did wonder whether it was
worth my while spending hours in the
chamber this afternoon waiting to speak
in detail to any of these amendments as
after six hours of debate yesterday the
minister made no attempt whatsoever to
address any of the detailed points
raised by opposition amendments now we
don't expect the minister to agree with
us but we expect him to at least do us
the courtesy of addressing what we have
bothered to say not just on behalf of
our constituents but also on behalf of
Civic society and uh and so on that's
how Democratic scrutiny works there's no
point in members opposite banging on
about the sovereignty of this Parliament
when the government ignore most or all
of the substantive points raised by the
opposition during legislative scrutiny
Dame Rosie that's not how a bill
committee is supposed to work and I
would appeal to the minister to remember
his duties not just to the government
and his political party but also also to
this Parliament and to the constitution
of this so-called parliamentary
democracy because the way we are
legislating in this house at the moment
is an absolute disgrace Dame Rosie a
bill committee is supposed to be line by
line scrutiny this is a fairly lengthy
bill which raises huge issues in respect
of our International legal obligations
and also huge moral issues but we've not
conducted anything like line by line
scrutiny and if I'm supposed to keep my
comments to 10 minutes I'll barely
scrape the surface of the Amendments
I've tabled and have not just been
dreamed out of thin air they're informed
by detailed legal scrutiny of the bill
by those lawyers advising my committee
and also many of the amendments are
informed by the existing unanimous
reports of the joint committee and human
rights on the Bill of Rights so you know
that this bill sneaks in some of the
things that we're going to be in uh the
Bill of Rights and yesterday as I say I
spent quite a long time addressing in
some detail the re the legal reasons
under reference to the convention and
case law of the European Court of Human
Rights the reason why it would breach
the convention for the government to
ignore interim orders of the court and I
also explained how very rarely interim
orders are passed and respect of the
United Kingdom and the minister just
completely and crassly ignored every
single point I sought to make and
frankly his behavior I'll take an
intervention in the minute the behavior
in failing to address any of the
opposition amendments makes a mockery of
this Parliament and it makes a mockery
of all their singing and dancing and
fuss about the sovereignty of this
Parliament so I'll take an intervention
grateful to The Honorable and learned
lady for giving way yesterday
um my honorable friendly member for
stone set out a very compelling argument
about the sovereignty of this place but
I share her concern that I think that
speaks to a earlier time of how laws
were made whether it was on a far more
leisurely way where this place made far
fewer laws and it took its time there
was motion and there were no program
motions people could take as long as
they wish to so I take a point entirely
and doesn't that speak to the importance
of scrutiny in the other place but also
some oversight of the courts so that if
there is error in our law making the
courts can point it out and we can
Rectify as and where necessary so I
fundamentally agree with the point that
which he makes with regards to the
importance of Court oversight yeah yeah
order before the um honorable lady
um responds just to say
um I gave some guidance as she knows
um it's not possible to impose a time
limit my guidance was to try to get as
many people in as possible
just to answer the honorable gentleman's
points yes I do think in our civilized
balanced uh modern democracy where we
have proper separation of powers the
role of the courts is very important but
the role of this chamber is very
important I'm not too bothered about the
other place it's not elected it doesn't
represent people I got elected to make
to the trouble of getting elected three
times to represent my constituents what
I have to say about this bill is an
awful lot more important than what some
unelected peer has to say and I say that
with all due respect to many of the
peers who I think do a fantastic job in
trying to fill in the holes of the
absolutely appalling way in which this
government seeks to Pilot through pilot
legislation through this Parliament yes
I'll take another intervention I I'm
very grateful to people who I uh I I
fear I wasn't here because I was trying
to support the honorable what she was
saying in that I I referenced at the
other place as of course in a bicamble
system
that second house provides time to
reflect and then obviously
give us their views which we can then
consider again but the fundamental point
with which I was I thought or hoped
helpfully agreeing with the honor of the
known as lady was the point that she
makes as do others of the importance of
being able to have court oversight
because we are inclined to rush our
legislation in this place and therefore
if we do get things wrong we are only
Human After All it is important to have
space for the courts to reflect to hear
evidence and to advise and guide yeah I
know he was trying to assist me but I
just I agree with him that Court
scrutiny is important of course I do I'm
a lawyer I'm not going to let the
government off the hook on the absolute
warful scrutiny that goes in week in
goes on weekend week out in this place
I'm totally in favor of a bicameral
system when Scotland eventually becomes
independent which I hope will be during
my lifetime I would like to see a
bicameral system in Scotland because I
like to see checks and bouncers and I
don't like governments who throw their
weight about and don't allow proper
legislative scrutiny and that's what I'm
going that's my point that's why Macy's
I'm spending some time on this just now
because the way this has been conducted
is frankly a disgrace it really is a
disgrace like I'm very grateful The
Honorable lady is raising these points
because as the chair of the home Affairs
select committee we were very keen to
carry out some pre-legislative scrutiny
on this bill to assist the house when it
came before us that wasn't possible
because it had to be rushed through it
seems so we've had no opportunity to
have evidence sessions or to do any of
the work that would really help the
government it seems to me why are the
government so frightened of proper
scrutiny of this bill which we all
recognize is so important
I tell I can tell her why they're so
afraid of proper scrutiny because proper
line by line scrutiny of this bill it
will illustrate that it breaches our
International obligations under the echr
it breaches our obligations under the
refugee convention it breaches our
obligations under the Council of Europe
action against trafficking and that's
just to mention three there's also the
International Convention on the rights
of the child and I could go on and I
could go on that's why they don't want
the scrutiny and what really infuriated
me yesterday was that when some of us
were actually trying to make arguments
that were based on evidence and the law
the minister was far more interested in
parroting the popular slogans coming
from his back benches which really had
no basis in law and no basis and
evidence then addressing the Amendments
we
um are trying to make so I am going to
spend a bit of time talking about the
Amendments I've lodged because I think
they're quite important not because um
just because I think they're important
because I think they reflect collect
issues that have been widely raised in
briefings by the even just speaking
about home-based organizations briefings
by the equality and Human Rights
Commission the Scottish Human Rights
Commission the law societies of England
and Wales and the Law Society of
Scotland I can absolutely assure the
members opposite the Law Society of
Scotland is not a Bastion of Lefty
lawyers I wish it was but it isn't
um so anyway let's just start with
Amendment one which is an amendment
um to uh Clause one and uh the purpose
of that amendment is to prevent Section
3 of The Human Rights Act from being
disapplied in respect of this bill
because if that happens it means that
the courts will be prevented from
interpreting this legislation to avoid
human rights incompatibilities in
Provisions unless those Provisions are
ambiguous and what will happen then is
that the court will be far more likely
to issue Declarations of incompatibility
instead
which and I noticed that the minister
despite everything I've said is now
conducting a lengthy and casual
conversation with the chap sitting
beside him rather than me this is just
not how we should be conducting
ourselves in this place in my previous
job if I sat and held a conversation uh
with the Barrister or The Advocate
sitting beside me when the other
Advocate was speaking and we'd have got
a telling off from the judge I just
think it's it's nothing to do with me
it's just wholly disrespectful to the
process of parliamentary scrutiny this
is really important the Human Rights Act
was passed by this Parliament all of the
responses to the government's
consultation on the Bill of Rights and
all of the responses are the vast
majority of the responses to my
committee's consultation on the Bill of
Rights showed that people thought
Section 3 was working really well and at
section three of the Human Rights Act
does not undermine parliamentary
sovereignty because it can only be
brought into play where Provisions are
ambiguous yet despite all of that
evidence and despite all of that
scrutiny the government is wanting to go
ahead with disapplying section three of
the Human Rights Act to this bill and
what I want to know by tabling this
amendment is I want to know the basis
for that how can the government be so
confident that their view which is in
direct opposition to the responses to
their own consultation the weight of
them and the responses to my committee's
consultation how can they be so
confident that their view is right I
think we all know the answer they're not
confident that their viewers right they
just want to uh drive it through on a
wave of a populist
um rhetoric
the next amendment I want to speak to is
amendment 123 which is designed to seek
to ensure that the United Kingdom will
comply with its obligations under
article 31 of the refugee convention now
insofar as in the government well the
government actually hasn't explicitly
addressed the compatibility of the bill
with the refugee convention in the
documents which accompany the bill but I
understand that the government's
argument is that protections under the
refugee convention only apply to those
who fall within the group who cannot be
penalized under article 31 that is to
say those who come directly to the
United Kingdom and this is the phrase
the government relies upon to justify
its interpretation that Asylum Seekers
should claim asylum in the first safe
country they reach and that's reflected
in the third condition set out in Clause
two which says a person is not taken to
have come directly to the UK from a
country where their life or Liberty were
threatened if in coming from such a
country they've passed through or
stopped in another country outside the
UK where their life and Liberty was not
so threatened and in practice that would
exclude any Asylum Seeker who travels to
the UK by any means other than a direct
mode of Transport from the persecuting
State now that is clearly not the
intention of the refugee convention the
government's definition of coming
directly set out in Clause 2-5 is
inconsistent with the interpretation of
article 31 in the refugee convention set
out by experts assembled by the unhcr in
concluded following analysis of the
travel Preparatory that the drafters of
the refugee convention only intended
that immunity from penalty should not
apply to refugees who found Asylum or
were settled temporarily or permanently
in another country and the government's
interpret the government's position is
also inconsistent with the similar
interpretations of article 31 made by
the English high court in the case of of
ademi and others against CPS and the
Secretary of State for the home
department and that their interpretation
was discussed by the House of Lords by
no less than Lord Bingham
um who said who can in another case of
asphal which confirmed that a short
stopover in another country on the way
to claiming asylum in the UK does not
preclude Reliance on article 31 of the
refugee convention so there is binding
Authority from the highest courts in
England
that the government's interpretation of
article 31 of the refugee the convention
is wrong
it's also noteworthy Dame Rosie that the
interpretation of coming directly in
this bill is much stricter than the
interpretation set out in the
nationality and borders act 2022 which
states that individuals will not be
considered to have come directly only if
they stopped in another country and
could not reasonably have been expected
to claim Asylum there so it is worthy of
comment that the government has
substantially altered its understanding
of the legal meaning of a
well-established International treaty in
the space of a year on the basis that I
think they're trying to say there's some
sort of evolving interpretation but if
actually you look at the interpretations
both by our our domestic courts and in
the convention the government are are
wrong and the interpretation I've set
out is
um correct
and another amendment I want to speak to
Dean Rosie is amendment 124 and that
would remove the prohibition for the
first 28 days of detention on the grant
of immigration bail by the first tier
tribunal and uh the ouster of judicial
review detention I'm not going to go
into the details of that because it's
actually quite complicated but I think
the government's contention that uh to
fall back on habeas corpus would fulfill
our article uh five commitments under
the echr I think that's a highly dubious
and I really hope that they will
Minister perhaps or uh his boss the Home
Secretary will come before my committee
so that we can discuss these things in a
bit more detail than we are able to do
today and then again amendments one two
five to one two seven and these are
designed to ensure that the
disapplication of modern slavery
Provisions extend only in accordance
with the Council of Europe's convention
on action against trafficking and uh
that's been spoken to in some detail
already uh by honorable couple of
honorable members right honorable
members opposite so again I'm not going
to take up more time talking uh about
that
um but I just wanted to end with one or
two other comments and during the debate
several honorable members have spoken
about the plight of women in Iran
and Afghanistan
and I'm not really quite sure how the
government thinks
a woman who's fleeing the persecution of
women in Iran or Afghanistan can come
legally to this country particularly in
the Iranian case and it'll be really
interested to hear what the answer to
that is because it concerns me Madame
Deputy speaker that the third condition
uh sorry Matt Dean Rosie it concerns me
that the third condition in Clause 2 of
this bill
is that in entering or arriving as
mentioned in subsection two the person
didn't come directly to the UK from a
country in which the person's life and
Liberty were threatened by reason of
their race religion nationality
membership of a particular social group
or political opinion I just wonder why
sex is missing from that list
because some of the more serious
persecution going on in the world today
is against women on the grounds of their
sex I've mentioned Afghanistan I've
mentioned Iran we also know about the
weaponization of rape against women in
war zones people talk about Ukraine but
it's happening in Africa all the time
now I know uh The Honorable gentum the
member for aberravan has an amendment 2
to add the word gender to that list but
I think the word should be sex genders
are social construct these women are not
being persecuted on the basis of a
social construct they're being
persecuted on the basis of their sex and
I think something where I and the
minister can agree is that the United
Kingdom should be very alive in its
Global Outreach to protect women's
rights so I would ask the government to
consider adding sex to that list now my
honorable friend the member for Glasgow
Central also said that we should be
adding sexual orientation to that list
and I completely agree with her on that
because of what's happened in Uganda in
particular but there are many other
countries in the world where it is not
legal to be gay it's not legal to be gay
in Iran they're still hang people from
cranes in Iran for being gay so I think
we need to think about that like the
minister may very well say to me that
membership of a particular social group
I think is traditionally interpreted to
include LGBT LGB people and trans people
but not to include sex so I think we
need to add sex to this list and we need
to be clear that it includes LGBT people
as well and I think I'll just leave that
there for now imagine it Madam chair
thank you
enlightenment
Dane Rosie I rise in support of new
Clause 22 and 27 proposed by the shadow
front bench just before my election last
year the nationality and borders act
became law the government claimed it
would resolve the Asylum backlog with
the then Home Secretary promising a
long-term plan that seeks to address the
challenge of illegal migration head-on
well here we are nearly a year on with
no real progress in tackling this crisis
in fact things have only got worse I
strongly welcome new Clause 22 which
would enshrine the home secretary's
accountability in law it would require
her to regularly report and how her
department is eliminating the huge
backlog in cases this should not be a
controversial Amendment the initial
decision backlog has increased by 60
percent compared to 2021 rising to a
record high of 160
000 and shockingly fewer than one
percent of last year's claims from those
arriving on small boats have been
decided you wouldn't think so from the
home secretary's rhetoric with the
silent delays getting even longer and
the home office taking 10 000 viewer
decisions a year than in 2015.
this has led to a record number of
Asylum Seekers being housed in long-term
hotels and contingency accommodation and
that brings me on to new Clause 27. 37
000 people now reside in hotels at a
staggering cost to the taxpayer of 5
million pounds each and every day and
decisions are still being made to use
more local authorities who have already
faced significant funding cuts under
successive conservative governments are
having these proposals forced on them
without any say this is a story of my
own Wakefield constituency there are
currently two hotels used to accommodate
Asylum Seekers with plans for a third
new Clause 27 would finally tackle this
issue placing a legal requirement on the
home office to consult with local
authorities when considering new sites
increasingly cash-strapped councils are
having to step in to provide intensive
support for vulnerable Asylum Seekers
they can't plan to do that if there's no
interaction with the home office there
is no doubt that the Asylum system is in
chaos and that this is a mess of the
conservative government's making and
Tory MPS who vote against this tonight
will make this situation even worse for
our councils we need new Clause 22 and
27 for some much needed accountability
because of this government's woeful
track records promising to speed up
claims but delivering the opposite
promising to end the use of hotels but
instead seeing their use soar and
promising to return those deemed
inadmissible but only returning 21
people we can't accept yet another bill
promising to do one thing but in
practice doing the opposite that's why I
will be supporting new Clauses 22 and 27
today for accountability and
transparency
Layla Moran
Rosie
I it will surprise no one to know that
the liberal Democrats will be eventually
voting against this bill and this this
really does feel at committee stage like
we are just
polishing the Absurd frankly
um we we don't want to be doing this we
don't want to be talking about this
that's not the same as saying we don't
want to solve these problems and
actually I would I would like to start
by trying to take if I can a little bit
of the heat out of it because I think
the suggestion that people on this side
of the house don't want to tackle the
small boats problem is just
categorically not true there is no one
on this side of the house that I've
heard say that they would agree that a
criminal should be allowed to stay here
and there is no one here defending the
traffickers there is no one here
trying to actually not support the home
office in deporting people who deserve
to be deported and in fact what we are
saying is that they should be doing it
better and faster so I think we should
just start by recognizing that
and I think we should also recognize
that you know this bill is partly about
the local elections isn't it the
questions around why are they uh so
scared of scrutiny I don't think they
are I think they actually just want to
get this out as quickly as possible
because if it's not out now then we know
it's not going to make the printers for
the local election leaflets they're then
going to drop in the next few weeks and
let's I'm sorry to be cynical but that I
think is what's happening here because
the problem is really the big issues
that need to be tackled here are
enormous and I do wish that the
government would actually grapple with
these I mean the biggest driver of this
and there was something I found myself
agreeing with the Home Secretary uh it
felt uncomfortable
um but she did say something that I
agreed with which is actually the first
issue here is there are big Global
factors that are pushing people around
the world there is climate change there
is also instability across the world
more than we had 20 years ago and a
combination of these two things are the
cause for global migration the vast
majority of these people are not seeking
to leave their regions many of them
don't speak languages they don't want to
leave the vast majority of refugees
aren't even in Europe they are in next
door countries just look at what's
happened most recently in the disaster
zones in Syria and in Turkey it's
surrounding areas where they want to be
and then there's this tiny number that
are coming over here in small boats and
boy do we not want that to happen there
is no one here who wants to do that so
let's start with that one I would point
to them though that doing things like
reducing our Aid spend from 0.7 to 0.5
doesn't help I would put to them that
going backwards in any way on any of our
commitments to climate change is not
going to help that aim and I would also
put to them that they are also partly
responsible for part of this this is to
do with home office inefficiency which
as we've seen over the last five years
this has started they want to blame the
pandemic it's not just about the
pandemic this started before that point
it's gotten worse and worse and worse
pandemic made it even worse
but this is fundamentally and they need
to accept that that is part of the
problem there is a managerial aspect
here that needs addressing
but I want to focus my remarks on
something very local and I just want to
start and put on the record my thanks to
the minister for meeting with me about
my concerns around camps field house
which was a Detention Center in
kidlington which in 2017 the local
community campaigned to close for very
many years it was shut down partly to do
with a gun well in fact entirely to do
with a government plan to reduce the
size of the detention estate and now the
plan is to reopen it
and I'll get to some of the key points
around that in a moment but the main
thing I think we need to just keep
remembering here is that these are
people inside these detention
centers and I I don't feel that
personally I can convey what they feel
myself as well as they can and so I want
to tell Alan's story who was a refugee
from Uganda who came to the UK and
stayed in campsfield but in his own
words
and he said I was imprisoned in
campsfield for nine months and though I
did not know how long I would be held
one of the hardest parts of detention is
the uncertainty of not knowing how long
you will be there
while you are there you are not treated
like a human conditions at campsfield
were at times inhumane with people
resorting to hunger strikes self-harm
and tragically even suicide
you are given a number
and referred to by that number rather
than your name
when you meet people from the outside
from outside of the center you are
perceived and treated as if you are a
risk to society a dangerous criminal
when all you were trying to do is reach
safety and build a life
when I was at campsfield I saw many
people struggling to cope with
depression and a system designed to
break people down
my way of coping was to join a legal
reading group where we taught ourselves
immigration law and supported each other
in our appeals against attention
I was eventually released from cancer
field in February 2015 when my legal
battle was successful
I was granted Refugee status later that
year and I've since returned to being a
carer in the community and my daughter
is now at University
treated like a criminal referred to like
by a number and that is the reality that
I worry we are going back to now I've
had assurances from the minister it's
not going to be like that but I've yet
to see anything concrete in the plans
for campsfield that say it's not
and
those
horrible things that happen to those
individuals that eeks out into the
community every time we have a suicide
it's in the Oxford mail my local
constituents write to me worried about
it so whilst people may not be concerned
about it right now the proliferation of
detention in this way is going to have a
negative impact on my community
and it's also got an impact on third
sector and it's also got an impact on my
own constituency casework and I will
take on those cases because Oxford is
proud to be a city of sanctuary and I am
an MP who will help them regardless
because I think that's our job you're
here but it's not going to solve the
problem because if you take everyone who
crossed the channel who is detained for
more than 28 days that's 9 161 people
campsfield is going to house 400.
they've also got hazler in gosport so
that's another
600 so that's a thousand but the numbers
also in terms of how much it's going to
cost is quite eye water in campsfield is
170 million pounds and I would put it to
the minister that surely this money is
better spent on 700 home office case
workers to process claims and make a
dent in that backlog I welcome the fact
that the government's already started to
do this I don't understand why it took
so long but let's let's do more let's
employ even more because that is the
answer to this and then my other
question is if you are going to have a
thousand more in detention what is now
our new Baseline detention
right what is the plan for the number of
people that we think we are going to be
having here and what is what are we
trying to do because surely what we want
to do is to have as many people
processed and deported as quickly as
possible I'm with the minister when he
wants to find the criminals I'm with the
government when they want to work out
who shouldn't be here and send them back
but I'm so worried that that's not
what's going to happen because we have
indefinite detention in this country we
are the only country in Europe that has
that and my experience having been an MP
for an area with a Detention Center is
that we don't keep to those 28 days that
we should we don't keep it even to a
number of months there were some that
were there for five years and I have no
faith I'm afraid in this government to
be able to deliver an efficient Asylum
system that's going to help them so
actually let's focus on what they can
actually do and get right let's stop the
political posturing let's stop
forgetting that these are real human
beings I genuinely think with child
detention point we are on the wrong side
of History here it was a stain that it
ever happened it's a steam that it
happens now the fact that one-third
actually our children should be enough
for the ministers to turn around and say
to himself actually we're going to do a
Do no harm principle we're going to
assume that everyone's a child until
they're proven not because I don't want
a single child held in detention and I'm
rather shocked that this government
doesn't feel the same yes
uh Dame Diana Johnson thank you Adam
Rosie and could I just apologize for not
being in the debate this afternoon at
the liaison committee uh was meeting
with the prime minister so I um had to
go along to that for a period
um and I also just wanted to start by
following up on the points made by the
chair of the joint committee on human
rights
in yesterday's committee proceedings
children and the issue of child refugees
was raised by members across this house
over 40 times and many members raised
their deep concern about the way in this
bill child refugees will be treated now
I've got a great deal of respect for the
minister but unfortunately the minister
in his very short closing speech
yesterday it just lasted 13 minutes
did not mention children once
and I also noted there were 70
amendments tabled yesterday now at the
rate of 70 men amendments going into 13
minutes that's about 10 seconds per
Amendment and I really would just agree
with the honorable lady about the lack
of scrutiny which is of huge concern on
this bill considering it's so important
and as I said earlier on the offer of
pre-legislative scrutiny by the Home
Affairs select committee which wasn't
taken up by the government the lack of
evidence sessions and now the large
sweep of amendments proposed by members
of this house the rushed process by
which it's being introduced and the lack
of any impact assessment so I hope this
evening we will get a much more detailed
and productive response from the
minister when he rises to speak now I've
tabled 10 amendments to this part of the
bill which fall under one essential
umbrella and that's around section for
Refugee children all of these Amendments
have the full support of the children's
commissioner and summarize from the home
Affairs select committee recommendations
in our small boats report which we
published last year
to start with Amendment 295 the
government have excluded accompanied
unaccompanied children from the removal
Provisions outlined in the bill
and we know that children will often
have made very difficult and perilous
Journeys probably at the hands of
traffickers or Smugglers
however
the bill obliges the Home Secretary to
remove these unaccompanied children from
the United Kingdom when they turn 18.
now in the year ending September 2022
the UK received
5152 applications for Asylum from
unaccompanied children many of them came
from Sudan a country facing political
instability following years of Civil War
and where child marriage is Rife for
girls as young as 10. now under this
bill for example a 13 year old Sudanese
girl could claim asylum in the UK be
placed in the care of a local Authority
and be fostered spend five years at
school make friends learn English get an
education build a life become a member
of society only to face removal on her
18th birthday if this was allowed to
happen the home office would be removing
a young woman who's built her life here
and may perhaps only know this country
as home and very importantly it also
dramatically increases the risk of
children fleeing the system and
disappearing before their 18th birthday
in the knowledge that they face certain
removal now this amendment that I'm
proposing does not Grant automatic right
for these children to remain in the
United Kingdom it simply removes their
mandatory removal when they become
adults so each case can be decided on an
individual basis
next I just want to turn to Amendment
299 and through and Amendment 301 the
children's commissioner has raised
concerns that under Clause 3 the Home
Secretary will still have powers to
remove unaccompanied children the
explanatory note sets out that this
power will only be used in exceptional
circumstances but there is no further
detail on the face of the bill as to
what that means I've tabled Amendment
299 to establish the right of an
unaccompanied child who makes a
protection claim including as a victim
of slavery and human trafficking are set
out in section 69 of the nationality in
borders act to have their claim
considered before potential removal I've
also added my name to Amendment one two
one tabled by The Honorable and learned
member for Edinburgh South West which
strengthens this position further though
Clause 5 subsection 4A gives some way to
a protecting such a person by stopping
their removal if they make a protection
claim or human rights claim it is also
dependent on subsection 4B which relies
on the Secretary of State considering
this to be an exceptional circumstance
I understand that such a power is likely
to be used with regards to unaccompanied
children from a country listed in new
section 80 a A1 of the nationality
immigration Asylum act 2002 and Clause
50 of this bill now without my Amendment
the whole secretary for example would
decide the right of a 14 year old
unaccompanied Asylum seeking child from
Albania to remain in the UK over recent
months there has been the growing view
that Albanian boys aren't in need of
protection on arrival to the UK but they
are in fact exceptionally vulnerable
often trafficked here without proper
protection and pushed into forced labor
or criminality again having the threat
of removal over these children's heads
is a guaranteed way to ensure that those
who arrive here unaccompanied will try
to go It Alone run away from care slip
out of the system and into the arms of
traffickers and abuse
therefore Amendment 301 goes further by
removing the power of the Secretary of
State to make arrangements for the
removal of an unaccompanied child
now the home Affairs select committee
reporting to channel Crossings last year
raised grave concerns about the home
office's record of safeguarding children
from failures identifying vulnerable
children through screening and
assessments to failures of communication
when transferring safeguarding
responsibilities from one agency to
another there is also the disastrous and
unforgivable failure of children going
missing on the watch of a home office
I'm really concerned that the home
office are simply not up to the job of
keeping children safe and secure and
that is why I asked the minister to
reconsider Clause Clauses 15 and 16
which set out how the home office would
accommodate a child and be given
safeguarding responsibilities that
currently sit with the local Authority
these Clauses are incredibly thin for
such an essential issue as safeguarding
children and they make no provision on
what the state of the accommodation that
will be provided will be will the
accommodation be regulated which body
will inspect them how will decisions be
made what support will be available for
these children the children's
commissioner has made clear that she
does not believe that the home office is
the right body to oversee the
safeguarding of children and I
completely agree this is also why I've
supported amendments 143 144 and 145
tabled by The Honorable member for
eastworthy insurance Ensure ensuring
that our current statutory time and
location restrictions on the Detention
of unaccompanied children and children
with families are not disregarded I also
want to speak about Clause 14 which
would remove the role of the independent
family returns panel in the removal
process the independent family returns
panel plays a vital role in safeguarding
families and children from harm while
awaiting removal and by ensuring that
they are returned to a country that is
safe
now this was introduced actually by the
coalition government to end the
Detention of children and provide advice
on the welfare and safeguarding aspects
of removal arrangements made for
families the duty to remove Provisions
proposed in the bill mean that the ifrp
overseeing the handling of families at
Port is actually going to become
essential if the government is going to
take us back a decade in safeguarding
measures please think again and put some
mitigations in place and please remove
Clause of our team
now on the specific issue of removal
Provisions in the bill regarding
children and their families I've tabled
amendments 304 and 306. under Clause 30
a person who's ever met the four
conditions relating to removal for the
UK would forever be eligible for any
route to British citizenship seems to me
it's completely wrong that this applies
to children who by the nature of their
age are not making these decisions or
Journeys by themselves it cannot be fair
or reasonable that an eight-year-old
child brought to the UK illegally by
their parents should be ruled as
ineligible for citizenship for life this
is I think a liberal and unjust and to
hold a child responsible for the acts of
their parents seems to me fundamentally
wrong again accepting this amendment
will not bestow any rights on a child to
claim British citizenship but it will
ensure that nobody's rights are removed
because of the actions of their parents
turning to Amendment 306 this would
solidify the rights of a family unit to
be considered as a whole rather than
individuals treated separately by the
home office when satisfying the removal
Provisions within Clause 5. this
amendment would make it explicitly clear
on the face of the bill that family
members arriving in the United Kingdom
would only be removed if it is safe for
all family members to be removed to the
same country this would mean that a
father or husband is not removed to a
country listed in respect of being safe
for men in the schedule if it was not
safe for all members of the family unit
including a wife and daughters
I want to turn um now to my amendments
which build on the recommendations in
the home Affairs select committee report
on small boats which was obviously
reached on a cross-party basis our
report found specific and serious
concerns about child protection in that
report including in the practice of
placing unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children in hotels which has led we know
to hundreds of children disappearing
currently a child's Asylum application
will take on average 550 days that's a
hundred days longer than an adult and
the issue of age verification and
assessment is a very live one with cases
of children often be mistaken for adults
we therefore recommended that the
government commission an independent
review of children's experiences of the
Asylum System including the examination
of the support needs for young Asylum
Seekers including failed Asylum Seekers
and refugees up to the age of 25. now I
know the government are committed to
securing the welfare of unaccompanied
children and young adults in the Asylum
system and so I look forward to the
minister responding hopefully positively
to new Clause 14. the committee's report
included many witness testimonies on the
significant lack of support to
vulnerable children who are left to
navigate the Asylum system alone often
with Language and Cultural barriers and
it must be terrifying and a scarring
experience for many of those children
and young adults so new Clause 15
introduces a provision for each child to
be provided with an independent child
trafficking Guardian these are
Provisions that are already in place in
Northern Ireland and Scotland and would
ensure greater consistency across the
whole of the country and deliver
independent legal guardianship to all
separated children here in the UK and
the children's commissioner fully
supports this amendment based on that
home Affairs select committee
recommendation and I again I hope the
minister will do so too
now acknowledging the productive work
that the government is doing with the
French authorities I also ask the
minister to look at new Clause 16 which
would integrate the select committee's
recommendation to consider a program of
trained Child Protection workers to work
directly with vulnerable child migrants
on the French Coast
new Clause 33 is my next Amendment
um which I think is incredibly simple it
will firmly establish the right of any
child to climb Asylum
I agree completely with the children's
commissioner's view that children should
continue to be allowed to claim Asylum
however they have arrived here no
vulnerable child should be turned away
because of where they were born because
of decisions made by their parents or
because of the actions of traffickers or
Smugglers take for example the case of
an Iranian boy who's been trafficked to
the UK alone he believed his family had
been killed he had no concept of what
England was he had no English language
but he'd been trafficked here by
criminals under this unamendeville the
child would not be eligible to apply the
lead to remain in the UK now I
acknowledge the government want to stop
the criminal Gans behind the small boats
but they must not do so by refusing to
deal with cases like this
a child can never and should never be
used as a battering ram to punish
criminals it's just not right
now establishing a safe and legal route
for Refugee children akin to the dubs
Amendment or fulfilling the rights
children had under the doubling
agreement would go a long way to
ensuring that they do not fall into the
hands of traffickers therefore I've
tabled nucleus 32 on Refugee family
reunion for unaccompanied children in
line with a home Affairs select
committee's recommendations in both 2018
and 2022 this amendment establishes safe
passage for unaccompanied Refugee
children to be reunited with a family
member who has already been granted
leave to remain but a lead to enter and
remain in the United Kingdom just as
they had before the UK left the EU
without a safe and legal route to be
reunited with their loved ones children
with families in the UK
who could have otherwise offered them a
home and an opportunity for a normal
life will likely turn to traffickers and
people Smugglers and we cannot leave
unaccompanied or separated children
alone in camps or in other countries
where they have no support system
vulnerable to abuse trafficking
criminality and worse so the bill in its
current form I think does nothing to
protect Refugee children the minister
yesterday as I started off by saying did
not mention children and yet there are
children out there who we can help who
we must help whose voices are missing
from this bill so I do hope the minister
will take a look closely at my
amendments and ensure the rights of
refugee children are firmly protected
Tim Norton thank you sir Roger and can I
first of all declare my interest in the
registers chairman of the safeguarding
board of Children's Group it's a
pleasure to follow the chair and fellow
member of the home Affairs select
committee and I agree with many of the
observations she makes particularly on
the recommendations which have come out
of various home Fair select committee
reports but also on the specific
conundrum that she mentioned where
children perhaps even babies who are
brought here
beyond their own power clearly as uh if
they're they're very young with parents
falling foul of the regulations that are
due to uh come in because they've
entered illegally will have a black spot
on them effectively for life through
making of their own and what would
happen sir Roger if that baby when he or
she grew up was then to marry a UK
citizen
effectively not able to come to the
country of origin of their spouse these
are not completely hypothetical uh
scenarios they are very real problems
that could occur and we should not as
almost about to use the phrase
throughout the baby with the the bath
water because there are some unintended
consequences which could seriously
harm
um a Young Person's prospects going
forward for a crime which it had no part
in effectively committing I want to
speak for a rather shorter time than
yesterday because I just want to focus
on two aspects of children
um and that's to do with uh children
being
effectively still capable of being
deported as children and also issues
around detention which I think are very
problematic here now in doing
um that I think there is a problem with
effectively trying to adultery uh
children in this um in this bill I
acknowledge there is a difficult
situation regarding families
and I have concerns about the treatment
of families but I've also seen as the
chair of the home first select committee
that has where people Smugglers are
using children to match them up with
supposed relatives to come across and
the case we saw in fact the day we were
last in Dover where the supposed uncle
and the child didn't even speak the same
the same language so we have got to be
cognizant of the the fact that these
criminals will use children in order to
try and uh help the passage of other
people who are paying them large
quantities of um of money
I'm also absolutely in favor of a much
more robust uh and efficient age
verification system it is a safeguarding
issue we have had instances
of Choke people claiming to be children
who later turn out to be adults actually
attending school alongside school age
children in positions of responsibility
alongside children this is an important
safeguarding issue many other European
countries already have age verification
techniques which will involve various
medical interventions as well we need to
look seriously at that if we are to get
this one right but again it is a
sensitive issue I also have a good deal
of sympathy with the concerns over
modern day slavery legislation as by
right under a friend for maidenhead
mentioned earlier in my uncle friend for
chingford as well and I hope the
minister will be looking carefully at
how we can preserve the principles of of
that whilst clamping down on some
potential abuses that have been
happening so I just want to concentrate
on on my Amendment says in my name and
names of right under Alondra all friends
amendments 139 to 145 and they focus on
clauses two three uh 7 and 11 which is
about
I'd be delighted to
be great for just in terms of the very
good points that he made yesterday can I
just confirm from him how happy he was
with The Minister's confirmation
yesterday that safe and legal Roots
would if necessary be brought forward
with Our intention being quote to open
them next year and that by launching the
local Authority consultation on the safe
and legal routes at the same time does
that give him and those of us who
supported his Amendment the reassurance
that he needed on that score
if I do too much backdropping to
yesterday's business here I'm sure
you'll call me out of uh of order but I
I will I will tell my uh honorable
friend uh some intensive discussions uh
went on with the uh relevant
um uh bodies to get assurances but on
the basis that I need to see some fairly
convincing and robust action in the next
few weeks before we get to report stage
otherwise we will be revisiting uh those
uh amendments and new Clauses with a
Vengeance at that stage I've given the
benefit of the doubt to the uh to the
government at this age so I hope we can
work constructively to achieve actually
what I think the Prime Minister wants to
achieve what he's put on record he wants
to achieve but some of us want to see
more of an urgency and some clear
undertakings attached to it on the face
of the uh the bill that was yesterday's
business today's business I'm not
intending at this stage to foster a vote
but I do want to have some assurances
from the minister because if we don't
get those these are very important
principles dealing with very vulnerable
children and I want to see some really
concrete action when it comes to report
stage on this because frankly if it
doesn't as with my case for the safer
legal routes yesterday it makes the bill
much less able to defend and will be
much more vulnerable to being pulled
apart in another place and by lawyers as
well so I want this bill to go through
but I want it to be a balanced bill that
can work and won't fall at the first
hurdle effectively so those Clauses I'm
I'm concerned with are those that place
the duty on the Home Secretary to remove
people how they impact on children and
the details around removal procedures
but also on the power of detention and
where we must absolutely make sure that
we don't as I use this word adulthify
children and they must be subject to the
same safeguarding constituent
considerations for any other child
legally already in the United Kingdom
who's taken into custody or subject to
some form of restriction on his or her
Liberty it first
I think also worth repeating as has been
raised by several people that no child
rights impact assessment has been
undertaken on this bill and I think that
is of concern and I think it will
benefit the government if it were to be
able to back it up with that sort of
analysis
um I also have concerns and we need
justification for the removal of the
duty to consult with independent family
returns panels as well and those are the
sorts of reasons why many children's
organizations and indeed the children's
commissioner has been very vocifers on
their concerns over various aspects of
this bill now there's also the issue of
the home office taking over
responsibility of accommodating
unaccompanied uh children and the
children's commissioner has pronounced
on that
quite firmly and she said in her report
it is entirely unclear how these Powers
would sit alongside local authorities
duties under Section 17 of the children
act 1989 to safeguard any child in their
area and take them into their care under
Section 20 if the criteria for doing so
are met the bill has the potential to
make it harder for local authorities to
fulfill their duties in the children act
1989 in relation to ensuring stability
for Jordan as their corporate parent and
to protect and support child victims of
trafficking and exploitation so the 1989
children is clear local authorities in
England have a legal duty to safeguard
and promote the welfare of children
within their area who are in need which
begins as soon as the child is found in
the local Authority area and this act
applies to all children equally in the
United Kingdom regardless of their
nationality their Origins their
ethnicity or their immigration status
and this has been a gray area as we
found on the home first select committee
when we've interviewed ministers before
and where it's gone wrong over the
placing of children arriving
through Dover in certain hotels and
there have been cases where the home
office has not actually informed the
local Authority which is the legal uh in
in person body in place of the parent
that they've actually placed children
there and there's some confusion amongst
home office officials as to whether it's
the home office who has Prime
responsibility or the local Authority
between whether they are refugees coming
here irregularly through Dover or those
coming on a resettlement scheme through
Afghanistan for example and we just need
greater Clarity in all of that and I'm
afraid with this with this uh the
changes here it does not Aid Clarity
I'll give away tomorrow I'm really
grateful to my honorable friend I think
he in his point that he makes about the
interaction with the children act and
indeed home office responsibility this
is where we get to the number the
problem I think the characterization of
this debate has become extremely
unfortunate when we are talking about
issues like detention which I'm sure the
government in practice doesn't actually
mean and this is really an issue
safeguarding first and foremost and
identifying genuine cases which which
require all the safeguarding measures
that are underpinned by the children's
act it's a just even it's a shame to say
the least that we aren't focusing upon
children in that context rather than in
the context of detention internment
whatever you want to call it that
language is not helpful well I'll come
on to detention in a minute but I I can
entirely agree with the principle of the
point my right angry friend is um is
making that whatever you think about our
immigration and Asylum system a child in
this country should be treated in no
different way however he or she arrived
in this country as somebody who was born
here and is in the care of parents or uh
or or whatever
um and there are times in this bill
where it's unclear that that is actually
um the case
so
all these terms need to be subject to
the child welfare prioritization in the
children Act of 1989 and also have
regard to the U.N Convention of the
rights of the child 1989 where under
article 3 subsection one the best
interest of the child must always be a
primary consideration and that has been
upheld in UK legislation not least in
the 2009 border Citizen and Immigration
Act
so in giving the Home Secretary the
power to remove unaccompanied children
when they reach the age of 18 or
potentially before as it stands this
bill could see a child arriving in the
alone in the UK age 10 for example
fleeing war and persecution being
allowed to integrate into UK Society
develop friendships and attend school
only then to be forcibly removed from
the UK as soon as they turn 18 and there
are concerns
that a child approaching 18 a 17 and
three-quarter year old could be
encouraged to go under the radar and go
underground for fear of that knock on
the door when they reach 18 and we need
to treat this sensitively otherwise we
are creating a greater problem and
putting some of those children at
greater risk than they might have been a
decade ago sir Roger the majority of
unaccompanied children were granted
temporary leave
to remain until they turned 18 rather
than Refugee status and we know that the
fear of removal forced many of those
children to go underground and go
missing at extreme risk of exploitation
so my amendments so Roger Amendment 139
it inserts a fifth condition in the bill
which needs to be met on the duty for
the Home Secretary to remove someone
from the United Kingdom
Amendment under 140.
details that the additional fifth
consideration is that the person to be
removed is either over 18 or a minor in
the care of an adult typically a family
member and this would have the effect of
ensuring that the bill does not capture
unaccompanied children
and then amendments 141 and 142 are
consequential remembrance uh rewording
of the due to the rewarding of Clause 3
and Clause 7 to remove subsections one
to four and the anomaly is in one or two
which still gives the Home Secretary
unrestricted Powers now the minister
I'm not sure if the front bench wants to
listen to this sort of it's a little
difficult to try and make a speech with
people having conversations right in
front of me
amendments 104 so ministers claim
that there are exceptional circumstances
only in which children would be removed
from the United Kingdom
and there have been examples that those
essential circumstances would be to
reunite a child with a family overseas
okay will a child to be related with a
family overseas can leave the UK of his
own or her own accord or subject to a
ruling of a judge in the same way as
would release a child from caring to
adoption for example so I don't see that
as a necessary exceptional circumstance
so if the government is really convinced
that there are sectional circumstances
where this needs to be laid there needs
to be more detail on the bill or at
least explanation in the explanatory
notes because there are none and as it
stands at the moment the Home Secretary
has the power to remove any child at her
whim
for reasons not specified in this bill
and that is a concern
now if the government had good reason
for that we deserve an explanation of
what those reasons are and it's for this
house to judge on how credible and
necessary those reasons actually amount
to
now the effect of those amendments is
that those children who arrive in the UK
on their own and seek Asylum would
continue to have their Asylum claims
heard here rather than being left in
limbo until the time they reach 18 when
they would under this bill face
detention and then removal these
amendments don't mean that every child
who arrives here on their own will go on
to get permission to stay instead it
means that the home office must process
their claims and crucially treat them as
children rather than punish them
dating NASA Roger with Amendment 143 to
145 on the issue of detentions now the
Amendments along with the these
amendments that I've already
described also maintain the safeguards
that were put in place under
conservative-led governments to protect
children from the harms of immigration
detention
in 2009 more than a thousand children
were detained in Immigration removal
centers but following changes led by the
then Home Secretary the right honorable
member for maidenhead over the next
decade the average was 132 children per
year
what's more those children could not be
detained for longer than 24 hours if
they were unaccompanied or 72 hours if
they with their family members
extendable to a week if a minister
agreed it was necessary we then
legislated for these limits in
Immigration Act 2014 under a
conservative LED government and
amendment's 143 and 145 ensure that
these safeguards continue to apply I'm
not asking for a change in the law I'm
just asking for the safeguards that were
deemed to be very sensible and necessary
back in 2014 still apply to the same
sort of vulnerable children they would
then prevent unaccompanied children from
being locked up for more than 24 hours
Amendment 145 would make sure that
children who are with their family
members continue only to be allowed to
be detained for a week at the very most
and when they are that it should be in
specific pre-departure accommodation
rather than anywhere the Home Secretary
may wish as the bill actually envisages
so under the bill clause 11 gives the
Home Secretary very wide powers to
detain anyone covered by the four
conditions in Clause 2 which without my
early amendments still includes
unaccompanied children
now there's no time limit for how long a
child can be detained
it amounts to effectively indefinite
Detention of children of any age
anywhere that the Home Secretary
considers appropriate
under Clause 12 the Home Secretary will
have a significantly expanded pair to
decide what a reasonable length of
detention actually is so it's all
subject to the definition of what is
reasonably necessary and it also
severely restricts Court scrutiny of
whether this is actually reasonable or
not now surely sir Roger this cannot be
right for children and not seeking here
to challenge The increased restrictions
on adults but particularly after all the
controversy on how we detain children
age appropriately who are already in
this uh country in the UK surely we are
not going to throw all that out of the
window by identifying migrant children
and some very vulnerable children at
that there's also a practical
consideration sir Roger if everyone who
crossed the channel last year had been
detained for 28 days
then on the 4th of September 2022 no
fewer than 9 161 people including
children would have been detained
this amounts to four times as current
detention capacity available in the
United Kingdom so where physically does
the government intend to place them and
especially those miners who need to be
in age appropriate accommodation
I'm also concerned as to how the four
hardial Singh principles from 1983 apply
to this part of the the bill those
principles that the person may only be
detained for a period that is reasonable
in all the circumstances and if it
becomes apparent that the Home Secretary
will not be able to affect removal or
deportation within a reasonable period
She should not seek to exercise the
power of detention so the government has
to make up its mind on what grounds it
thinks it needs to detain children and I
again understand the sensitivities there
may be those claiming to be children who
later turn out not to who may abscond
but it needs to have a clear idea of
what it's going to do in a short space
of time in order to justify that
detention when they actually arrive and
we don't have that level of detail or
Clarity in the bill and so it's entirely
incumbent on the minister to give
assurances to this house that children
are not going to be disadvantaged in
that way so finally sir sir Roger the
amendment's 143 and 145 would mean that
the amendment would remove the provision
which enables a person of any age to Be
Tamed in any place that the Secretary of
State considers appropriate and would
reapply the existing statutory time and
location restrictions on the Detention
of unaccompanied children it was good
enough in 2014 I don't think
circumstances have changed for the way
we should regard and treat vulnerable
children that we need to change the law
in this bill and the amendment 145 would
remove Visions which disappoint the
existing statutory time location
restrictions on the Detention of
children on their families I don't think
this is unreasonable
um sir Roger
but if the government wants to take
issue with me then it's incumbent on the
government to say why it wants to make
these changes I've gone along with most
of what's in the rest of the bill
I've given the government the benefit of
the doubt on what it's going to do and
the detail it's going to provide and the
timing of safe and legal routes but we
need some serious assurances by report
stage and hopefully some good signage by
the minister when he gets onto his feet
uh shortly that the sort of protections
which children have been entitled to and
we are proud to give them those
safeguards and have done in the past why
the law needs to be changed in the way
that the government is now proposing to
do
I think all of us want to do the right
thing by vulnerable children
I think most of us would like to see
safe and legal routes as I referred to
yesterday that involved something
equivalent to a dubs II scheme where
genuinely unaccompanied minors in places
of danger are brought to Safety in the
UK and given Safe Haven in the United
Kingdom
I want to continue in that tradition I
want to make sure we are offering that
safe passage and Safe Haven to the right
genuinely vulnerable children and I
don't want them to be penalized in the
way that potentially they could be by
the wording of this bill I'm happy to
take assurances but if I don't get those
assurances by the time we get to report
stage I think I won't be alone in
wanting to push various amendments to
try and force some of those assurances
onto the face of the bill
Ali
sir Roger thank you so very much I stand
today on behalf of the hundreds of
emails and letters that I've received
from my constituents also on behalf of
children at Saint dunstan's Catholic
Primary School which is a school of
sanctuary
this bill marks a new low for this
government in its continued attempts to
treat Asylum Seekers with cruelty and
content
the TUC have made it clear if this bill
passes it will effectively amount to an
asylum ban this bill is an attempt by
this government to turn its back on most
vulnerable people who are fleeing war
and persecution around the world
and if passed he will tarnish the
reputation of the UK for decades to come
under Clause 11 the Home Secretary will
be given Paris to detain children
whether a company or not based on her
own conclusions for for however long she
deems necessary
what right does the Home Secretary have
to judge the most vulnerable groups
situations and why they have arrived in
this country illegally why does she get
the right to make decisions whilst
diminishing Court jurisdiction and going
against laws of welfare and safeguarding
because that's exactly all this
deplorable bill will accomplish by
promoting not only failure but danger
but it is also clear is that the bill
will only worsen an already intolerable
situation this government shouldn't need
reminding that Asylum Seekers crossing
over to the UK illegally are often
victims of human traffickers who profit
from the exploitation of Asylum Seekers
and who are responsible for the deaths
of countless innocent people who have
died crossing the channel
and what exactly does this bill do to
help bring these human traffickers to
Justice nothing in fact far worse than
nothing this bill disqualifies victims
of human trafficking and modern slavery
from the protections and services
offered by the Europe convention on
action against trafficking in human
beings instead victims will be
threatened with deportation it is
obvious in such circumstances that
victims will simply not come forward and
human traffickers will get away with the
continued exploitation of vulnerable
people by removing these protections and
essentially criminalizing victims of
human trafficking this bill will push
more and more Asylum Seekers into the
informal economy where employers will
take advantage of their lack of legal
status and no recourse to Legal Market
inspectors again those who profit from
Human misery and exploitation will go
Untouched by this will for whilst their
victims are made to suffer this bill
breaches international law promotes
human rights abuses has serious
implications for the safety of the most
vulnerable groups in society including
children and places an unacceptable
amount of power in the hands of someone
who has demonstrated that they are
incapable of making appropriate
decisions it is for these reasons that I
am resolutely opposed to these bill as
are my constituents in Birmingham some
whole green as are the children in
sentences Catholic primary schools it
will do lasting damage to the conscience
and international reputation of our
country this bill must be stopped before
it creates an irreversible damage to
hundreds and thousands of people who are
seeking nothing more than enough uh
nothing more than an opportunity to live
free from harm that's your Grady
thank you sir Roger um can I maybe just
start by congratulating Hamza Yusuf on
becoming Scotland's new first Minister
and wish him every success in taking
Scotland forward to Independence he of
course comes from a Heritage Beyond
these Shores and that should be a matter
of Celebration and pride
so Roger once again the amendment's
before us today show that this bill
pleases nobody opposition members on a
cross-party basis are trying to restore
some basic elements of humanity and
decency to the process and make sure
that the UK actually continues to have
something that resembles an asylum
system but it seems that for many Tory
backbenchers the bill doesn't go far
enough and Tori extremists want to make
it even more punitive and we see that
for example in Amendment 136 out for the
member from a stuck on train North who's
no longer in his place attempting to ban
the use of hotels for temporary
accommodation is simply gesture politics
it's probably unworkable it's certainly
impractical and it's likely to further
increase not reduce the costs to the
taxpayer I wonder how often he and many
others have spoken today have actually
met with Asylum Seekers who are staying
in such hotels who incidentally I'm
happy to consider as constituents of
mine who have a voice that needs to be
represented in this place too many of
the Tory back Ventures speak of them as
some amorphous as my honorable friend
from Glasgow Central said some sort of
amorphous dehumanized blob and I think
that's completely inappropriate the
Asylum Seekers that I've met through the
Mary Hill integration Network and
elsewhere don't want to live in hotels
they want to be able to work and
contribute to society the way to get
Asylum Seekers out of hotels is to give
them the right to work the right to earn
a living which is another fundamental
human right by the way and let them pay
for their own accommodation let them pay
tax into the system and at the end of
their Asylum process if their claim is
rejected well then there will always
have been processes for removal and
return but if their claims are accepted
then further down the road they will be
much further down the roads of community
integration and at far less cost to the
taxpayer instead this bill and the
honorable members amendment is going to
channel yet more money into the hands of
Outsourcing companies like Mars and
circle and many of us will continue to
hear stories in our constituency
surgeries about substandard and
unsuitable accommodation being paid for
by taxpayers
so Roger today's groupings of Clauses
and amendments really get to the heart
of what the government says that this
bill is trying to achieve although
actually many of us suspect what the
government is actually trying to achieve
is a fight firstly with the House of
Lords then with the Supreme Court and
then with the European Court of Human
Rights but much of that it was covered
yesterday
um but Clause 2 provides sweeping powers
and duties to add up to watch the U.N a
High Commissioner for human rights has
described as a ban on Asylum
during the passage of the nationality
and borders act many of us asked how can
the United Kingdom which is surrounded
by water ever be the first safe country
of arrival for undocumented migrant my
honorable friend the member for
Edinburgh South West touched on this how
could anyone traveling from Iran or
Eritrea or Sudan or practically anywhere
else on the globe be expected to meet
the third condition in Clause 2 section
4 about not passing through a safe Third
Country maybe there is some inventive
way of doing this maybe the minister can
tell us he's paid so much attention uh
to the debate the member for East
warning really shouldn't be surprised
that he was having conversations on the
bench because he spent most of the
debate looking at his phone I don't know
if there's been an update to Angry Birds
or a candy crush or maybe it's just a
particularly difficult Wordle today but
nevertheless what are the inventive ways
what are the inventive ways for people
reaching this country without passing uh
through a safe Third Country someone
pushes off from the coast of era and
navigates the heart of Africa and sails
around the Cape of Good Hope and makes
up the North and South Atlantic Ocean
without straying into anybody else's
territorial Waters and then lands on the
south coast of England will they perhaps
be allowed to claim Asylum under this
clause
that in fact will there even be a way of
knowing because they're not even allowed
to make a claim when will they even get
the chance to prove that that was the
journey that they undertook and that's
why the s p has tabled amendments 186 to
196 to mitigate these ridiculous
restrictions like a tribute to my
honorable friend from Glasgow Central
for humanizing them in the way that she
did to offer protection to people who
are under the age of 18 to people
already determined as refugees under the
terms of the refugee convention to
people who face discrimination because
of their sexual orientation to people
who are victims of torture people who've
been trafficked or faced slavery people
who have HIV or Aids and indeed people
who come from Ukraine or from
Afghanistan and given the outrage that
we've heard from the sections of the
conservative benches today about the
treatment of Asylum Seekers from
Afghanistan I hope the government will
be prepared to accept our Amendment 189
or face the prospect of its members
joining us in the lobby in support of it
later on yeah I asked the member yes the
minister yesterday and he didn't bother
to respond in fact again I'm not sure he
was listening if these Powers if the
threat of immediate deportation is
supposed to have a deterrent effect
where is the evidence why hasn't the
nationality and borders act had that
impact and shouldn't it already have
started to work because the powers in
Clause 2 under Section 3 back date the
bill to the 7th of March when the bill
was introduced so surely there should
already be a Slowdown in the number of
arrivals but if there is a reduction in
arrivals from Albania it's because of a
separate Arrangement that the government
has come to the reality is that this
clause and these Powers will not have a
deterrent effect
freedom from torture identifies four
principal reasons for a their clients
undertaking perilous Journeys to reach
these Shores to join a family or
community that could offer security and
support because of familiarity with the
language culture and institutions of the
UK that the UK government spends
thousands probably millions of pounds
promoting abroad Britain is great come
and get achievements scholarship come to
the United Kingdom except actually when
you try to apply to you can't unless
you've got an awful lot of money and
apparently one of the reasons is in the
hope of reaching a place where human
rights are respected which is suddenly
ironic given the bill that's in front of
us and the Clauses we're debating today
and then because of a lack of safety in
the countries that they were passing
through and there's very little that the
government can actually do to address
any of these pool factors through
legislation and several stakeholders
make the point that many people arriving
here have little or no familiarity with
the Asylum rules so the punitive
measures particularly the powers in
Clause 2 will do nothing to change that
the Amendments I've table 174 and 175
relate more specifically to the debate
that we heard yesterday uh about the
Clauses around safe and legal routes but
what they would do is make sure that
this house has a meaningful see on what
cat or Target for entrance under safe
and legal Roots should be the current
proposal for a statutory instrument
drafted by ministers with no room for
amendment is really no say at all brexit
was supposed to be about parliamentary
sovereignty about this place taking back
control over decision making so why
conservative backbenchers are so Keen to
hand over powers to the executive is
really not clear at all and I also
welcome new Clause 29 table by my right
honorable friend the member for
different marionid the commitment of
Welsh ministers and said of kumri to
making their country a nation of
sanctuary is hugely encouraging and she
is right to seek to make sure that the
Clauses in this bill recognize and do
not interfere with that commitment and
perhaps nation of sanctuary status is
something that our new first Minister
and his team will consider for Scotland
because of course we already aspire to
those ideals even if not using that
formal term
but I wonder a sir Roger just the
conclusion it's worth reflecting the
Greek philosophers figured out in about
500 BC that the world was round
but this doesn't seem to have quite sunk
in in the far reaches of the Tory back
benches we can't just keep pushing
people away in the expectation that they
might fall off a cliff at the edge of a
flat Earth if you keep pushing people
around the globe eventually they will
come back to you migration is a global
reality it's part of human nature over
the centuries people had to flee these
islands because their crops were
devastated by blight or because they
were forced from the land to make way
from sheep so it's just as well that
America and Canada and Australia we're
implementing hostile immigration
environment policies back then and it's
just as well that known we have Global
treaties and conventions to protect
human rights and regulate how refugees
and Asylum Seekers are treated by
countries of arrival but not for this
government the exceptional stratitude
displayed by some tourists that first
led to brexit now and we see that in
amendments that have been tabled that
exceptionalist attitude no stretches
beyond the European Union and the
Council of Europe to key United United
Nations Frameworks that have sought to
keep everyone on this planet safe since
the end of the second world war also
Roger that might be their ambition but
it's not the ambition of people in
Glasgow North and it's not the ambition
of people across Scotland and if the
government continues down the road that
it's going in the international
agreement that we will be withdrawing
from is the Treaty of Union 1707.
Beth winter yeah
having studied and listening to the
entire debate today has only
strengthened my resolve that we must
oppose this rotten bill in its entirety
it is inhumane it is immoral and it
demonizes in scapegoats the most
vulnerable desperate people who are
fleeing violence
Terror poverty and we should be
welcoming them with open arms
and as others already said
um I I have to express my concern at
some of the inflammatory inaccurates
um comments by some of the members
opposite this afternoon and I also want
to um reiterate concerns expressed about
the lack of scrutiny 10 12 hours to be
considered in excess of 130 amendments
totally totally unacceptable
notwithstanding my belief that the bill
should be thrown out in his entirety I
want to set out some of my concerns
about Clauses and to speak in support of
a number of amendments before the house
today the Clause is before us today
create a duty to remove
make Asylum Seeker claims inadmissible
ban appeals by those being held and make
the tension the norm and that has
already said the bill does breach
international law the refugee convention
and I'm particularly concerned that the
government's willingness to conflict
with the United Nations High commission
for refugees
in the unhcr's commentary on the bill
they said and I quote the legislation
have passed would amount to an asylum
ban extinguishing the right to seek
Refuge protection in the United Kingdom
for those who arrive irregularly no
matter how would genuine and compelling
the claim may be and with no
consideration of their individual
circumstances in detail and in relation
to the Clauses under the duty to make
arrangements for removal close to Aims
to place a blanket Duty with limited
exceptions on the home circuits which
remove people who have entered or
arrived in the UK illegally but the
refugee Council have highlighted that
half of the people who crossed the China
last year came from just five countries
with high Asylum Grant rates and the
unhcr said the bill creates real and
foreseeable risks of direct and indirect
persecution for people subject to the
mobile Duty saying and I quote nothing
in the bill makes over dependent on the
receiving country having an effective
Asylum procedure or agreeing to admit a
person to it and this is why I support
the spirit of my friend the shadow
ministers Amendment 17 to Clause 6 which
would add an explicit requirement for
the circus day to have regard to the U.N
High Commissioner for refugees
and this is something I would recommend
the Home Secretary to do with regards
all aspects of the bill
now under the theme of inadmissibility
of claims and duty to remove I
completely oppose the clause for
requirement treat protection claims from
persons subject to the Asylum ban as
inadmissible with no right to appeal
that must be opposed and I therefore
support Amendment one-to-one table by
the member for Edinburgh Southwest
on detention and bail Clause 11 to 14
and unaccompanied children Clauses 15 to
20 detention action have argued that the
bill dramatically increases the number
of people in detention and the length of
time they would be detained and that the
Home Secretary is likely to hold people
in detention for an extremely long
periods far beyond the minimum 28 days
the bill makes mandatory
I am concerned at the introduction of
wide new powers for detaining persons
and their recent discussions shifted to
placing Asylum seekers in camps on
former military sites presumably to
better facilitate their removal the
accounts of conditions that they've
already said at manston in Kent last
Autumn and also in in my country of
Wales and finale stay with me at the
overcrowding the lack of facilities and
the spread of disease absolutely
appalling detention camps are not the
solution and are not the approach that
we'd expect of a civilized country
I'm also concerned the proposals
contained in this film will have severe
consequences for the welfare of
extremely vulnerable children and others
the side of the chamber a very
eloquently and movingly relayed
individual stories of children who've
experienced absolutely horrific
circumstances
um and others have said many have gone
hundreds have gone missing as a refugee
and migrant children's Consortium say
there are many amendments on detention
are non-child Asylum Seekers I wish to
express my support for including
um my friend a member for Hayes in
Harlington the member for avravon the
members for Edinburgh Southwestern East
Worthing and Shoreham and new Clauses in
the name of orkney and the Wolfson Stone
between them would result in an
improvement in access to immigration
bail restore limits on detention time
frames and increase the role for
external scrutiny on the rights and
well-being of children
however Jim why I hope and would support
the number of amendments tonight for me
and many others that bill in his
entirety is unthoughtable
the bill has come about because the
government is facing a growing backlash
to its low pay and poverty agenda it is
a tool to try and distract demonize and
divide people and is seek into isolate a
group of vulnerable people to divert
their anger on we won't allow that to
happen there is yes I'm a friend for
giving away she's making a really
excellent speech I've had an email just
just now from one of my constituents who
works in the Health Service and she's
spoken to me about the immense
contribution that have been made by
people who've come to this country
fleeing persecution have been granted
Asylum and are now working in the
National Health Service would Marvel
friend agree with me it's a really
important Point I've also had of course
people writing to me about you know how
damaging this bill is to the reputation
of this country is a safe haven and for
the values that we stand up for I fully
agree and people one moment please order
order
I'm sorry to interrupt The Honorable
lady
thank you I'd like the house to behave
like that all the time
it really is most discourteous
the conversations be taking places on
the back benches
particularly from people who've not been
in the chamber much of the debate
some of us want to hear what members
have to say
that's true I appreciate your
intervention there
so in conclusion I just want to
emphasize that there is an alternative
as is evident from the number of
extremely Progressive and positive
amendments we need to clear the backlog
we need to expand safe routes and I
think the Amendments tabled by my
honorable friend the member for
Sheffield in cooperation with careful
Carly and PCs Union on uh safe passage
routes was an excellent Amendment and we
have to be welcoming people uh
vulnerable people to what I would
describe a nation of sanctuary and I
just want to finish by reflecting on the
words of the first minister of Wales and
I'm going to court him and he said about
a week or two ago the basic belief that
in our brief lives we are a duty of care
to family and friends but also to
strangers that simple belief at the
heart of it there is our ambition to be
a nation of sanctuary to provide a warm
welcome to families forced out of their
homes all of those who seek Sanctuary
from wherever and however they may come
to our Shores
care compassion respect dignity humanity
inclusivity and kindness those are the
values that I hold dear to me and those
are the values and principles the weaves
should be seeking to uphold this bill
does not do this at all we must reject
it thank you very much
thank you very much indeed sir Roger
it's a pleasure to follow the honorable
lady and I very much share both our
concerns with the bill and indeed with
the process that we've undergone for
scrutinizing that but I want to try and
make three short points in my speech for
Roger and the first I think the most
important one is to try and encourage a
little bit more interest in the Clauses
in this bill which relate to citizenship
so that's causes 30 to 36 and I think
they were touched upon by the chair of
the select committee and also by the uh
former Attorney General but I think they
really are incredibly important and
really quite alarming and it might seem
slightly odd so Roger that it's an snpmp
who is rushing to the rescue of the
concept of British citizenship but
citizenship is vitally important it's a
source of stability and it's a source of
other rights and deprivation of
citizenship or as in this bill blocking
people from citizenship is something
that should be looked at very closely
and very seriously and I I just want to
highlight one particular subject
poisonous which really resets all the
alarm bells ringing so this is class 30
which is headed persons prevented from
obtaining British citizenship and the
fourth subclause of that says a person P
Falls within this subsection if P was
born in the United Kingdom on or after
the 7th of March 2023 and either of
Peace parents have ever whether before
or after peace boss met the four
conditions in section two that is an
unbelievably broad Clause that means
children and indeed some adults will
face being blocked from accessing the
rights to British citizenship not
because of their own actions but because
of the actions of their appearance
potentially even decades ago that to me
is absolutely ludicrous overreach even
if you are in the space of accepting the
government's premise of deterrence this
could in many cases be children born
here and when one of the parents
actually it becomes settled still or one
of the parents could become a British
Citizen and still this child born in
Britain is deprived of their own British
citizenship or that child could be born
here and spend the first 10 years of
their life here and there to be deprived
of the British citizenship just because
of the actions of one of their parents
potentially many years ago
could be a child brought here at a young
age and whose entire life has been built
here
surely even to the Bill's most Ardent
supporters depriving kids of British
citizenship because one of their kid
their parents did is a step too far that
is absolutely wild sir Roger but that is
precisely what college started to 36
does in this bill and it should be
looked at again
the secondary point I want to make sir
Roger is just about the detention causes
and like lots of honorable members have
said today fewer safeguards and
protections with more detention is
another tragic and it's a backward step
other colleagues have set out most of
the key concerns I just want to repeat
the point in a minute second reading
Marvel friend forever Southwest made it
today that any idea that the writ of
habeas corpus or a petition to the nobly
officium in Scotland makes all of this
fine is absolutely Preposterous these
are much more limited procedures for
challenging detention confined to
questions of authority detain rather
than errors in decision making they are
also infinitely less accessible when
Speedy compared with the bill
application to the tribunal now it's a
specialist so of vulnerable people this
is a a set of Clauses designed to stop
people who should be freed from
detention actually been able to secure
the release from the tension and nothing
else
the first and final point I wanted to
make sure Roger relates to Clause 4 and
the permanent state of inadmissibility
of of claims and that to me is the the
problem really at the heart of this bill
it's a permanent ban on making certain
claims in which our Amendment 294 seeks
to address
permanent and admissibility means over
time thousands of refugees and others
who qualify for protection will be left
in limbo because the government won't
have the capacity to remove them all to
Rwanda but it also because of this bill
quite simply isn't allowed to process
and recognize our claims here
these refugees will end up spending year
after year after year in hotels or in
dismal former military barracks without
any hope of being able to move on but
the penny that doesn't also seem to have
dropped right across the houses it also
means that many who are not refugees are
also going to be left in limbo in the
United Kingdom because again the
government is not going to have the
capacity to remove them all to Rwanda
but also because of this very Bill the
government will not be able to remove
them to their home countries because if
you don't process their Asylum claims
you cannot with a few exceptions remove
the person to their home country and
that is recognized in Clause 5. so
thousands of these people will also be
left in limbo forever in fact
this bill almost creates a perverse
incentive if you're an oversteering when
we're speaking about overseers probably
the best bet that you have is to
actually make an asylum claim and then
be left in this permanent state of limbo
it's an absolutely mad bill doesn't make
any sense at all
that I suspect is why we haven't seen
the impact assessment because it will
reveal most of this
so this is not a bill that's going to
solve any backlog it's all the backlog
in actual fact is going to balloon more
people will be jammed into hotels and
Military Barracks not fewer the backlog
is essentially just going to be given a
different name inadmissibility that is
what this bill achieves and nothing more
a different bag backlog incredible
cruelty that is what this bill is all
about and that's all it's ever going to
achieve if it gets passed
Minister Rob generic
foreign I'm pointable that I seek your
guidance sir Roger as this bill is
reaching the closing minutes of
committee stage and last Thursday in
business question the leader of the
House said in answer to my question as
to the whereabouts of the government's
impact assessment of this bill and I
quote I have spoken to the home office
about the impact assessment it is quite
right that we publish it before
committee stage now as the right
honorable lady has previously asserted
her strong support for Parliament to
have these impact Assessments in order
for colleagues on all sides to
scrutinize any government properly sir
Roger and I know her to be a woman of
her word I am baffled and I'm sure it
couldn't possibly be that the government
has found the impact to be the three
billion pounds to the taxpayer that the
refugee Council has found out so could
you tell me sir Roger of any mechanism
that I can employ even in these closing
minutes to enable or encourage or merely
exhort the minister to publish the
government's impact assessments even now
the
Shadow leader of the house has been in
the house long enough to know that it is
the responsibility of the government to
publish or not publish government papers
it's not the responsibility of the chair
however she asked me a question
but she has placed a point on the record
I'm about to call the minister of state
to reply he's heard what the right old
lady has said
Robert Janet well thank you sir Roger uh
and it has been a wide-ranging and
interesting debate today and I'm
grateful to all the honorable and right
honorable members for their
contributions uh I won't detain the
committee by dwelling on the government
amendments in this group as they're all
essentially technical in nature but I
will instead set out to respond to as
many of the Amendments and new Clauses
that have been debated as possible I
would just in opening take issue with
those who said that the government
provided insufficient time to debate I
would note that both today and yesterday
the debate has concluded almost an hour
before the allocated time
um firstly
firstly
as she has the lead amendment I want to
start with some overarching remarks in
response to the number of amendments
Made In The Name Of The Honorable member
for Glasgow Central
I'll pick up on some of the detail
points raised uh by some of these
amendments a little later in my speech
but I I would say that The Honorable
member
has a choice
either we can legislate as the
government proposes for a coherent and
robust scheme that places an unambiguous
Duty on the Home Secretary to make
arrangements for the removal of all
those who entered the UK illegally on or
after the 7th of March with only a
single and temporary exception for most
unaccompanied children
all we can put into statute
a scheme so rhythm with holes and
exceptions and get out Clauses as to
make the whole bill unworkable
now we know we know which of those uh
The Honorable lady wants but we on this
side of the house want to stop the boats
and that is what this bill sets out to
achieve it I'd be pleased to give away
to their items I wonder if my right on
offense could clarify one point he has
just used the phrase either the
government acts to stop all people to
deal with all people who have come here
illegally that is not what this bill
does
it has caveats it only deals with those
who've come here illegally through a
third safe country could he just clarify
that point
the the right online is correct in that
the bill doesn't seek to change the
arrangements for those who come here
directly and claim Asylum from a place
of danger which is an important point
and a principle of our long-standing
Asylum obligations but for those who
pass through safe countries such as
France which let's be honest is the
reason why we're here today because last
year 45 000 people crossed the channel
in small boat from a place of safety
with a fully functioning Asylum system
for those individuals with certain
carefully thought through mechanisms to
protect those who will be placed in
serious or irreversible harm should they
be taken to a safe Third Country for
those people this scheme applies and it
is essential that we pass this scheme as
it is rather than as the Leaky sieve
that The Honorable lady wishes so that
she can undermine the intent of this
policy I'll happily give way to her he
says that people should come here
directly can you tell me how many direct
flights there are to Heathrow from Yemen
uh from Afghanistan or from Syria
Minister well people do come here
directly from places of danger and we we
do have she well she's incorrect because
we do have long-standing arrangements
for those people those people who
Transit through other countries in order
to come here so she she's wrong in her
Point uh that she's racing but the wider
issue The Wider issue which she and I
have debated on many occasions is that
what we've heard continuously from her
and her colleagues is a kind of
humanitarian nimbyism from the SMP where
they come to this chamber
to say how concerned they are for those
in danger around the world and yet they
take disproportionately fewer of those
very people into their care in Scotland
now let me let me turn to let me turn to
serious questions let me turn to the
serious questions that have been raised
about children today
and let me Begin by saying that we
approach these issues with the
seriousness that they deserve and from
the point of view that we should provide
that the UK should provide a caring
compassionate approach to any Miner who
steps foot on these Shores
and these are not easy choices
but the challenge we face today is that
a very large number of miners are coming
to the United Kingdom
at the behest of human traffickers in
some cases and people smuggle Us in
others
and we have to deter that we have to
break the cycle of that business model
since 2019 the number of unaccompanied
minors coming to the UK has quadrupled
and that has meant that hundreds in fact
thousands of unaccompanied minors have
been placed in grave Danger
in dinghies
and then brought to the UK
some to ultimately enter
the black economy others for even more
pernicious reasons than that and I've
I've those children
seen them at the Western jet foil and I
can tell you that there's no dignity in
that situation as a parent that is one
of the most appalling things you can see
children in dinghies risking their lives
I want to stop that the measures that
we're bringing forward today intend to
stop that
now we're going to do this in the most
sensitive manner we can and the powers
that we're bringing forward under this
bill do just that
the duty to make arrangements for
removal does not apply to unaccompanied
children until they become adults
there is a power not a duty to remove
unaccompanied children
as a matter of policy the power to
remove will only be exercised in very
limited circumstances such as for the
family
safe country tree identified in Clause
50 and can be safely returned to their
home country
now it's very important to stress at
this point that this power is already in
law and is used on occasion when an
unaccompanied child arrives and we're
able to establish arrangements for their
safe return the illegal immigration bill
I will give in a moment I mean if I may
finish my point the illegal immigration
Bill simply expands the country's deemed
safe for that removal happily give way
to The Honorable lady Minister forgiving
way the government has accepted because
of what happened at manston that it will
be subjects to an article 3
investigation to see where there are
breaches of article three of the Human
Rights Act basically the treatment of
people in a huge inhuman and degrading
ways the government at the moment is
resisting that being an independent
inquiry but why not wait until that
inquiry happens and learn the lessons of
how you got into the mess at manston
before moving forward with this
legislation so we do not risk again
seeing pregnant women and unaccompanied
children in the thingies and in the dist
Devastation that he just set out why
press ahead without learning the lessons
of his previous failures well
I don't think anybody could dispute the
seriousness with which I took the
situation at manston in the Autumn or
the incomparably different situation
we're in today manston today is a
well-run facility led by a superb former
Army officer left General Lieutenant
General caps and we are ensuring that
that site is both decent and legal but
responsibility for the failures and
situation at manston in the Autumn of
last year doesn't rest with the
government it doesn't rest with the
people who work at manston it rests with
the people Smugglers and the human
traffickers it was a direct result of
thousands tens of thousands of people
coming into our country illegally in a
short period of time and I can tell the
honorable lady that the same thing will
happen again if we don't break the cycle
and stop the boats more people will come
later this year she knows that the
estimates are that numbers could rise
this year unless we take robust action
that that's what this bill is setting
out to achieve
if we take this action fewer people will
put themselves in danger fewer children
will be in this situation that's what I
want to see I think that's what the
British public want to see as well
I'm happy to give away
I'm very grateful for my right on the
phone for giving away can I on
unaccompany children could I just ask
him to address the point I raised
earlier in the debate in relation to
Clause 16 and the power that's being
given to the sector of state to remove a
child from local Authority care where
the the Secretary of State doesn't have
powers under the children act and
responsibilities that follow and what
the reasons are behind that if not in in
full now but certainly before report
stage
well I think uh the uh The Honorable
gentleman for one of a friend for that
comment uh firstly as an important aside
another issues he's raised previously
nothing in this bill
disapplies the children's act that
continues to apply in all respects with
regard to the children that we're
dealing with in this situation but to
his particular point we do take the
power so that when we come in those very
small number of judicious cases where we
set out to remove a child that we can
take them from the care of the local
Authority into the responsibility of the
home office for that short period before
they're removed from the country and the
two examples the two examples that I've
given are happily give again I know that
the honorable member for Worthing and
East and Shoreham is concerned on this
point the two examples I would give in
which we would use this power are where
we are seeking to return a young person
to their relatives in another country
and I think it's incredibly important
that we keep the ability to do so
because that does happen okay and it's
obviously the right thing to do that we
could return somebody to their mother
their father their Uncle the support
network that they have in another
country or where we are removing
somebody who's arrived as an
unaccompanied minor to another safe
country where we're confident
that they will be met on arrival by
social services and provided with all
the support that one would expect and
that happens all of the time here where
an unaccompanied mind is I think the uh
the right honorable gentleman a
mentioned from his experience as a local
Member of Parliament around Heathrow
that this does happen regularly and it's
important that we continue to have that
because we shouldn't be bringing people
into local Authority care uh for a long
period in the UK when we can safely
return them home either to their
relatives uh or to their home country
where they can be safeguarded
appropriately I'm happily
in his summing up he will respond to the
shadow leader of the house where is the
impact assessment of this bill well the
impact assessment will be published in
due course
um but let me make let me make the um
let me continue with the the points I
was making with particularly returning
to the question that was raised on a
number of occasions around our policy
for a Detention of Miners and again let
me say of course of course as a parent
we take this incredibly seriously we
don't want to detain children we have to
apply the highest moral standards when
we take this decision
but the the circumstances in which we
would use this power are where you have
an unaccompanied minor
where there is an age assessment dispute
and it's easy to dismiss that but this
is happening all the time and my
honorable friend uh the the member for
Mansfield was very uh was correct to
raise the poison his experience as a
local Authority leader in this regard
and we do have a very large number of
these disputes between 2016 and December
of last year there were 7 900 Asylum
cases where age was disputed and
subsequently resolved of which almost
half 49 were found to be adults
it would be wrong for the government to
place those people where there is a live
age assessment dispute into the same
accommodation
as those miners brought clearly children
and create safeguarding risks for them I
am not willing to do that I want to
ensure that those children are properly
protected and when I visited recently
our facilities at Western Japan asked a
member of staff there what the the
oldest person that they had encountered
who had posed as a minor was they said
that person was 41.
41 years of age does anyone in this
house seriously want to see a 41 year
old man placed with their children I
don't want to see that and that is the
circumstance in which we're going to
take and use these very judicious Powers
now if I can turn to the I'm sorry or
just before I close on this point my
right or friend the the the member for
South Holland and the deepings have
raised a number of important points in
his Amendment with respect to mandatory
scientific age assessments and I can say
to him that not only are those valid
points but the government is carefully
considering how we proceed in this
regard the UK is one of the very few
European countries that doesn't
currently employ scientific methods of
age assessment
in January the age estimation science
advisory committee published their
report on the issue the Home Secretary
and I are carefully considering its
recommendations and I hope to be in a
position to say more on the issue at
report stage
turning to the amendment that was
referenced by my honorable friend from
Stoke North and in different ways by
other members across the house regarding
the frustration that he feels and the
British public feel about the number of
Asylum Seekers currently accommodated in
hotels
it is absolutely right that we clear the
hotels as soon as possible the
government shares the frustration of the
general public it's for that reason that
the Home Secretary and I have set out
intensively to seek more sustainable
answers to this situation and we'll be
saying more on that in the coming days
the uh I'll give away one last time but
I'd like to bring my remarks to a close
assistant I I have constituents who have
been waiting for 20 months in her tail
for the home office to conduct a
substantive interview 16 months 18
months two years 40 months would you
process these people and then they would
have no need to be in hotels
well we we are doing that that is the
plan that the Prime Minister set out in
December on which we're already making
good progress but I'd say to I'd say two
further things to to the to the
honorable lady the only way to reduce
the number of people in the system is to
stop the boats it's to stop
no system
even the most efficient system in the
world could cope with 45
000 people breaking into our country
against our laws and then seeking Asylum
and and at the other and the other point
I I would make is that she knows
she knows that the way to get people out
of hotels is for all parts of the United
Kingdom to step up and provide the
accommodation that is required and her
and her SMP colleagues consistently
decline to do that
now my right or friend the member for
Kenilworth uh raised I thought a very
thoughtful and importer point
in his Amendment uh 283 relating to the
citizenship Provisions in the bill and I
I noticed concerns and we're going to
reflect on those uh and revert to him I
look forward to engaging with him but I
would I would make this point
that there is a route to entering the
United Kingdom even if at some prior
stage one had entered illegally and been
caught by the provisions of the bill
and we specifically put that in to
ensure that we continue to meet our
international law obligations he's right
to say that there is a different route
and standard with respect to achieving
citizenship
and the reason we did that was because
we believe that British citizenship is a
special privilege
and it is not something that should be
given lightly but the if someone breaks
into our country and breaches our laws
there should be a higher standard to be
applied before one gains citizenship of
our country
now
uh I'm not good I'm not going to give
away another time I'm not going to give
way to The Honorable lady
let me let me turn let me turn to let me
turn
to order
27 members have taken part in this
debate this afternoon
a rather more members present who are
speaking but who didn't take part in the
debate the 27 who were here
participating I'm aware of that
have a right to hear what the minister
has to say be good if they could do it
without interruption and that means
without interruption from either side of
the house Minister well thank you sir
Roger the The Honorable lady doesn't
like the bill she's going to vote
against the bill and she doesn't want to
stop the boats uh she's tabled a whole
raft of amendments with her colleagues
um and we all know what the purpose of
those amendments really are
her
sir it
is Sir Roger for the minister to so
misrepresent my position the amendment
side tables I tabled as chair of the
joint committee on human rights not on
behalf of the Scottish national party
and the point I wish to make is he has
not answered a single point raised by
anyone who spoke on their side of the
house it's a farce a farce order that is
an observation not a point of order yeah
The Honorable lady is fully aware
that members are responsible for their
own remarks on the record
they have to take responsibility for
that minister
yeah uh well sir Roger it's an
observation but it's also incorrect
because I've already spoken about the
many questions around children that have
been raised and before I wind up my
remarks I want to just raise or address
the issues that have been raised
regarding modern slavery uh by my right
Animal Friend for maidenhead and my rod
friend for for chingford and Woodford
green uh all of us in government look
forward to engaging with them and
learning from their unrivaled expertise
and experience in this field as we
ensure that the bill meets the standards
that we want it to do I would just say
there are a number of honorable writable
members said that there wasn't an
evidential basis for taking action it
with regard to Modern slavery I don't
think that's fair and let me just raise
a few points of clarification
when the modern slavery act in 2015 was
passed the impact assessment envisaged
three and a half thousand referrals a
year but last year there were 17
000 referrals
the most referred nationality in 2022
were citizens of Albania a safe and
developed European country a NATO Ally
and above all a signatory of the
European convention against trafficking
I'm not going to give away on this
occasion in 2021
73 of people who arrived on small boats
and were detained for removal put
forward a modern slavery claim
give way thank you
I'm grateful to my right honorable
friend for giving way and for repeating
the figures that have been set out
previously the fact that the number of
referrals to the nrm has increased does
not mean there is abuse of the system it
means actually that we may just be
recognizing more people who are in
slavery in our country and of the 73
that was 294 people and also of those
who have had their cases looked at by
the nrm nearly 90 percent are found to
be correct cases of slavery
well I I don't with great respect to the
right honorable lady I don't think it's
correct to uh to denigrate the concern
that 73 of those people who arrived on
small boats and were detained for
removal put forward a modern slavery
claim because because were we to
implement the scheme in this bill and
it's absolutely essential that we do I
think that figure suggests that a very
large number would claim modern slavery
and that would make it almost in
possible for us to proceed with this
scheme the evidence I'm afraid I'm not
going to give away because I'm going to
bring my remarks to a close I'm going to
bring my remarks to a close I'm afraid
I'm going to bring my remarks to a close
because I think I've spoken on it but
but well I will I will give away
good night
can I gently suggest to my honorable
friend that the whole purpose of raising
this issue was not to Bandy the figures
but there is a real disregard I think
for some of the real figures here my
Royal friend is quite right to say they
are concerned that there would be an
exponential rise as an alternative to
coming across illegally bear in mind
these people are trafficked that's the
key difference all we're asking them to
do is to look carefully at this and not
take the power until they can see and
show the evidence that after all the
borders bill is still yet to see the
impact so all I'm asking is gently
please just accept that they will think
about that before they come back and
Report yeah well I'm grateful to the
right Amendment and as I've said to him
previously I do look forward to
listening and engaging with him and
like-minded colleagues we do come to
this however from a serious concern that
there is mounting evidence of abuse of
this system and we want to ensure that
the scheme that we bring forward works
and that it does the job
I'm not going to give away because I'm
going to bring my remarks to a close
sir Roger
can I
[Music]
well I'll happily give away that because
I'm certainly not
uh if I would like to know from the the
immigration minister in front of me if
he says that there is mounting evidence
could he tell me which one of the
agencies was it the Border force was it
the NCA is it local authorities which of
the agencies that actually makes the
referrals for modern slavery is in
charge of the most fraudulent referrals
is it one that the home office manages
or somebody else
Minister well I'm I gave way to The
Honorable lady against my better
judgment but that's not the point that
is not the point the point it's not the
point the point is that three-quarters
of those people who are on the verge of
being removed from this country are
claiming more than slavery and that I'm
afraid is wrong and we need to bring it
to a close
thank you
with that sir Roger
um I fear I've run out of time and uh I
look forward to engaging with colleagues
across the house and in particular those
that I've referenced this evening uh and
with that I will conclude my remarks and
encourage colleagues across the house to
continue as they had before to support
this incredibly important piece of
legislation
[Applause]
does The Honorable lady wish to withdraw
sir Roger if you will allow because I
understand you can speak twice in this
committee stage it is utterly
disgraceful what we have heard from the
minister he has not presented any
evidence whatsoever to back up his
claims to back up this legislation we
have no evidence there is no evidence he
has not presented any evidence he has
not presented even so much as an impact
assessment of this legislation yet he's
he and his members opposite are about to
come out come out here and vote against
Oliver were the Amendments without a
shred without a shred of evidence to
support it he did not give the urban so
the greatest of respect to the minister
The Honorable member from Birmingham
Yardley asked for evidence and he was
unable unable or unwilling which is it
unable or unwilling to present that
evidence to this house so this house
will vote to demonize to stigmatize to
remove
victims of modern slavery and
trafficking from this country on the
basis of no evidence whatsoever this
house is I will give away in addition in
addition to the lack of evidence put
forward by the minister will my
honorable friend agree with me that he
has actually failed to put forward any
analysis and has completely failed to
engage with any of the legal analysis
that and I and others put forward in
relation to the problems this bill poses
for our obligations under the echr under
ecat and under the refugee convention
will she agree with me it's not just a
case of no evidence but also a case of
no analysis and that in fact is
downright ignorance and no way to
conduct Bill scrutiny order order
just go any further can I remind those
this is a committee stage yeah in a
committee stage members are entitled to
speak more than once
so The Honorable lady is entirely in
order in seeking to speak to the house
again
and the house has until 8 20 to complete
this debate
so much sir Soldier for clarifying that
and I'm sure other honorable members may
find this of interest as well because at
this committee stage usually a bill
would go upstairs it would be
scrutinized line by line every one of
the over 150 amendments that we have had
to this bill would have been discussed
would have had the opportunity to be
voted on would have scrutinized the
minister in significant detail on each
and every one of those amendments and we
would have had it properly discussed in
this house if it had to work to get this
bill through the house if it had gone
upstairs to committee rather than being
discussed in this farceable process this
afternoon what is also important to
understand for those that are watching
this at home is that no evidence has
been taken on this bill usually when we
would go upstairs to a bill committee we
would be allowed to take evidence from
experts in this field and the experts in
this field have done their absolute
utmost sir Roger to get that evidence to
us I am holding in front of me some of
just some of the evidence I have
received from organizations which I have
tried to present in the many amendments
I brought to this bill
all right and now I do have to call The
Honorable lady to order
because she's making a general speech
she's well aware of the fact that there
are a series of amendments that are
under discussion rather than a second
reading General debate so perhaps you
now like to come back to the Amendments
under discussion
I thank him very much and we'll be glad
to go back to the topics of the bill
um because there is at the back of this
schedule which may be of interest to
members here a list of 57 different
countries and in this list of 57
different countries we have countries
where people are known to be trafficked
from intersex slavery in this country
the Republic of Albania is the first on
this list and we know because the
evidence the actual evidence supports it
that there are people being trafficked
here women being trafficked you to this
country to be held in in facilities
where the rate repeatedly by men those
women will not be able to go and ask for
safety because if they do so they will
be putting themselves at risk of being
deported to Rwanda and traffickers as we
know will hold that over these women it
will be a threat it is a traffickers
charter this bill
this list of um 57 countries at the back
of this bill as well
I had a look through the Human Rights
Watch country profiles on some of these
countries which the which the ministers
deem are safe countries to which people
can be removed and I had a long
conversation with rainbow sisters about
this as well about the difficulties uh
that a lesbian and bisexual women will
find in being returned to these
countries
men also are mentioned in here and it
says within the bill Gambia and respect
to men Ghana in respect of men Kenya and
respect to men Liberia and respective
men Malawi and respect to Maine and
Nigeria in respect of men so men can't
be removed to these countries but in the
cases of Gambia Jamaica Kenya Liberia
Liberia
Malawi Mauritius Nigeria and Sierra
Leone which are in here all of these
countries Outlaw same-sex relations all
of these countries Outlaw same sex
relations but ministers are not going to
ask when somebody arrives in a dinghy or
if somebody arrives on a plane or
however they arrive in this country
they're not going to ask anything about
the circumstances of these people
they're quite simply going to put them
on a plane and send them back if they
can and if they can't they will be in
limbo in this country forever because
they have no means of removing them too
I will
happy to give away and I'm sure there
are lots of members in the house that
will be listening to what she's saying
and lots of people watching at home who
will want to continue the line by line
scrutiny of this bill and the time that
is available by the order agreed to uh
by the house she mentions Malawi for
example I'm very proud to chair uh the
all-party Parliamentary group on Malawi
but isn't this precisely the point that
the individual circumstance of any
Asylum Seeker that come here that comes
here needs to be assessed you can't
arbitrarily make decisions about
individuals because you don't know their
individual cases but what this bill what
the Clauses in this bill do and and what
the schedule that she's talking about
does is order
I know that this measure arouses strong
opinions
but we do have a process in this house
we do have to stick to the amendments
there are no amendments to the schedule
and The Honorable gentleman was not
referring so far as I can see to any
Amendment so can we please now confine
in the remaining stages of this session
our arguments to what is on the order
paper and what is not not what is not on
the order beta Alison Thomas yes I'm
certainly within that section The
Honorable member would be referring to
Amendment 191 which talks about and
there's a reveal risk of persecution or
serious harm on the grounds of sexual
orientation if removed in accordance
with this section which is close to page
2 line 33 and we would like to insert
that into the bill because we think that
this is important we think that people's
individual rights and risks
ought to be assessed by this government
but they are not being assessed by this
government they are not looking at
individual risk and it's interesting to
me to find Nigeria on this this list
because lgbtq people uh being returned
to Nigeria are
at significant risk Nigeria topped a
danger index of countries for LGBT
people and men would boost the death
penalty by stoning women would face
whipping and imprisonment if they were
found to be LGBT so the very real risk
that we are trying to prevent by our
amendment to this section would be to
prevent people being returned to these
countries and Jamaica I know also is
number 18 on seem dangerous but it is
listed here as a country that the Home
Secretary is perfectly happy to return
LGBT people to to an uncertain future
where they would be outlawed from living
their life and expressing the rights
that they have
so Roger there are many aspects many
amendments of this bill that we could
talk to because they are all all of this
bill an assault on human rights
we believe that the human rights should
belong to everybody sir Roger it
shouldn't be that the Home Secretary
gets to deny them to a group of people
just because of how they happened to
arrive in this country because we know
that there are many people that will
flee very dangerous circumstances we
will try to reunite with family members
who are already here
it might be the very last person you
know in your family that is alive you
could have seen the rest of your family
killed in front of you and have an uncle
here in the UK but if you cannot get
here by any other safer legal rights to
that until to that last remaining family
member as is referred to in our
amendments then how possibly will you be
able to live your life we are
sentencing people to a life in limb
while if they will no longer be able to
live and the government has not thought
through the full consequences of this
bill what will happen to these people
that are forever left in limbo I want to
mention also Amendment 246 within you as
well because this is our amendment that
says it can only put these things
forward with the consent of the
well-centered with the Scottish
Parliament or the Northern Ireland
assembly because the government will not
get legislative consent for these
measures and I have a letter signed by a
significant number of members of the
Scottish Parliament as well sir Roger
who do not give consent for this who do
not accept this bill who do not think
this bill is something that they want to
see it is an affront to our human rights
in Scotland sir Roger it is not the kind
of country that we wish to build and I
was very proud indeed to see alhamdul
Youssef as our new first minister in
Scotland
family
I'm here
order
let's try again let I'm sorry the new
first minister of Scotland however
honorable he may be is not part of this
legislation
now with the honorable lady please stick
to the Amendments that are on the order
paper
otherwise I shall have to ask her to
take her place
the only person to the Amendments we we
have put here because he
because hamza's grandparents came here
as immigrants I
family find their way here and that is
true of many people in this country who
came here and have made some of them
have ended up as legislators in this
place and are drawing the ladder up
behind them Hamza has made it incredibly
clear that how grateful he is that he
has this opportunity that his
grandparents could not have imagined
that when they came to the UK with very
little with no money in their pocket
that they could work their way up
through at society and that their
grandson could aspire to achieve the
highest position in Scotland to be the
first minister of Scotland so instead of
demonizing immigrants instead of
demonizing the people that come to this
country instead of saying to people like
no father that they would not get to
come here in future instead of doing
that we should listen to the experience
of people who have come here have made
their lives here we should thank those
people for what they have contributed we
should thank them for doing is the honor
of choosing to come to this country and
making their home and making their life
here
just when we don't recognize that
contribution when ministers pull the
ladder up behind them when they prevent
people from coming here it makes this
country poorer not just economically of
course horrible afraid for giving away
isn't that the importance of amendment
189 which is her Amendment and which is
the lead amendment that we're discussing
today she said that she humanized each
of the Amendments that she's tabled and
she gave them different names she said
perhaps 189 should be called tobias's
Amendment because it's to specifically
exempt Afghan Asylum Seekers and
shouldn't every conservative member who
got up today and express their outrage
at the way that Asylum Afghan Refugee
the Asylum Seekers are being treated in
this country shouldn't they all be
expected to join us in the lobby shortly
in about half an hour's fight when we
reach the knife shouldn't they be
expected to join us in the lobby in
voting for Amendment 189. they should
indeed an amendment 189 recognizes not
just the plight of Afghans who are
facing a terrible situation
but it also recognizes the contribution
of Afghans it recognizes the
contribution of Afghans like Abdul
bastani a councilor in Glasgow who came
here as a refugee and now represents the
city of Glasgow it also recognizes the
contribution of people like sabir zazai
the chief executive of the Scottish
Refugee Council who came here as a child
in the back of a lorry he would be
demonized he would be removed to Amanda
if he came here in similar circumstances
under this bill
of course
thinking that uh Xavier zazi has been
awarded with an order or a merit of the
British Empire that's what Asylum
Seekers can achieve in this country if
they're allowed to flourish that's what
our amen order order order
honorable members are in danger of
abusing the house
I am being scrupulously fair and trying
to ensure that everything that is said
remains in order
The Honorable gentleman was out of order
with the honorable lady please conclude
her remarks so the minister if he wishes
to May respond
and we then move to the divisions
thank you very much but with reference
to uh Amendment 189 and the contribution
of Afghans sabios as I tells a story of
when he was given a letter from the home
office which he said said you're a
person liable to be detained and removed
more recently a celebration to mark his
awarding of an Obe he said he got he got
a different letter which said that he
was being awarded this great honor of
the British State he said he was going
to go and put those two letters on the
wall next to one another
because it really shows that regardless
of the circumstances by which you came
to these islands
that there ought to be nothing that you
can't achieve
there ought to be but this bill before
us
pulls up the drawbridge it makes this
country smaller it makes this country
meaner it makes this country crueler and
it means that forever sabiers
for every person that Tobias The
Honorable member for uh Bournemouth East
is outraged about
people can come here and make a
contribution they can live a dull boring
ordinary life they could be an Obe they
could be the first minister of a country
but they have a contribution to make and
they deserve to get to meet that
contribution without the UK government
pulling up that drawbridge and seeing
that people are unwelcome obviously take
care of them I'm very grateful to my
honorable friends and I was just on
Amendment 189 about Afghan citizens it
really is
um striking the veterans Minister this
this afternoon saying that that there
are no safe routes for Afghans to come
to this country Afghans who have
protected many of us in terms of the
citizens but also in terms of our armed
forces and we have there are no safe
routes for them to come come don't you
think that that's an absolute disgrace
given the promises that were made to
them in 2021. yes yes I absolutely agree
with her and I sat through many phone
calls with ministers at the time and
with constituents at the time who were
terrified for their family members many
of them still don't know if they will
get to safety at all despite having
applied through the process they are
waiting with an uncertain future in
Afghanistan for their lives are threats
where their daughters can't go into
education where they're being pursued by
the Taliban day in and day out so the
point of Afghans within this bill is
particularly serious but there are other
nationalities as well that you could
equally see Iraqis who helped support
British forces other people from other
countries where Britain has a footprint
because many people come here because of
the footprint that Britain has had in
the world and we have a particular
responsibility to those people and
there's the Afghan interpreters have
used the phrase and the exhibition that
they gave we are here because you were
there
and that speaks also to the legacy of
Empire the legacy of the English
language Legacy in Britain around the
world and that is why people seek to
come here and I believe I believe very
firmly that we have a gity and a
responsibility two people around the
world this government renege on that
responsibility that's what this world
that what this bill is all about and the
real fear that I have is that having
seen Britain do this that other
countries will draw up the bridge to
they'll pull up the drawbridge too that
they will reneg on their International
obligations because they say well if
Britain can do it other countries can do
it too Britain won't stand up for human
rights why do we need to bother if
Britain doesn't stand up for the refugee
convention well why should we if Britain
doesn't stand up for the UN convention
the rights of the child why should we
bother either let's get children back
into into slavery and be trafficked all
over the place because this government
this government is not protecting
children here that's why we have these
amendments because we seek to protect
people who are being trafficked and
exploited this government by ignoring
the Amendments that we are putting
forwards sir Roger seeks to refuse
people that protection that human
dignity those rights that they have
under International obligations when we
have those rights we have those rights
because of this the things that we have
done in the past we should no longer
have to put up with this government
Scotland needs Independence because he
can't trust this government
respond
does The Honorable lady wish to withdraw
her Amendment
order
does The Honorable lady wish to withdraw
her Amendment
six
you wish to put it to the vote
well with the honorable lady like to
move
being moved does she wish to put it to a
division
[Music]
is it your pleasure that the amendment
be withdrawn
[Music]
and then by leave withdrawal
Amendment 189 has been chosen for a
separate division
foolish to move the amendment formally
move formally the question is amendment
189 be made as many are that opinion say
I
the country no
clear the lobby
the question is that Amendment 189 be
made as many of that opinions say aye
aye country no no tell us for the eyes
Marion fellows Gavin Newland tell us for
the nose Julie Martin and Mike Wood
foreign
universe
thank you
Enterprise
review
[Music]
foreign
um
thank you
all right
um
what's up
[Music]
questions
foreign
look for those
here